northwest
suite 650
washington dc
2001
or call us at area code
of authors 202-626-4898 hemingway and f
scott fitzgerald
scott donaldson's book hemingway versus
fitzgerald traces the similarities of
their lives and a friendship which
helped launch ernest hemingway's
literary career
last month mr donaldson was at a
bookstore in saint paul minnesota to
compare and contrast the two writers and
to talk about some of the other literary
figures who played a role in their lives
this discussion lasts about 45 minutes
well good evening again thank you for
coming out on such a snowy night um
we are very very happy to have scott
donaldson here with us tonight
this is quite an honor and i'm again i'm
really thankful that people
checked out because i know it's
treacherous outside
mr donaldson is a native minnesotan he
grew up in south minneapolis he was a
reporter for the minneapolis star and
then he moved on to be an editor at the
bloomington sun
following his career in journalism he
returned to academia and taught at the
college of william mary for 26 years
he is the recognized prominent scholar
on hemingway and fitzgerald
his books have included by force of will
i don't know if people can hear me kind
of straining with the flu
i think it's on i think i'm too short
his previous books include by force of
will
the life and art of ernest hemingway
fool for love f scott fitzgerald john
chivera biography
and archibald macleish in american life
which won the ambassador award for
biography in 1993.
in hemingway versus fitzgerald the rise
and fall of a literary friendship mr
mcdonald fuses his knowledge of both
these writers lives to provide a
portrait of what their lives and their
writing meant to each other
mr donaldson mr donaldson's examination
of the synergy that existed between
these writers as well as the demise of
their relationship allows fans of
hemingway and fitzgerald to see their
lives and their work through a different
lens
michael reynolds author of hemingway the
final years has said this about
hemingway versus fitzgerald
donaldson distills a lifetime of
research to tell the story of scott and
ernest whose lives and times define
modern american writing
told with style grace and clarity
hemingway versus fitzgerald is a model
for a compelling biography should be
well thank you for coming and thank you
for coming
thank you
[Applause]
it's it's nice to be here and back in
the twin cities although we flew in
today from phoenix where the weather was
different
um
what i thought i'd do is uh
read you a couple pieces from the book
the first is about the first meeting
between fitzgerald and hemingway and the
second one will be about the
the one ugliest thing that hemingway did
to break up the friendship
so the first meeting now were in april
1925 and
this is tries to be a scene of sorts
after a good day's work at his craft in
paris ernest hemingway joined a couple
of completely worthless characters for a
drink in the evening dank of the
bardingo and montpernace
his companions warming up for the
revelries of the night were lady duff
twistin whom he was half in love with
and pat guthrie the scotsman she was
supposed to marry
these two people were to appear without
much disguise and the sun also rises but
this was late april 1925 and the trip to
pamplona
ruined by sexual jealousy over duffs
amours the crucial event that informed
that novel still lay months ahead
after a while hemingway would walk the
half dozen blocks home to his wife
hadley and son bumby in their apartment
above the sawmill on the rue notre dame
de champs
but for the present he was having a fine
time absorbing the latest gossip with
his clever
and entertainingly self-deprecatory
if worthless friends
went in walked two men who first got to
know each other in princeton
one of these the one hemingway took a
liking to was a tall and pleasant fellow
named dunk chaplin who had been a famous
pitcher in college and who seemed
extraordinarily nice
unworried relaxed and friendly
the other who came right over to
introduce himself and chaplain was scott
fitzgerald
in contrast to chaplin fitzgerald was
rather effeminate a man as hemingway
wrote
who looked like a boy with a face
between handsome and pretty
his most striking feature was his long
lipped mouth that on a girl would have
been the mouth of a beauty
the mouth worried hemingway he wrote and
he was put off too by fitzgerald's
excessive flattery and interrogation
had hemingway slept with his wife before
they were married
fitzgerald aston
i don't know hemingway replied i don't
remember
but the most memorable event of that
first meeting as it's described in a
removable feast was that as they drank
the champagne fitzgerald had ordered all
the coloring left his face and it turned
into a true death's head before
hemingway's eyes no need to worry
chaplin reassured hemingway as he
ushered the comatose fitzgerald into a
taxi cab that's the way it takes him
at this stage in the memoir that
hemingway wrote beginning in 1957 32
years after he first met fitzgerald and
17 years after scott fitzgerald's death
chaplain disappears
he has done his job as a foil a likable
fellow against whom fitzgerald's
shortcomings are measured
and is no longer needed for the rest of
the three devastating chapters of a
mobile feast devoted to fitzgerald
chaplin is replaced by another character
whose behavior stands in implicit
juxtaposition to that of poor scott a
hungry hard-working happily married
young writer totally dedicated to his
profession who can hold his liquor and
will not allow himself to waste time or
money
that character of course was ernest
hemingway
there was another good reason for
chaplin to vanish from hemingway's
account of his first meeting with
fitzgerald chaplin was not there without
the dingo not in paris not in europe
hemingway invented him in all his
authoritative specificity to lend an air
of authenticity to the story
this does not mean we should distrust
everything hemingway says about
fitzgerald in a movable feast as he
warns us in the preface to that book
the book might be regarded as fiction
but there's also the chance he adds
immediately that such a book of fiction
may throw some light on what has been
written as fact
here hemingway implies that his
rendition reveals more of the truth than
any straightforward reportorial version
and in a sense he's right
readers of a mobile feast can learn a
great deal about fitzgerald especially
about hemingway in spite of or because
of the fictional liberties that the
author takes were the facts
at the same time however it should be
recognized that hemingway's memoir of
the years in paris is far more reliable
about his feelings toward fitzgerald in
the late 1950s than in the mid-1920s
when they first met and became extremely
close friends
at the time they met fitzgerald was much
the better known and more established
writer
he was the author of three novels his
master the great gatsby had just been
published
and two volumes of stories several of
which had initially appeared in the high
pain saturday evening post
in those stories and those novels his
characters drank and smoked and necked
in open defiance
of the older generation
and so did scott and zelda fitzgerald
themselves as if determined to become
public examples of the flappers and
cheeks in his fiction
living in and around new york
they dwindled into celebrities
as the newspapers eagerly recorded their
exploits most notably a midnight dip in
the fountain outside the plaza hotel
they came to europe in the spring of
1924 in order to escape the frantic
partying
but geography could not alter
fitzgerald's public image for the rest
of his life
and beyond
he fought vainly to shake off his
lightweight reputation as a chronicler
of the jazz age
hemingway on the other hand have been
based in paris since the end of 1921.
he began as a feature writer for the
toronto star weekly with all of europe
as his beat
and returned briefly to canada for the
birth of his son in october 1923 he gave
up journalism at the beginning of 1924
in order to devote himself entirely to
fiction
but at the time they met hemingway had
published nothing to book length
and only a handful of stories and poems
in little magazines and two slim volumes
printed in france in limited editions
hemingway was 25 and they met fitzgerald
28
but despite his relative use youth
earnest had lived a far more adventurous
life than scott
in contrast to fitzgerald's stateside
service in the u.s army for example
uh ernest had volunteered to serve in
italy with the american red cross where
he was seriously wounded and decorated
by the italian army
then later in europe as a newspaper man
he interviewed many of the great figures
of the time including lloyd george
clemaso mussolini
during his years overseas he had also
become friendly with such distinguished
modernist writers as gertrude stein ford
medics ford ezra pound
over six feet tall a sturdy 190 pounds
and darkly handsome he formed a striking
contrast to the slightly built blonde
fitzgerald who stood five feet eight
inches and weighed about 140 pounds
and there was unmistakable charisma
about ernest hemingway's young man as
his wife hadley recalled in those days
men loved him women loved him
children loved him
even dogs loved him
but men most of all
for hemingway had a remarkable gift for
inspiring and later breaking off male
friendships
the two writers had a number of things
in common besides being close together
in age both with midwesterners
fitzgerald from st paul hemingway from
the chicago suburb of oak park
and both it spent middle class boyhoods
dreaming of the kind of overnight
success dramatized in the fiction of a
racial alger
like most male american writers both had
strong mothers and comparatively
ineffectual fathers
both have been jilted by their first
great loves
and both that survived that rite of
passage to mary and father child
but there are crucial differences
between them as well fitzgerald's
socially ambitious family had sent him
first to country day school sba
and then east to a catholic prep school
and then to three years at princeton
while hemingway was finishing public
high school in oak park the end of his
formal education
but fitzgerald was socially and
psychologically insecure and
particularly inept at developing
relationships with male companions his
tendency was to make heroes out of his
male friends often to the discomfort of
them both
there was every good reason for
fitzgerald to make a hero out of
hemingway because he'd been through the
war and he'd been wounded he'd been
decorated
and he admired how many ways learned
capacities he put it to face down fear
ernest was given to exaggerating
somewhat the extent of his military
background he he used to say he'd fought
with a crack italian rdt
which is not quite the same thing as
driving an ambulance for the american
red cross
and similarly he pretended to expertise
in athletic endeavors that went beyond
the actual case as a run-of-the-mill
football lineman in high school
still
fitzgerald was never shake able to shake
off what he called his two juvenile
regrets
not playing football at princeton and
not getting overseas during the war
he used to conjure up dreams of glory
quote once upon a time they needed a
quarterback at princeton i weigh only
135 so they saved me until the third
quarter
or
quote the headquarters staff and the
regimental battalion commanders have
been killed with a single shell the
command evolved upon captain fitzgerald
with superb presence
it seemed to him that hemingway had
achieved what he could only dream about
and then the consequences he would be
forever disadvantaged as a writer
hemingway was inclined to
agree the reason you're so sore about
missing the war he wrote fitzgerald in
december 1925 is because war is the best
subject
it groups the maximum of material
and speeds up the action and brings out
all sorts of stuff that normally you
would have to wait a lifetime to get
fitzgerald came to admire hemingway for
his discipline and dedication to his
craft as well as for his military and
athletic exploits
and adopted in him as what he called his
artistic conscience in the krakow
according to arnold gingrich the esquire
editor who persuaded both men to write
for his fledgling magazine during the
1930s fitzgerald was quote so gone on
earnest from the beginning
that the degree of his admiration was as
among grown men
almost embarrassing
okay
so there's the first meeting and um
in the story of their friendship
it goes to a number of stages the first
stage lasting about a year and a half
they were extraordinarily close
and fitzgerald forged those bonds by
doing hemingway a great many favors he
loaned them money
which is not the least of them but he
also
managed to persuade him to switch
publishers and help to orchestrate the
switch to uh
to maxwell perkins as his editor at
scribners
he uh did a
considerable um
to chemicals considerable benefit
he managed to to get him to uh to alter
the beginning of the sun also rises to
to cut out nearly 4 000 words at the
beginning of the book
which if they had been left in would
have damaged the book considerably
he wrote articles praising hemingway he
tried to get others to write articles
praising hemingway he made it a kind of
a
full-time project to sort he wasn't
writing much of his own after he
finished gatsby so for about a year and
a half he did almost everything any
human being could do for furnace
hemingway
they were
extraordinarily close
then
an ocean intervened between them for
much of the the next uh
decade
uh and they kept touched by way of
correspondence and through the
intermediary particularly through the
intermediary of maxwell perkins who was
put in the position of trying to
calm down and any uh
any storms that rose in their friendship
and and to keep them both happy with
each other and with their own selves as
writers
um the friendship effectively made
came to a close it seems to me it in the
late 30s
um and the cruelest cut of all was
administered in in august 1936 in the
snows of kilimanjaro which is published
in esquire magazine for for that for
that date
and that same issue by the way
fitzgerald had published an article
called afternoon of an author in which
he portrays himself
as innervated and barely able to get up
in the morning and uh only mastering is
is inertia to get downtown to to get
himself shaved at a barber shop and to
come home to take a nap but not to be
able to write anything that day so
that's fitzgerald's contribution to the
august 1936 esquire if it's hemingway's
contribution was this great story this
knows of kilimanjaro
in which
um he is saying
indirectly to scott what he thought
about
fitzgerald had been writing in esquire
generally not just the afternoon the
author of peace but earlier in that year
in 1936 the three crack up essays in
which for fitzgerald portrays himself
as a diminished human being no no longer
able to to write as he once had
he describes himself as a cracked plate
all right to keep leftovers in in the
refrigerator
not sufficient to be used to be brought
out for company
it's it's a
it's a confession of
a failure of what he called a legion of
vitality of what he called his emotional
bankruptcy
hemingway thought those essays were
deplorable and in stones of kilimanjaro
in a way he's letting him know how he
felt
in a public declaration that breached
the boundaries of personal and
professional
courtesy and effectively
shattered the cracked plate of their
friendship
this passage occurring midway through
the story
recorded the thoughts of the narrator
snows of kilimanjaro about the rich
it's a famous anecdote
they were dull and drank too much or
they played too much backgammon
they were dull and they were repetitious
he remembered poor scott fitzgerald and
his romantic awe of them and how he'd
started the story once that began
the very rich are different from you and
me
and how someone remember that how
someone had said to scott yes they have
more money
but that was not humorous to scott he
thought they were a special glamorous
race and when he found out they weren't
it wrecked him as much as any other
thing that wrecked him
well
so he's writing out fitzgerald um and
this this heartless passage derives from
two sources the first was fitzgerald's
own story the rich boy
where his narrator expounds on the
situation of the very rich as a group
let me tell you about the very rich
fitzgerald had written in that story
or his narrator had
they are different from you and me
they possess and enjoy early and it does
something to that makes them soft where
we are hard and cynical where we are
trustful in a way that unless you were
born rich is very difficult to
understand they think deep in their
hearts they are better than we are
even when they enter deep into our world
or sink below us they still think they
are better than we are
they are different
the other source
unattributed was a luncheon that
hemingway and max perkins had had in new
york with the quick-witted irish writer
murray column
ernest began talking about his contacts
with the wealthy folk in bimini
bart baker's is back from there
who fished and partied off their yachts
he was getting to know the rich he said
the only difference between the rich and
other people mary callum told him is
that the rich have more money
this remark rather belittled hemingway
who had been waxing expansive about
knowing the rich
in the snows of kilimanjaro he
transferred the foot down to fitzgerald
upon reading this knows that kilimanjaro
and esquire which he could hardly help
bringing out a piece of his own same
magazine
um
fitzgerald objected once in a brief
letter to hemingway dear earnest please
lay off me in print
if i choose to write day profundus
sometimes it doesn't mean i want my
friends praying aloud over my corpse
no doubt you meant it kindly
but it cost me a night's sleep
only one night i'm tougher than you
think
and when you incorporate the story in a
book would you mind cutting my name
it's a fine story one of your best and
absolutely true about that and generous
of them to mention it
even though the poor scott fitzgerald
rather spoiled it for me ever your
friend scott
p.s riches have never fascinated me
unless combined with the greatest charm
or distinction
hemingway replied to this letter but his
response alas has been lost or destroyed
fitzgerald said that in his response
ernest had rather resentfully agreed to
omit his
met his scots name when the story was
republished in a book
hemi white also commented scott said
that since fitzgerald had been exposing
his private life so shamelessly in the
crack up essays he figured it was quote
open season unquote on in
okay did fitzgerald think of the very
rich as a special glamorous race and why
did ernest determine all of a sudden
that this was one of the things that
wrecked scott
earlier he had been attributing
fitzgerald's troubles as a writer to a
number of causes in letters to perkins
and others
among these causes zelda was jealous of
his work and tried to emasculate him
scott could not control his drinking
he wrote slop for money
he was stalled by critical overpraise in
the sense that he must write
masterpieces
he couldn't think he didn't listen
he fell in love with the idea of failure
he loved youth so much he never grew up
and so on
but it snows of kilimanjaro for the
first time hemingway cited fitzgerald's
romantic awe
of the rich as yet another principal
cause of his crack up
context helps to explain why
the stones of kilimanjaro tells the
story of harry a failed writer and of
his rich wife helen and marion helen the
writer chose security and comfort over
his career and what happened to him was
subsequently was very much like what
happened to fitzgerald's dick diver
in tenders the night or had happened to
him a few years before the two years
before
when that novel was published
harry and the snows of killing jarrah
like dick diver fell into a pattern of
too much drinking and too much travel
and not enough work
in africa on safari with his wife as
ernest napoleon hemingway had been in
1933 harry contracts gangrene and dies
after thinking back on all the stories
he had not written and
evoking how the glorious days in paris
the rotting away of harry's leg
symbolizes the rot in his soul
as much as any story ever written the
snows of kilimanjaro still illustrates
exactly how the very rich are different
from other people and how they can wreck
writers
and it clearly represents a cautionary
tale that hemingway was directing at
himself
harry the writer rather cynically
reflects as ernest must have done after
leaving his first wife hadley for the
wealthier pauline that he had traded on
his talent
quote it was strange too wasn't it that
when he fell in love with another woman
that woman should always have more money
than the last one
unquote
in singling out fitzgerald as a writer
destroyed by admiration for the rich
hemingway was transferring the guilt
implicit in his own story
in doing so moreover hemingway chose to
ignore what scott had written on the
subject in the second crack up essay
fitzgerald thinks back to the summer of
1919
when zelda sarah threatened to close out
their engagement on the basis of common
sense
it was one of those tragic loves doomed
for lack of money fitzgerald had written
and though he wrote a novel and so it
came out all right
it came out all right for a different
person
the man who married the girl in the
spring of 1920 would always cherish an
abiding distrust and animosity toward
the leisure class not the conviction of
a revolutionist but the smoldering
hatred
of a peasant
since that time fitzgerald had never
been able to stop thinking as he wrote
that at one time a sort of dwat de senor
might have been exercised to give one of
his rich friends
his girl
so he always distrusted the rich yet he
worked for money to share their mobility
and the grace that some of them brought
into his lives
brought into their lives
the fact is that both hemi wayne
fitzgerald were simultaneously attracted
to and repelled by the world of the very
rich in fact hemingway in his later
years
spent more time with him with the very
rich than fitzgerald ever did he used to
say that he understood they inhabited a
different world
but he maintained to his friend buck
lanham for example that he could go into
their country as he could go into any
foreign country and emerge unscathed
getting hemingway to remove the phrase
poor scott fitzgerald from the souls of
kilimanjaro was not as easy as
fitzgerald might have thought or is that
max perkins assured him it would be
for of course fitzgerald
media put immediately put max on notice
that his name should come out when when
the book was published of hemingway's
stories he did not want forza scott
fitzgerald in it
and so there are a series of letters
from fitzgerald to to perkins remind him
and i remember ernest said he was going
to take out my name he's going to change
the name
not to worry uh perkins wrote back in
march 1937 he'd spoken to earnest a
while before and his feelings toward
fitzgerald were far different what you
seem to suspect
ernest had some queer notion perkins
wrote that the reference and snows would
give scott a jolt and be good for him
anyhow he means to take it out
thanks for the word about ernest scott
replied me thinks he does protest too
much
a year later fitzgerald took up the
issue once more for in the fall of 1938
was planned to publish hemingway's first
49 stories that is the large collected
hemingway stories that until a few years
ago was was the standard edition of the
stories
do keep in mind that he has promised to
make an illusion of my name he wrote
perkins it was a damn rotten thing to do
and with anybody but earnest my tendency
would be to crack back
why did he think it would add to the
strength of his story if i had become
such a negligible figure
but when hemingway's amended copy for
the book came in late in august 1938
it simply reduced poor scott fitzgerald
to poor scott
mild protest perkins wrote back so he
elaborated be better if his name could
come out altogether
if people did not recognize scott as
fitzgerald though he's identified as a
writer in the following sentence it
might might as well be some other name
and if they did so identify might take
them out of the story and get get them
thinking about fitzgerald instead of the
story
he'd shown the passage to two other
people max said who thought scott might
feel bad about it being very sensitive
it would be good if his name could come
out
but as perkins wrote they he and ernest
could talk about it when hemingway came
in to see him in scribner's offices in
the week ahead
at that meeting
perkins had his way and hemingway agreed
to take scott out
and to replace him with julian so poor
scott fitzgerald became poor julian and
so remains and all printed copies of the
snows of kilimanjaro
julian by the way the name of the
alcoholic and suicidal protagonist of
john o'hara's 1934 novel the appointment
appointment at samara
in order to keep the peace perkins never
told fitzgerald the ernest halfway
measure
of changing before scott fitzgerald to
poor scott
in september one letter he simply wrote
one of the news stories
in the book of collected stories is this
knows of kilimanjaro and you are not in
it
as if to suggest there'd been no trouble
at all to get rid of his name
now one of the interesting things about
this anecdote is is that
it's become a legend of sorts
and that the exchange of the very rich
that a legend about the supposed
exchange of
views about the very rich between
fitzgerald and hemingway has become an
apocryphal part of literary history
you'll remember
that in the stores of kilimanjaro
hemingway had not written
well he had not read that he responded
yes they have more money someone
had said that to fitzgerald
so but when hemingway won when
fitzgerald was putting together
his notebooks and he kept extensive
notebooks and
and uh edmond wilson
when he uh collected things in the crack
up and other and essays and notes
uh included a number of those notes
including one in which fitzgerald had
commented had written
they have more money comma
ernest wisecrack
period
now wilson
was fitzgerald's mentor and friend
although
not always
his best friend because i think wilson
undervalued fitzgerald as a writer and
always thought of him as considerably
superior to him as an intellect
explained that remark in a footnote
wilson in that footnote which you can
find in your copy of the crack up if you
have one
wilson incorrectly explained that
fitzgerald had said that rich are
different from us and hemingway had
replied yes they have more money
so that's the way we know the story
right we all know a story lionel
trilling repeated that story harry levin
repeated that story it's come down to us
in a number of forms so we all know that
fitzgerald said this and hemingway said
that
and
that's uh that's the way of literary
legends there was such a discussion
and hemi wade said the rich are
different from why
you and me and and mary collum had said
yes they have more money to hemingway
and it was not that was the way it was
and it was not hemingway putting down
fitzgerald and even in snows to do them
justice hemingway did not claim credit
for yes they have the more money line
but in the construction of legends truth
can hardly compete with fiction
um
okay well i thought that would give you
a flavor of some of the things in the
book and uh
i assume a number of you out there are
hemingway fitzgerald fans and
uh interested in
putting questions or comments and i'd be
delighted to take a couple so
whatever you like to do yeah i have a
simple question sure
what
hemingway's
is
and where did he come from or where did
he meet
well
i spoke i spoke of two wives he had four
wives
his first his first wife was hadley whom
he divorced in order to marry pauline
and pauline had more money so that's
that's the point i was trying to make
about them and then there were two other
wives later
ernest always had
the subsequent wife in the wings as the
last act of the previous marriage is
being played out you know so
so you would never have to be unmarried
for long
a um friendship
from from matt buckley's well matt's got
two books on those and they're both
collections of documents and then uh
i've tried to supply some interpretation
and to supply some story and uh
he calls his books documentary
reconstructions and that's what they are
and uh
so there is that considerable difference
and i've also done a number of things
that by way background by way of
bouncing them off other people
that that he didn't do using a lot of
correspondence with other folks
so there are a lot of differences
yeah
yeah
did hemingway acknowledge the health
that destroyed him and what was wrong
with that 4 000 page
about 4 000 words yeah
yeah
life work right yeah
um
well for first part uh uh diddy
acknowledged
fitzgerald's help but no no he found it
very difficult to do that and
in fact tended to minimize the help and
uh
um
and and the interesting thing about it
is the fitzgerald did not take credit
for that well while ernest was while
they were both alive either so he did
not want to offend ernest by claiming to
have done so much for him
uh and there's a letter to from
fitzgerald to john o'hara in which he
minimizes
what he had done and he had done
that done done a substantial service to
fitzgerald what's wrong with those four
thousand words is they're chatty and
they're in the mode of a kind of
here's a view of of paris
and a kind of wise guy tone
that hemingway was
want to adopt when he when he was
writing the
pieces for the toronto star weekly a
certain element of sarcasm operating
there
and it's it's it's it's very uh
it's very uh
lightweight it begins this is a story
about a lady and her name is lady ashley
and
and
and this begins in spring and and we're
in paris in the spring and then and
paris is nice in the spring you know it
goes on like that it's it's it's really
not good so yeah yeah
did you find
in hemingway's
clear that
this daryl would
last longer
um
well the question is did i find direct
evidence that hemingway thought gatsby
was going to last longer than anything
he wrote and
no i don't know any direct evidence
about that particular point but there's
plenty of evidence that hemingway was
one of the most rivalrous people who
ever lived and uh and this certainly
drove his feelings about fitzgerald and
about william faulkner and about other
writers who were coming up like the the
writers of the the 50s about
norman mailer james jones people writing
about the war
he
he could not abide having competition
and without trying to put them down and
of course he was you know
he's a great writer uh but but uh he's
he's also was
a compulsive competitor
yeah
yeah what was the most fascinating
yeah yeah
that's a good question um
i i guess um
you go back and you look at stuff um
that you don't think other people have
looked at and you know you that's what
you're looking at that's what you're
always looking for you know and i
suppose going back
i'll bounce bounce that around a ways
when hemingway is writing a movable
feast
his then wife his fourth wife uh mary uh
said
this this doesn't seem to be really
about you it's it's about all these
other people and he says well it's like
high lie
it's it's bounce you're bouncing off
walls
and uh
and so i'm i'm really telling about
myself as i'm
well in effect as i'm demolishing
fitzgerald as i'm diminishing gertrude
stein as i'm making fun of of ford
medics ford i'm telling you something
about myself in opposition to them in a
way
so it was that kind of thing looking
into
the correspondence of people you would
not suspect
said stuff about it and
this led me to some pretty strange names
of folks that that who probably wouldn't
resonate very well on c-span but uh you
do you do find find things in in remote
places and
um
well it's simply a resource like edmond
wilson um
everybody knows edmund wilson was this
great editor and great critic and uh but
and they know that he was the editor
fitzgerald's uh posthumous work
what people don't realize about wilson
for example is how much
he was involved with hemioi's career at
the beginning how he kind of established
hemingway's reputation at the beginning
he was the first
critic to write a favorable review of
ernest hemingway's book in the united
states
so you go back and see what wilson had
to say about these things in his
notebook see about these p these people
in the notebooks and they had a one one
disastrous
dinner together
in which fitzgerald and one of his worst
exercises and self-humiliation was
crawling under the table and uh
simultaneously
wilson said about used to half truckl
and half bait the people around you kind
of chuckle up and say these these
fawning things to you and then then
then when you least expect that he'd say
something nasty to you this is what
fitzgerald was like when he was drinking
and
and courting humiliation and so you know
you get people like wilson
who knew them putting spin on it that
you wouldn't see
in direct correspondence with each other
that's probably not a very good answer
for pack
suggested earlier that the um
well
[Music]
for fitzgerald is concerned hemingway's
accounts of fitzgerald are concerned um
i think there's very little in a mobile
feast that is that's literally untrue
uh for example there's the famous matter
of measurements
in which uh um hemingway and fitzgerald
go to
to luncheon and and
fitzgerald is complaining that zelda has
emasculated him by telling him that he's
his equipment is not adequate for sex
and that uh
hemingway then takes him into the
the men's room and they they have an
inspection of his private parts to see
if they measure up this sort of thing
oddly enough
though this this certainly sounds like
an invention uh it probably wasn't
because others have testified that
fitzgerald did in fact used to talk to
his dinner partners about his sexual
equipment and to mention that zelda
complained about it and and so that it's
quite possible that this is entirely
accurate it's it's just it's just that
what you learn about it is is not not so
much hemingway's invention of these
things as his need to
to try to recover that time really
i i think as he said in in the movies
it's really
magical in its evocation of what it was
like to be a young writer in paris and
and and to be finding yourself as a
writer that's one of the great things
about the book and i like that book very
much despite its nastiness to other
people it has that wonderful quality um
and and
anybody who got in the way of that
idyllic past and this includes
not just fitzgerald but but people like
gertrude stein and it was also savage in
that book and ford maddox ford and
ernest walsh and others
is going to be
denigrated because somehow
or or gerald and sarah murphy are
blamed for breaking up his first
marriage well
you know
two other people
rarely break up your marriage you know
and uh and i don't think it happened in
this case either but but but i think i
think that's
one of the things you learn is that
hemingway is trying to recover
is his most his time of greatest
creativity his time of greatest
happiness
really and and he's trying to and
therefore he has to attack everybody
who had anything to do
with taking the aura off of that
wonderful time
yeah
had okay around
in his time
does that seem to be one of his reasons
i don't think so i i i know no no i have
no uh no no account that hemingway's
sexual power is flagged
yeah
yeah
fitzgerald's very worst fiction is is
about him anyway yeah
a four-four story is about a character
called philippe who's a a
a medieval
french nobleman and who has uh
of extraordinary vigor and power and and
military prowess
but in the fourth story he kind of gets
his come up and switched interesting but
it's very bad fiction philippe was
consciously modeled on hemingway these
stories he wrote in 1934 35 36 when
when he was
the worst of his drinking period before
he
tried to stop and and and pretty much
did stop during the hollywood years
so that by the way there's a extensive
chapter in the book about what different
kinds of alcoholics these two people
were and about the the
the condition of of the the writer as an
alcoholic in the society too
okay uh two more questions one more
question maybe one more question
right last question anybody
speak briefly to your years as a
professor
did you enjoy that 26 years was it
is it nicely remembered sure
sure you know i had a great time william
mary i met the most important person in
my life there which was
one of the best things that happened and
uh i got to teach some wonderful
students and
[Music]
that's it's a very good it's a very good
small university and so yeah
thank you very much appreciate it
scott donald has written a number of
literary biographies including ones on
ernest hemingway and f scott fitzgerald
and on john cheever and winfield townley
scott
the overlooked press publishes this book
hemingway versus fitzgerald
the work it does
thanks very much you're very welcome
some of f scott fitzgerald's
correspondence can be found in the
huntington library in san marino
california
on a recent trip there we talked briefly
with sue hudson the curator of literary
manuscripts about f scott fitzgerald and
his personal life
why is f scott fitzgerald read in many
american classrooms
fitzgerald is one of the classic
american novelists
talks about life in the early part of
the century especially the 20s and 30s
and he's telling us about a life a way
of life
that is part of our history
what type of collection does the library
have in regards to f scott fitzgerald we
have only a small handful of letters and
they're all written to a man named carl
hubby who was the husband of a
screenwriter in hollywood named sonya
levine it's her papers we have
she she wrote
screenplays for oklahoma the hunchback
of notre dame and interrupted melody
among others and she did receive an
academy award for the screenplay for
interrupted melody you have one of those
letters correct yes tell us about it
this letter is written in april of 1921.
it is again to carl heavy who is the
editor of metropolitan magazine
and he writes that he's sending today
part one of the beautiful and damned his
new novel
he says the second part should reach you
monday and the third part tuesday
after the ten months i have been working
on it it has turned out as i expected
and rather dreaded a bitter and insolent
book that i fear will never be popular
and that will undoubtedly offend a lot
of people
personally i should advise you against
serializing it now that the damn thing
is off my hand i can try a few cheerful
stories
if you do not want it i don't believe i
shall offer it to anyone else but she'll
let scribners bring it out in september
which is probably the psychological time
anyhow
why would gatsby be writing a letter
like this against serializing some of
his work
a serialized novel needs to catch people
in the first installment
and
needs to make them want to go out and
buy the subsequent issues of that
magazine in which this uh successive
chapters appear
also serialized works often and works
for magazines
often needed to be a little bit lighter
in nature to reach a broader public i
think a public was more willing to read
something heavy in a volume in a
full-scale novel in one whack than in a
serialized form answer if you can why
does fitzgerald need money at this point
of his career well he goes on in the
letter to say that soon he and zelda are
going abroad
for a few months
and he expects to write several novels
and short stories while he's over there
but he needs money for the trip
he says you see if you don't serialize
it
i shall have to depend on an advance
from scribners for our trip and of
course i can't ask for that until i hear
from you
two questions who was zelda
zelda was mrs f scott fitzgerald and who
is script nurse scribner's is the
publisher charles scribners and sons
they were a major major publisher for um
many of the more significant american
authors
like edith wharton f scott fitzgerald
ernest hemingway what's the date on this
letter april 22nd 1921. what if anything
do you learn by looking at his
handwriting and his letter
well we can learn that he's a very
fluent writer
he writes straight ahead it's a very
upright hand
so it's a modern hand and it
it in some ways is very rounded almost
looks like a woman's hand
in some regards it it has some
similarities to actually to zelda's
handwriting
do you know how the library came into
possession of this letter yes we
received sonia levine's papers in the
1950s
she was a screenwriter her husband was
carl heavy the addressee of the letter
and you mentioned you also have a letter
by zelda fitzgerald yes we do
this is
famous among the library staff as the
so-called flapper letter why is that
because she talks about being a flapper
in the 1920s what was a flapper before
you begin oh flapper was a wild young
thing who who danced smoked drank did
all the wicked things one wasn't
supposed to do was the first of the
modern young women were the fitzgeralds
flappers absolutely absolutely they
lived in high society they lived hard
they drank hard they smoked hard
and they paid the price for it
ultimately did this come through in f
scott's works oh definitely what would
be his most well-known works that people
would see in writing about this era oh
the great gatsby
why don't you tell us a little bit about
this letter okay this letter isn't
undated but probably is written before
1922
and
zelda is sending a story to carl hovey
she is was also a writer and she was
herself talented
and so she encloses it she says here is
this foolish thing and i hope it will be
something like what you wanted the
flapper and that's the name of the story
the flapper
is a very difficult subject for me
because i cherish a secret ambition of
being one someday and take the duties
quite seriously
i think she achieved her wish you talked
about if scott's writings tell us a
little bit about zelda's writings
she's of course far less known um there
has been a volume of her stories that's
come out in the last few years and prior
to that she was really not regarded as a
serious writer in any sense at all but i
think that perception has changed some
in terms of her handwriting what if
anything can you
teach us
oh it's a very flamboyant handwriting
it's it's large it's bold it's
well-rounded it's almost like a larger
version of scott fitzgerald's
handwriting but it's just very bold and
flamboyant which i think bespeaks the
personality
how rare or how common is it to have
husband and wife team of writers for a
collection here at the library very rare
we only have a couple of other examples
who would they be
we actually have kingsley amos's papers
the 20th century british novelist and we
also have the papers of his first wife
i'm sorry his second wife elizabeth jane
howard who is a gifted writer as well
thank you very much
tonight on c-span american writers too
the series tonight explores the
progressive era and reaction to it
through the life and times of social
history we recently spoke with author
and actor george plimpton about f scott
fitzgerald ernest hemingway and the
relationship between the two writers
the interview lasts about 30 minutes
talk about the play zelda scott and
earnest
well uh
um hemingway and fitzgerald had a
correspondence of
i think 29 letters between them
and uh
if you read them they
they describe a sort of an interesting
arc of a friendship
they're just getting to know each other
and then they the correspondence is
enormously friendly
rather boisterous sort of locker room
stuff
gee i miss you that sort of thing i'd
give my orange ties says fitzgerald at
one point to see you all that
and uh some of the loves are fascinating
because they're critiques of each
other's work
there's a remarkable letter from
fitzgerald hemingway criticizing
the opening chapters of the sun also
rises and indeed hemingway takes out
the first section
following fitzgerald's suggestions
um
and then
there's a downward slope to these
letters
i think mostly because hemingway was
dismayed at fitzgerald's lack of
effort
the seven years stretched between the
great gatsby and tender is the night
and uh
hemingway thought that zelda was
destroying
uh her husband
work habits getting him to drink and so
forth
alcohol of course had a big big thing
and then of course uh in this nose of
kilimanjaro there was that there's that
crack about f scott fitzgerald and that
was sort of the end of their
friendship and everybody patched it up
after that
so there's sort of an interesting arc in
this
so a dramatic arc
and i thought that this could be adapted
to the
uh to a read to the stage so you could
read three three parts zelda
and scott
because zelda's letters
to her husband she never wrote to
hemingway disliked hemingway intensely
pansy with hair she called him
uh among other things
her letters are quite extraordinary very
beautiful very lyric
and
a very lengthy
correspondence with her husband back and
forth
so with all this material it it worked
very well to have three three readers on
the stage
so i've been doing it with norman mailer
as hemingway
which is quite wonderful
he comes out with two canes and
sits down there and clears his throat
and just throws himself into the pot
and his wife norris
plays zelda
rather overpowering as elder
and i play scott
and
we've done it
a number of times here in this country
and it does i think give a portrait of
these three very very distinct very
interesting characters
what was important for you to know about
f scott's fitzgerald in order to portray
the man on the stage
well i'd read
an awful lot of fitzgerald i think you
get something of the man through reading
his work obviously
there's some very very interesting
biographies on all these people
so i think if you read those
the most fascinating part of the play
of the reading really
is a transcript between uh
a conversation before a doctor john
hopkins between
scott and zelda
and they're seeing this man who actually
sort of a judge an intermediary
to see if they can solve a big fight
that's going on between them which which
is that scott fitzgerald did not want
his wife to continue writing
did not want his wife to finish this
novel
which was called caesar's things as i
recall
wonderful ideas about nijinsky going mad
on a cattle boat
zelda wanted to be a ballet dancer and
she knew quite a lot about that world
and
oginski going mad on a cattle boat uh
but scott didn't want her to write
and they so the doctor was sort of a
referee in this and eventually
scott uh gets zelda to agree that she
was not right
it's an extraordinary moment
so that's part of this as well so
there's a lot of material in there
to get this sort of a reading going how
did the two meet
the scott and fischer hemingway and
fitzgerald
well according to a movable feast
the line is um
the first time i met scott was at the
dingo bar
and uh which was where in paris
around what time
19 i'm bad on dates you know mid-20s
uh and then of course this friendship
struck up and and fitzgerald was then
at the height of his of his popularity
successful wrote this famous letter to
max perkins who was the editor at
scribner's
his editor
uh suggesting that he uh take a look at
hemingway's work this is the real thing
i think he says he writes
what drew these two men together sorry
what drew them together
the friendship lasted 20 some years
well i think they i think they had a
you can tell by the letters they really
enjoyed each other's company
i think they both liked the social life
they had great friends in the mglishes
and the um
uh in the and they went down to the
south of france quite a lot together
then then hemingway uh but then
fitzgerald came back to the united
states and then that's when these
letters reflect how much they wanted to
be with each other what were two
americans doing in france during the 20s
why were they there
well france in the 20s i mean that the
it was it was the of course it was the
time of affluence and there was a large
colony of um
american writers there
there were salons there was gertrude
stein's hello and everything seemed to
be going on at that time there was a
there were revolutions in writing there
was pound
ezra pound and james joyce and there was
the
sylvia beach's bookstore where they met
it was the time when there's a
revolution going on in art you had
picasso and all that also in music you
know stravinsky
rights of supreme and it is just a
huge uh
uh energy and
and the toppling of all sorts of
institutions
so it was a very rich place to be in in
terms of imaginative work creative work
and i think that's what drew them
hemingway originally went there for the
toronto star i went to europe for the
toronto star
uh stayed on in paris wanted righteous
gerald was there really more to
celebrate i think celebrated success
but also become part of this very
wild uh time and letters and social life
as well
you mentioned alcohol what role did
alcohol play in the lives of fitzgerald
and hemingway
well i think it's sort of
it's pretty much known that it destroyed
or almost destroyed
fitzgerald
apparently had almost no capacity for
alcohol he would very few drinks would
would
uh set him off
he behaved apparently atrociously with
booze
sort of person at a party who say oh
things are getting out of hand here
and there are stories about him in the
south of france sort of becoming really
outrageously drunk
zelda
in his letters is always criticizing him
for dragging himself through this
drunk through the streets of paris
coming home drunk
so it was obviously a very
um debilitating thing in his case
of course the latter part of his life he
through
he quit
but in the paris days for sure
also in these letters he occasionally
says i'm going on the wagon
there's always usually a line or two in
these letters about whether he's going
to be able to stop drinking or not
christmas is coming i'm getting
off the wagon and that sort of stuff
what about for hemingway
well hemingway was
from the from what i know was enormously
disciplined i mean i think he loved his
in cuba we used to drink these things
called papadoplas which was a daiquiri
drink
but he was always up at six o'clock in
the morning
always wrote a certain number of words a
day
uh down in his um
in his bedroom in the think of a here
he wrote standing up
and typed on a bureau
uh typed and also there was a a
clipboard there in which you which you
would write but above the
bureau was this big cardboard side of a
cardboard box and on it were marked
vertical and horizontal lines
and um
he kept the words number of words there
written on this board
they'd be 522 and then they'd be
462. like all writers he counted his
words
and then they'd be a thousand two
hundred and he did that so the next day
he could go fishing on the gulf stream
now i don't know whether he did that all
his life but i do know that he was it he
was always got got up at first light
and wrote
and uh apparently he was able to do that
even though he had a good
roy string night the night before
so
it wasn't much of a
factor in his
literary life where in fitzgerald
alcohol was a
uh
or at least according to hemingway was
always very critical of this drinking
what type of relationship did you have
with ernest hemingway
well i met him in paris in 1953 he was
on his way to africa
met him in the ritz bar
which was his favorite bar in paris
and we just started the
paris review in fact in the ritz hotel
there's a bookstore there
and i saw this man buying
a copy of the paris review he was the
only person i've seen buy a copy of the
magazine i've been associated with all
these years
in fact i was with some friends
the book and right near the bookstore i
said my god someone's buying the
review and he turned around and
it was earnest hemingway
so a few minutes later
i was introduced to him in the in the
bar
and we sat and chatted and he was
he of course started in that same world
himself
back in the 20s in literary magazines
and so he had a certain
has a certain affection for people who
do silly things like that uh literary
magazines in paris
and um
one of the features of the magazine had
been right from the start
interviews on the craft of writing
the first one was with um
e.m foster who was in my
college at cambridge university kings
college
and he agreed to be interviewed which
gave an enormous panache to these series
uh
so i asked mr hemingway the if we could
interview him
on the craft of writing
and he said yes and i said i think he
said that really because he never gave
interviews didn't like to talk about
writing at all
but
it was the nature of this literary
magazine in paris this
sympathetic response to my question
and then
he went to africa that was the time he
got into the airplane crashes and
i think the next time i saw him it was
in spain he asked me to go down to spain
so
that was the first time i met him it was
in the ritz bar
talk about that interview did it ever
happen
it did happen a lot of it happened by
mail because every time we'd sit down
and talk
we'd get sidetracked and and uh
as i say he did not like talking about
it writing very much felt it emptied the
well which was a
um
which he very often spoke about don't
want to empty the
the well
but it was eventually done it appeared
in issue number 18
and caused quite a stir
why
well he said some rather memorable
things in it
the most famous one i was going to look
it up to get exactly right but it's the
radar-proof [ __ ] detector is what the
equipment that all writers must have
so that's in there
also his discussion about the
the iceberg principle that
one-ninth of what produces the sentences
in the subconscious is under
um
it's a
but since he only gave as i've i think
he only gave one other interview in his
life so
it's um
it's an interesting piece what was it
like to sit down and chat with that man
well he'd much rather chat about other
things than writing as i was just saying
i mean you could sit down he was a
wonderful teacher he loved to talk about
boxing he loved to talk about fishing
we went out on the gulf stream a couple
of times
fishing
uh
he was a failure i always wanted to get
him to tell anecdotes about ezra pound
and all those people and he
he once told me something um
i don't know this is
i'll say it anyway
i was uh
visiting him in cuba at the think of a
here
and in that first meeting
in the ritz bath
i had said to him
when he agreed to do the interview
i said why do we meet tomorrow
and we'll go to some of the addresses
and i knew them all you know 24 routers
gertrude stein i knew about the sawmill
where the the i knew all these addresses
and i said we'll go to all these places
and you can talk about uh gertrude stein
and
alice b tuckless and ezra pound and
we'll go out to san clew the races and
so forth and right in the middle of my
suggesting this he said that's the
silliest damn idea i ever had in my life
but then uh years later
at the thinker
he said i want to show you something
you're responsible for
and he
pulled out this manuscript
a type written there was some things
scribbled on it
and he sat me down this great big white
chair in the living room
and he knelt behind me so he could look
over my shoulder and what he'd given me
was the chapter on gertrude stein that
eventually appeared in the
in a movable feast
which was published after his death
and i read it
and every once in a while i would laugh
at something and he would say what are
you laughing at i mean it was the most
nervous
reading of a manuscript that i can ever
remember
now what he meant by you're responsible
for this presumably is that you know he
thought about going around to the 24
rudi of fleur released it
hochner my old friend who wrote the book
papa hemingway
says this is absolute nonsense he wrote
that because he discovered a trunk in
the
cellar of the ritz hotel but i like to
think that
i like to believe
mr hemingway on that one
you mentioned a movable feast a couple
times for those that don't know what was
that novel about
a movable feast is a memoir
that hemingway started and he died
before it was published
and it consists of a number of chapters
on
uh those paris years
the the title i think it's a
i think the title comes out of his novel
across the river into the trees i think
he refers to
harry's bar or something like that being
a movable feast
and
hochner and miss mary hemingway's wife
were trying to think of a title for this
posthumous memoir
and they came up with a movable feast
i
it has a number of portraits in there
there's a one that i read in the
thinkover here was a gertrude stein
uh there's one on
pound
there's one on what paris was like at
that particular time
what does he say about hemingway i'm
sorry what does he say about fitzgerald
in it
well
he um
he talks about fitzgerald's
he describes him in the dingo bar
and he describes it he sees a sort of a
death's head
thing i think he foresees
um
he foresees
the tragedy of fitzgerald
he's also very critical of
zelda see zelda is this predatory figure
a hawk
and
talks about his wasted talents
also there's a famous thing in there
about
a visit to the louvre fitzgerald had
some idea that he was not as well built
uh his genitals were his uh
he was
too small he felt it was inadequate
and uh
there's a passage in there about
hemingway says you can't tell looking
from up looking down
um it's perfectly normal but i'll show
you this and then we'll go to the louvre
and now we'll take a do some some some
comparisons here
um
that's one of the paragraphs of the
feast
when in hemingway's career did he write
a moveable feast
approximately
well as i say was towards the end he
wasn't able to die before it was
published it would be as
well of course there were
i don't know to tell you the truth i
don't know whether they did chapters
there's an awful lot um since he wrote
every single day
uh and after all there were two novels
that were published
and then this movable feast and they've
just i have some friends who just got
back from cuba where they
were looking down in the
cellar of the thinkover here there's all
sorts of stuff down there
so the exact dates of when he wrote the
chapters for removal of a feast i don't
know
the reason i ask is if it were later in
his career why do you think he would
have the critique that he did of
fitzgerald
well it's not a devastating portrait i
mean there's a there's a portrait of a
that has to do with affection but the
affection is involved in it but also
disappointment
uh
i think he had a very keen uh
perception of people and uh he wrote it
uh at the end of their friendship which
had collapsed
uh because of the lines in um the snows
of kilimanjaro
fitzgerald at that time was to be in
hollywood they very rarely broke to each
other or saw each other
and i think hemingway saw him as a
wasted talent and said as much
he obviously didn't write at the
beginning of their friendship he wrote
it at the end right
what are you doing these days
sitting here giving interviews about
above and beyond that
well i've been asked to do a book on
shackled and i just got back from the
antarctic
yet another book on jacqueline
and i'm trying to finish a book on birds
i'm doing two pieces for the new yorker
one on barney rossett who
was the editor of the evergreen review
and a rather remarkable figure in
the history of
literary magazines
and
then of course
what i spend most of my time doing is
running the paris review what is the
paris review
the paris review was a literary magazine
started in paris in the
50s
and is just about to sneak into his 50th
year which is startling most magazines
have the life of butterflies
but this one seems to have
pushed on
and so we're planning planning a big
celebration celebratory year
the magazine is particularly noted
for um
finding new writers
getting them started
and over the years well philip roth
published one of his very very early
stories in the paris review t cor sagan
boyle richard ford
james solder
whole bunch of them so that's the sort
of thing we're particularly proud of is
being a launching platform for writers
who go on to great things well from your
unique position are there a group of
writers or artists in today's world that
you would compare to the group that
hemingway and fitzgerald
associated themselves with in paris
what do you like to think this
generation reduces that so that quality
of work
um
i i think comparisons are really very
hard you can't really make them
certainly fitzgerald's style the beauty
of his writing is so hard to imagine one
can just can do that sort of thing
but then his novels have flaws
hemingway's style
and creating it was a enormous step in
the history of literature comparative
literature
but then you read
pinchen or william gaddis or
bill gass or william stein or john
updike means quite a wonderful list of
very very powerful
marvelous writers of our generation
you know going back to uh fitzgerald
briefly if you were sitting across a bar
stool from fitzgerald
what type of man do you think would be
sitting there across from you if you had
to describe him to someone
i really don't know i i'd be surprised i
think he was smaller
i think physically you'd note that he
was a small smaller man
probably wearing an orange tie for
princeton
i don't know it's very hard to say i i
see pictures of him i've seen
photographs so i know what he would look
like
i suppose he'd like to talk about
princeton to get going i'm just just a
guest he was very proud of that very
proud of the
triangle club and the on and that
particular part of his i think he'd be
very rather nostalgic about what life
had been like
particularly if he was drinking
how often did you visit hemingway in
cuba
three or four times what was that like
well
where in your career were you when you
visited i would just be i was just
beginning i was very young and callow
i remember
i was there once when they were filming
our man and havana graham greene's novel
and um tennessee williams was there
and he wanted to meet hemingway
hemingway wanted to meet him he'd very
much admired a
cat on a hot tin roof as i recall or
maybe it was the glass menagerie
and we met in this bar the florida
detail i think it was called in the old
city
and
ken tynan was with us
he used to be the drama critic for the
new yorker englishman
and he was there too
and
the bar at one end had a bust of
hemingway
and he used to sit right under it so you
would see these two anyways
one corporeal and the other not
and um
neither but the bar was dark
and
you'd walk into it there was no foyer so
the it was blinding light from the
havana sun i mean that and then you have
to get your eyes adjusted
once you were in there it was like
almost pitch black you had to get sort
of adjusted then you'd see these two
hemmingways
and um
uh tennessee was late
and the reason he was late was that he
sort of had to get himself
outfitted to meet hemingway and he was
in a sort of a yachting outfit
i mean he wasn't quite wearing a cap
with an anchor but he had this blazer
with these big buttons gold buttons he
looked like a yachtsman with
white duck trousers you know
and uh
tynan stuttered
and i was so
these two great writers meeting for the
first time
and so there was this awkward
pause
and finally um
uh
tennessee made a mistake
he said this reminds me of the first
time i met faulkner
and hemingway was an enormously
competitive man and there'd been a list
of the five great american writers that
um
faulkner had put out the sort of thing
you shouldn't do as a writer and
hemingway i think on this list was
number five faulkner himself was number
two
and i think o'neill was number one
or thomas i don't remember
and
so this was not the way to start things
off
that didn't stop tennessee talked about
the first meeting
with um
which happened in rome
at some little restaurant
and faulkner had been sitting there
alone and
and tennessee walked in and uh
faulkner was sitting at the table with
his head down
and tennessee sat opposite him and when
faulkner raised his head and these were
tennessee's words
his eyes were so full of sadness that i
burst into tears
he told his story
to hemingway
who said
great effort
and there was another awful long pause
it finally got better but that was the
sort of the
that was the first meeting between these
two titans
and what were you doing in the bar what
had brought you to cuba
to see hemingway
for these interviews
no this was after the interviews this
was just a social visit um
we got a lot we had a good time we used
to go as i say we used to go fishing and
we used to
oh
go i used to go swimming in a swimming
pool
covered with shrub with leaves big
leaves floating in the thing like
soup plates murky
and he used to tell so i mean i just you
know it was a very easy
time
with him
you mentioned you had some friends who
were down in cuba recently do you know
what the status is of any type of
preservation for the homes or areas that
hemingway lived in
well the cuban government has kept the
thing just as it was
and i've not been there but they've
taken the pilar which is his boat and
they've got it in a sort of a cradle
there
and i i think you can take a tour
through the house
and there's a guide that takes you
through
and i know that you can go and look at
the grounds um as the swimming pool
it's up on a hill
um
and then these friends of mine as i say
i got into the cellar and i'm surprised
that they found as much as they did
they wrote me a long letter about it
which i've sort of half through so i
can't tell you exactly what they did
find there but they found uh
many manuscripts and um
letters various things it sounds like a
wonderful
and i think they are trying very hard
they've just been spending some time at
the kennedy
library where the hemingway collection
is up on the
seventh floor sixth floor
and i'm sure they'll be wanting to look
at this stuff and preserve it as best
they can
how many we kept everything
what's the future of zelda scott and
ernest
a little a little play
well you have to
you know to perform it you have to uh
pay
the hemingway foundation or the
fitzgerald estate
but people seem to like it a lot and and
we like we like doing it uh
i mean they've
performed in washington
um all for charitable
non-profit
organizations in providence town and
manchester vermont
seton hall denver
and
then we're going to do a performance in
the kennedy library
to raise money for the hemingway
foundation
and
so we're going to do it there
last an hour very dramatic
as i say it
describes the arc of this rather amazing
friendship between these two great
american writers
finally it's
with both hemingway and fitzgerald is
there any work that stands out as your
personal favorite for both of these men
well the great gatsby i don't think it's
probably the
great american novel certainly one of
them
and farewell to arms they're both early
works but i think they're the ones that
i find myself reading over and over
again why
well in fitzgerald's case the
beauty of the um
of the language as much as anything
uh also the mysterious figure of gatsby
himself
i think he gets a tremendous sense of
place you can in time which some writers
can do
wonderfully well he particularly
and they
they farewell to arms is the
the extraordinary scenes of the retreat
at caporetto
i think it's hemingway's prose which is
just exactly at that state where it's
not parity
it's it's
there's nothing wrong with it
it doesn't stick out
but sometimes the later work it does
thanks very much you're very welcome
american writers returns live on sunday
afternoon to focus on the life and works
of ernest hemingway his 1926 novel the
sun also rises deals with a group of
american expatriates living in france
and spain
our program from key west florida begins
sunday at 3 p.m eastern right here on
c-span
it's the course of our nation
this week our selected writer is f scott
fitzgerald
last saturday at the bound to be read
bookstore in saint paul minnesota
talk radio host ian poonett hosted a
special edition of his dead theologian
society
this discussion was entitled the god of
gatsby and examined the morality of the
characters in fitzgerald's novel the
great gatsby
saint paul mayor randy kelly introduces
this one hour program
thank you very much i'm randy kelly
mayor of the city of st paul
and i am just so very very happy and
delighted today
to be uh kicking off this community
discussion of c-span's uh
part of the series on american writer's
tour
featuring if scott fitzgerald st paul of
course is the
home of this uh
great american author and i believe the
discussion today will be about various
aspects of the great gatsby one of the
great american novels
uh our host today is going to be ian
punnett who is the kstp ams radio host
of the dead theologian society and he
will be moderating uh today
we also are pleased to have with us
father james mcconville of saint peter's
catholic church
in north st paul a suburb here of our
great city and
david
pinchansky who is assistant professor of
theology at st thomas university so we
look forward to uh this uh this
discussion uh here today uh it is uh
truly uh appropriate i think that we
have a
literary discussion uh beginning here
this week because uh on tuesday uh next
uh superintendent harvey and i will be
uh announcing our one book
for all saint paul lights which we're
asking everyone to read
next month as part of a community-wide
project to cultivate a culture of
reading
here in our city so we're delighted to
have our guests here and to be listening
to this lively and interesting
discussion so with that in it the
floor's yours
let's say thank you so much mr mayor for
being here thank you and i'm
disappointed only that you didn't bring
your guitar
uh i don't know how many of you saw last
night mayor kelly had his guitar with
him at the twins game and uh how many
thousands do we need to get before
you'll play do we need to get is there a
minimum crowd we need to have
not at all just i have to have a couple
drinks
well i we have a blank board up there if
you'd like to sketch out some of your
ideas for the proposed stadium
issue in st paul trying to get the twins
over here
and just open air on the river in saint
paul i'm with you 100 and we we thank
you so much for
for being here and i was i was very
proud of you last night that even though
you're in competition with mayor rybak
that you didn't hit him el caban like
with the guitar at the stadium and uh
and try to get the twins over so thank
you so much for being here we're very
civilized
uh
for those of you who haven't been here
before
this is a regular meeting which we do
usually on wednesdays
at bound to be red
the dead theologian society is an
informal group
some have referred to it as kind of like
a damaged sunday school for damaged
adults who
who want to get together and talk about
theological issues but have no other
place to do that
we also enjoy
quite a bit of
of guest appearances uh one of whom is
coming back with us again today with the
dr pinchansky uh there is sort of an
aspect to this that we'll be drawing on
for you all later on too and that we
will have our theological perspectives
but you are welcome to yours and part of
the beauty of the dead theologian
society is always that we simplify
theology down to just
god talk
and that's all that it is that we do
it's just talking about god so you don't
need to feel as though you are
unqualified
god talk happens all the time and it
does happen in the get in the book the
great gatsby so we thank you here to our
little island of lost theological toys
and for uh anybody who's uh watching you
are welcome to come here any every other
wednesday
at bound to be red so if you're in saint
paul
or minneapolis you can call ahead and
find out whether we're meeting that
wednesday and we'd love to have you
as we always do though if we can just
open our meeting with a quick moment of
prayer
god of grace
yahweh
elohim
el shaddai
adonai
theos deus
redeemer creator
great spirit holy spirit
allah
our many names for you god reflect
that we are a fractured people
but we thank you for this opportunity to
come together today on this
beautiful spring day
many different people
from different places of different minds
but all of one heart
and that heart is
shared in yours
we thank you for this chance to exchange
words in your honor
amen
uh
i will get a thank our guests uh dr
panchansky from saint thomas and also
father james mcconville who is a
frequent contributor to
my radio show as well
and i want to hold up if i can dr
pinchansky's
most recent book
what rough beast
quite a challenging read but very
enjoyable images of god
in the hebrew bible and a perspective
that he's going to share with us today
and i'll also mention dr panchansky's
wife who is an artist
hen al mansour opened up last night in
for a gallery selected works appearing
at the mcad gallery mcad mcad gallery
minneapolis college of art design uh in
south minneapolis and
i recommend this it's very interesting
and i wish i could have been there last
night but it was our first really warm
night all year long
and i couldn't get my kids off the
playground to save my life to get over
there in time
uh i will look forward to hearing your
contributions later on if you have
questions please save them toward the
end and then we can address them but
first
a couple of opening remarks when we were
asked to do this i talked to both dr
panchansky and father james and they
both made the same comment in regard to
the god of gatsby and looking at
theological issues in the great gatsby
at first blush
doesn't give you a lot to work with um
god
god mentions are peppered throughout the
great gatsby but usually as only an
exclamation or worse an expletive
but
but there are occasions and there are
important uses
of theology in gatsby and we'll get to
that because it is thick with religious
significance and so it is
that we'll start with some opening
remarks and i'll i'll ask dr pinchansky
as as you address this book probably for
the first time like many of us it's been
a while since we've read it straight
through
uh what were your first impressions now
that you are a professor of uh theology
in in regard to how god is used or
abused in the great gatsby well
i looked for god in the book in three
ways and uh the first two didn't really
work for me i first did what you said i
i read through the whole book and i i
just made uh a mark next to every place
where there was some reference to god or
or some issue in theology or or church
and first thing i noticed is that
the references are few and far in
between and the second thing is that the
references aren't really terribly
important for the movement and the plot
of the book
so the second place i looked was
sometimes novels have a kind of a kind
of a paint a mythic world a world in
which the gods are involved and it's
really not not hard to find that in
gatsby there's a
there's an in-between land between new
york city and long island that the
characters are constantly driving back
and forth between and some significant
elements in the plot happen
in that place and it's a blasted grey
ashy place with grotesque
shapes and smokes and clouds going up a
place of of of death a place of misery
and horror and the people who live there
are are pretty awful people and in this
blasted place there's a there's a faded
billboard sign with two huge eyes
and at certain points in the book you
get an idea that the eyes are are the
eyes of god that are that are looking at
everybody
this didn't work for me either because
it's a billboard it's an advertisement
it's faded it doesn't really represent
anything or have any real significant
involvement in the story
sometimes and this is my third way
you can find god in the absences and the
things that
are not mentioned the things that are
talked around and and the biggest clue
for me was
i'm reading this book and and here is a
a a a series of collections of really
just repulsive
shallow self-centered people why is this
book so popular
and the reason is
gatsby somehow is an appealing and a
sympathetic character so i thought to
myself aha
you know there's something in here
there's something going on there's
something that's
greater than human
and i i'd like to probably pick up on
that again later but just briefly let me
say that uh gatsby's utter devotion to
something outside of himself
is a kind of religious sensibility and i
thought i might find in there a source
of of god talk well and i
want to pursue several of those things
that you mentioned in particular uh the
relevance to him being such a flawed
character and maybe that's why people
relate to him so well today
uh and have ever since but they're all
flawed they're so morally well like
seinfeld characters in a way that in
their transparency uh maybe it's easier
for us to see ourselves in them
because there's not that much there uh
that we have to connect with uh father
james your first impressions well
i'd share many of the same uh feelings
uh with my colleague here that the the
uh
uh especially that sense that these are
not terribly attractive characters at
least at first blush that they're all
they're
considered to be well to do they come
from old money most of them gatsby we're
told is new money uh but still he even
his way of behaving is is not you know
top drawer christianity that's not what
you're looking for not looking for
really a morality play in the in the
traditional sense but that was my
question is what is the vertical
dimension
not in the sense of necessarily human
beings to god but even just any sort of
transcendent principle is anybody rising
up as anybody uh is there any sort of
connection with something greater
whatever that greater might be
and um
that's there's one of the instructive
lines in the whole thing is i think that
nick makes the
uh the thing about gatsby says he he
imagined himself or created himself as a
17 year old might
and never got beyond it
and uh and that was the thing is that
that uh this hopefulness that gatsby is
sympathetic and he's very sympathetic
because he's very hopeful fellow that he
is reaching out the first time we see
him he's got his hands extended he's
looking across the bay at this green
light at the end of a dock across the
way we later find out about all these
things but but it is that's that i think
that
that one action
the first time we meet gaspi really does
set it all up is that this reaching out
for the un
attainable but yet
uh what was the thing the fire was that
our uh our reach must out
strike our grasp or what's the heaven
for some of that sort of thing is that
that's now that's the idea is that there
is there's there is a motion there is a
movement in the sense that he wants the
unattainable so i agree with that that's
a very powerful theme in the preface of
the book it says the great gatsby does
not proclaim the nobility of the human
spirit it is not politically correct it
does not reveal how to solve the
problems of life it delivers no
fashionable or comforting messages and
the book certainly delivers on that
non-promise
uh what does the book do if if one is to
read this book and look for instruction
on how one is to act or not to act
what is there for the reader
after watching these characters interact
i i actually might disagree with the
introduction i think there is something
of the nobility of the human spirit in
this book uh but in order to understand
that you have to see uh you know what it
is that that gatsby is is focused on uh
traditional narratives usually take one
of two shapes they they are comedies
which is a kind of a u-shape where you
start off on the top and then you go
down and then you get up to the top
again
boy meets girl boy loses girl boy finds
girl again
then there's the tragic shape which is
an inverted you so it uh it it starts
off at some low place and with gatsby
that low places his humble beginnings
and then he reaches this this pinnacle
of his fantasy he's he's a rich person
living in a beautiful mansion and
hundreds of people come to his popular
parties which last all summer long and
then at the end of the book he loses
absolutely everything so it's a tragic
story so we're not going to see in
gatsby some kind of a glorious model of
a way to live
so the reason i say that i think it is
in a sense a hymn to the nobility of the
human spirit is because gatsby
loses himself in in his love and his
passion for something that's outside of
himself and even though uh the object of
his passion which in this case is an
empty-headed bubble-headed barbie-type
woman
woman
daisy
she's not worthy of such devotion and
such passion as we find out at the end
of the book but because he reaches out
to this it somehow gives him a nobility
the tragedy of the story is that he the
object of his devotion is not worthy
of such devotion and such sacrifice and
ultimately that brings him down and
destroys him and that's and that's the
whole point of tragedy isn't it that you
get you have a generally sympathetic
character
who um has a flaw
and that uh and that that seems to be
his flaws that what what he's pinned his
hard on is not going to ultimately
satisfy it's not it's not like you say a
worthy uh goal to go after but i think
that's very true he's uh he's tragic
even in the senses of of a lear or a
romeo or all these other uh sort of
idealistic fellows uh that even the
shakespeare would paint for you uh
yet then
that must bring us in some form to what
kind of god then is portrayed in gatsby
if if he is striving
toward the worship of somebody who is
unworthy
what about what about god the thing that
that is referenced frequently in the
book as being a force
but we never quite get an idea of what
kind of force
that god is uh this is this is why i say
that
god is present in gatsby in his absence
i i don't think the discussions of god
will lead us anywhere because
uh
it's it's it's god as a kind of social
presence among the classes of people
with which we're dealing so it's the
absence of god in the critique of the
god-like things that gatsby worships so
if these things
that are so desperately important to him
are not adequate even when he he pretty
much gets everything he wants then
the reader is is left to begin to wonder
well is there then some
adequate object of our devotion which
will not disappoint now there are two
answers you can get to that and i'm
frankly i don't know enough about
fitzgerald to know what his answer would
be the answer could be no there is
nothing there's just the emptiness that
we have here and the other and i this is
where gatsby's nobility and sympathy
begins to push me over to that end
because the other possibility is if this
uh the the joys and the glories of the
jazz age of partying all the time and
conspicuous consumption if that's not it
well then maybe he's leaving room for
there being something else and i suppose
the only
place i could see that in a positive way
is in the kind of barely sketched
character of the narrator nick
and he seems to be different from the
other characters there seems to be some
uh kind of depth in him which the other
characters lack a moral center a moral
center thank you yeah i i can i think we
all get that from nick and certainly
toward the end as nick continues to
plead with the other characters for them
to have a moral center as well of course
he's he's very
upfront to tell us that he's the most
honest man he knows right
what about you father james do you agree
what kind of god is in gatsby well well
again i think that's yeah
as i look at i'm very familiar with some
catholic authors where there's some 20th
century ones where there's some
wonderful overlap with someone like
evelyn wa
you know i think of two of his novels a
handful of dust and vile bodies actually
this is more like vile bodies where you
have these contemptible characters um
but yet somehow
uh it's like they they're almost filling
in the gaps i think that's correct to
say that you know that god is is
noticeable by his absence
look at how they fill in the blanks with
regard to behavior uh tom seems to be
more upset with daisy and gatsby's uh
relationship because of this class
structure that's set up uh gaspi is no
you know it's the nouveau riche you know
he's he's he's he and and so therefore
he's still gotten yeah exactly which is
weird for tom to suddenly take a moral
position exactly but he finds it easy to
do that with guests in fact even nick
will make the comment his transformation
to prig was complete right
it's it's really a class uh hatred
that's masquerading as a moral sense
exactly exactly and that's the thing is
it seems like he's filling in the hole
is that there's
we don't have some objective uh truth so
we kind of make it up as we go along at
least that's
you see some of that i want to read from
chapter 2 here because this brings us to
a discussion of the god that is
semi-identified and i think it's
actually debatable to say whether or not
this is identified as god but above the
gray land and the spasms of bleak dust
which drift endlessly over it you
perceive after a moment the eyes of dr
t.j eckelberg
the eyes of dr t.j eckleburg are blue
and gigantic notice its nordicness
their retinas are one yard high
they look out of no face but instead
from a pair of enormous yellow
spectacles which pass over a
non-existent nose evidently some wild
wag of an oculus
set them there to fatten his practice in
the burrow of queens then sank down
himself into eternal blindness or forgot
them and moved away but his eyes dimmed
a little by many paintless days under
sun and rain brewed on over the solemn
dumping ground
we will explore that further as that
billboard is referenced as being god or
at least i would argue perhaps reference
uh but uh
the certainly the fadedness of the
billboard
points to this impotent god of gatsby
this somewhat powerless god who maybe
had some place sometime in the past but
now is just kind of a relic it reminds
me of a a poem by shelly ozymandias
which is uh
uh two vast and trunkless uh legs
standing in the desert of some huge
statue of some great emperor now long
forgotten and his vast empire is just
now it's just sand so something great at
one time in the past but now has no
relevance i think i really think on a
conscious level fitzgerald is is
critiquing the the faith of the previous
generation and saying that this is faded
this is meaningless this is gone so yeah
that is his only positive god image in
the whole book i think and it's very
negative yeah it's an advertisement
positive image yeah it's very naked
which again and uh another character who
carries on that motif of these these
eyes and glasses is what what he simply
refers to as the owl-eyed man
uh in the uh
who uh nick first runs into in the
library of gadsby's house and he's just
fascinated by the fact that the books
are real right that these aren't just
fake book fronts that you know
trying to look like he's a very uh
literary type you just imagine this
whole wall was just nothing but
cardboard with uh with little pieces of
wrapper on it and that's what he's
expecting so he's pulling these things
out and saying it's real and i found
that just a fascinating thing that that
um that somebody should actually you
know there's there's something real
about this whole thing and the fact that
because i think there is i really do
think there is a connection between
between eckelberg's uh visitor the
eyeballs and this man that he's
described as a man with these large
glasses that um
that this that
the allied man
does seem to be even he doesn't seem to
uh
you know as being the wise one uh seems
to be totally inactive in this whole
thing or unable uh eckelberg comes back
later on during a major conflict uh in
the book when uh wilson's glazed eyes
turned out to the ash heaps where small
gray clouds took on fantastic shape and
scurried here and there in the faint
dawned wind i spoke to her he muttered
after a long silence i told her she
might fool me but she couldn't fool god
i took her to the window and with an
effort he got up and walked to the rear
window and leaned with his face pressed
against it and i said god knows what
you've been doing everything you've been
doing you may fool me but you can't fool
god
standing behind him michaelis saw with a
shock that he was looking at the eyes of
dr t.j eckleburg which had just emerged
pale and enormous from the dissolving
night
god sees everything repeated wilson
that's an advertisement michaelis
assured him
uh
that's an advertisement
is a play on words it seems to me if we
want to take god sees everything as a
kind of religious slogan
is it is it an advertisement because
it's a religious slogan
or is it because it's an advertisement
because it was up on the billboard or
both there's one more thing you want to
put into the mix there which is the
person who's saying this right wilson
is uh the the the the character who
inhabits this ash heap land he's sick
he's bitter he's desperate his wife is
cheating on him he doesn't know with
whom and the very man that he's trusting
is in fact the man who's cheating with
his wife
he's a desperate and pathetic character
and what does he do he
when he finds out his wife is cheating
him his reaction to it is he locks her
in a room which ultimately uh results in
her death when she escapes and runs out
and is hit by the car
so the figure in whom is this
theological slogan sloganing the really
the only theological slogan in the
entire book
is the weakest and most pathetic
character in the book
so again i think uh
fitzgerald is telling us that this this
is not a route that's going to be useful
for us there's nothing here for any of
the characters what about the owl-eyed
man for you i don't know i hadn't
thought about that one a little bit i'd
like father jim to reflect on that
that's a new one for me well it is just
because like you say well i think
there's just a physical similarity are
you saying this just because you have
big spectacles and you're
right
all right come here you fancy yourself
as the owl-eyed man yeah right
no i don't cough up little pellets
either
no the uh uh
the whole the no it's just i think there
is there's a physical similarity between
eckelberg's image on or the the roaster
advertising his work and then um this
allied man and that uh
what seems to be so illusory so uh
let's say ashes just crumbly decay all
the rest of it uh and here is this sort
of personification of echoberg in the
library saying this is real right uh
this isn't illusory this isn't this
isn't and then he's the only one that
turns up at the very end of the novel um
at the funeral yeah and there's a kind
of transcendency to that and uh
let's address that because that does
that the owl-eyed man actually who's
never identified by name we don't even
know really what relationship he is in
fact the narrator uh marvels the fact
that he's there because he was not
called he was never he how did he find
out about the the funeral none of
gatsby's friends and only you know one
of his family members are there uh so
why the owl-eyed man well there's it's
sort of offered is a kind of
almost a mythic figure he shows up there
and he offers some of the few words that
are said at the funeral
uh again almost sort of a transcendency
of god you think
well that's what i'm wondering is that
if he's if he's not at least uh
offering some sort of a commentary
almost a deus ex machina isn't he i mean
just he just he just pops up at the end
and uh um
i think he gave he gives the uh the
final uh uh assessment of uh of gatsby
he does in fact he gives two of them in
a way yeah uh
it's uh said here at the funeral dimly i
heard someone murmur blessed are the
dead that the rain falls on and then the
owl-eyed man said amen to that in a
brave voice and then a little bit
further on he took off his glasses wiped
them again outside and said the poorest
sob
and and that is that's the final that's
the benediction that's what's offered at
the very end
um
interesting note on the fact that the
scripture doesn't exist um
the closest we get to it i think
it's a conglomeration obviously but uh
revelation 14 13 begins blessed are the
dead but it doesn't end blessed are the
dead that the rain falls on but blessed
are the dead who die in the lord from
now on and the sermon on the mount says
uh
the rain falls on the just and the
unjust so that might be the rain part of
the reference something probably he
learned in sunday school and mixed up in
his mind as we come to the funeral
though it begs the question about the
role of religion not just god but how is
religion used in gatsby and i think one
of the things that makes it so
attractive to the modern reader and and
i think provocative for many readers
today
is that there is uh there is no piety in
this age and some people i think in
their modern imagination all we see the
farther back we go in history the more
pious people were but here are the 20s
the roaring 20s the jazz age as
fitzgerald called it and uh there's
there's there are no pious characters in
the book and there's very little
evidence of the need for religion except
as we have it in our modern use uh by
many and that's in its ceremonial
context you're it's there for when
you're born for when you're married uh
we know that
that gatsby went to a lutheran college
but there doesn't seem to be any
lutheran imprint on him at all there's
no sense of the importance of that that
upbringing
and then during a very crazy time uh
when there's a lot of screaming uh the
the notion is brought up for the need
for a priest
uh and i'll read that here too because i
think it's indicative uh have you got a
church you go to sometimes george maybe
you haven't been there for a long time
maybe i could call up the church and get
a priest to come over and he could talk
to you see
don't belong to any you ought to have a
church george for times like this you
must have gone to a church once didn't
you get married in a church listen
george listen to me didn't you get
married in a church that was a long time
ago
and so the role of religion seems to be
just very purely ceremonial and we have
to talk about the reason why religion
plays such a small part in the
characters lives and i think here gatsby
becomes a model for us as well
because gatsby has built his entire life
on a fantasy on an idea he creates
himself in an image that he had in his
mind when he was 17. and and this notion
of uh just a complete self-creation like
a
totally self-absorbed and self-centered
devotion to making oneself a particular
kind of person it's it's a sensibility
that's really uh
anathema to religion which requires one
uh to devote oneself to something that's
that's outside of oneself it's an
acknowledgement
of of something greater and so
the
the defining moment for gatsby because
he really has two ideals that are in
conflict with him one is this uh
building this life for himself and the
other is daisy and when he sacrifices
himself for daisy uh it ennobles him in
some way because it's greater than this
i just kept thinking of like the surface
of a soap bubble that that's that's how
much clarity his life had it was a
surface of a soap bubble and and when
it's when it started going it just
popped and it was gone hundreds of
people coming to his house and then all
of a sudden nobody comes to his funeral
so uh the moment where he gives himself
over to something uh he ennobles himself
gives up everything that he worked and
hoped for
uh so it becomes a profound critique of
of how he built his life and and that's
why there would be no place for religion
in in a life so constructed
but even until it's interesting because
you're talking about this this um noble
end something that's that
that ennobles him because he's got this
goal that he's going after that's beyond
himself and it actually it seems to me
that the the wealth and the parties and
all of this are are really part of that
means uh to that contrast that to cody
uh the man who you know in his yacht who
uh uh befriends uh befriends gatsby in
fact it's from him he decides to change
his name from james gatz to uh jay
gatsby
and uh
the fact that cody doesn't have this he
has the wealth he has
all of these things he wants he has the
material side of life tied up but he has
nothing beyond that and so he just
simply becomes a drunk that floats
around on a yacht for a bunch of years
and eventually his money just gets taken
away uh gatsby was supposed to be the
beneficiary he doesn't even get that and
so i so i think that's a it's a very
powerful thing that you bring up well
and it it's also it isn't limited to the
shallowness of that isn't limited to the
uh the secular characters but even uh to
the only minister that we have a little
before three the lutheran minister
arrived from flushing and i began to
look involuntarily out of the windows
for other cars so did gatsby's father
and as the time passed and the servants
came in and stood waiting in the hall
his eyes began to blink anxiously and he
spoke of the rain in a worried uncertain
way the minister glanced several times
at his watch so i took him aside and
asked him to wait half an hour but it
wasn't any use nobody came
and
and here you have a minister who's not
at all engaged he is not in relationship
as you know he's part of very central to
lutheran theology to be in relationship
with those you serve um he is offering
nothing of comfort there's no pastoral
character to this minister just another
guy waiting for a bus there to pass uh
so we're we're not offered from
fitzgerald's point of view we're not
given any hope that the clergy is
actually anything special either
it's from the past generation that
doesn't offer anything to this new
generation so
it is it is very modern because uh we we
have here uh uh younger people 20
somethings
uh who are uh
trying to find meaning in life with uh
uh with with a lot of uh just spending
things in on their pleasure and and
there's there's nothing there and
there's they don't feel that the older
generation has anything to offer them
and they're cut adrift right
at very 80s and 90s in particular and
perhaps you could say
you know maybe we've moved away from
that a bit uh
in
this uh post 9 11 age but even there
that's probably too large isn't that
what it is
what they're saying these days too is
now initially there was a huge upsurge
in church attendance everything else
immediately after 9 11. and now they're
saying levels are beginning to go back
to where they
were all right or i mean actually even
even shortly even that probably invited
me over i yeah whatever but but
so again you know exactly the point that
fitzgerald is making times of crisis
times you know we we turn back to these
sort of comfort places these these uh
things that give us some uh comfort and
some familiarity uh maybe uh
because there are things you know
stories my mother told me right i can
hang on to it and now uh okay my
equilibrium has been reestablished maybe
our corporate memory thing the the
poignancy is faded so now i go back
because think about world war one right
was right on the doorsteps of what's
going on here in fact the fact that the
novel really sort of picks up
very much the tail ends of of a
disenchanted period yeah and and yet we
know there's a great religious revival
that comes in the 30s so this is sort of
a
obviously a pre-uh
depression era novel and
and yet i think the point is very good
it shows the cycle of where we are with
the clergy and the and the need for
common ritual and liturgical words and
comforting worship that we do in
community with each other as a pastor
however
and as a chaplain uh that must be kind
of frustrating to see a lutheran
minister right in this moment this key
moment and as f scott draws him uh he's
colorless
well it's
this character i mean i witness it uh
constantly is that you you see and i've
witnessed it in my own life so i'm not
going to you know i'm not going to be
that sanctimonious i mean there are
hundreds of moments where
a nice word given a just a simple
gesture
to somebody at a particular point could
make the world of difference it doesn't
have to be
this perfect
ritual everything's by the book it's
just simply the fact that you care
the fact as especially because of the
clothing because you're a clergyman to
actually show some sort of interest it
is is it it's it's the engagement it's
the relationship it's not just simply
i'm coming in doing these pre you know
described things uh we're in we're out
we're interchangeable you know just we
just happen to find a guy in flushing
bring him out you know right that it's
it that there's something human about it
you in fact i think that cs lewis made
that comment heavens the place where god
uh will pay attention to us
you know what uh what a great uh image
of heaven yeah but it seems like is
these characters they don't want to be
engaged either
i think the worst thing that could
happen is that this minister would
actually start talking to them because
they're looking out the window they
don't want to lock eyes
and as i consider that though i i it
goes back to the ceremonial nature of
religion uh and how it's used and the
fact that uh christianity doesn't fare
very well here in gatsby it doesn't it's
not looked upon as uh anything that is
uh challenging the characters they don't
they don't feel particularly bad about
their excesses there's no sense of are
we doing enough for the poor there's no
social justice uh
but even though
escott doesn't do anything for
christianity and the characters don't
seem to care too much about their own
faith they seem to go out of their way
and so does f scott to kind of take a
swipe at judaism
uh
and
and i i don't know i mean i how steeped
this is in anti-semitism but it's fair
to note
that the characters that are as equally
flawed as gatsby and his generation
who are jewish are identified as jewish
and flawed and the other folks are just
sort of flawed and there isn't any
highlight brought to that notion at all
i don't i don't think that uh fitzgerald
was
setting out to write an anti-semitic
tract he's he's largely reflecting the
attitude of his age uh and his class
which uh which regarded uh jews in this
very offensive hateful and stereotypical
way suspicious uh yeah jews in this
particular way of looking are uh are
shady they're
physically disgusting they're not to be
trusted and the emphasis he gets on on
wolshine's nose hairs it's uh when we
when we read this today i mean this is
patently offensive i don't believe that
fitzgerald meant anything by it it was a
kind of
intellectual laziness on his part a
stylistic laziness that he needed to
somehow account for uh gatsby's shady
past an easy way to do it connect him
with a jew so we can criticize his age
for this kind of uh of of shorthand
which is so hateful and we know what he
didn't know at this point is what is
where such hateful attitude could lead
uh but it wasn't his purpose to do that
it's it's an unfortunate thing when
you're reading a book written in the 20s
by a a white anglo-saxon protestant it
will frequently betray uh these kinds of
very ignorant and hateful attitudes
towards jews well and we should say the
same thing too about any of the
african-american references which are
equally detestable but uh but still
indicative of the era uh and in in but
yet despite meyer wolfsheim's corpulence
and the way in which he's portrayed as
you know being the sort of bloated
figure of over-indulgence and and and
always um
a kind of a temptation personified
connected via this other mythical
character who's also jewish uh to the
real life character that was involved in
the tainting of the world series
that in doing that
he opens the door for uh meyer wolfsheim
to also be a good guy and there's a
there's a contrast that's offered
and nick sees a lot of virtue in this
character although the character doesn't
necessarily live up to nick's
expectations in the end well in fact
that's
that's what i think was the one of the
brilliant points in the way gatsby's
written is that
uh that corruption
that uh
infests everybody i mean even if you
look at somebody like myrtle you know
myrtle
uh starts out uh you know well she's
living in this ash world where there is
some sort of moral life of you know i
mean good working class sort of uh
individual she starts putting on errors
and pretensions as soon as she starts
having the affair with tommy this whole
thing of just corruption just gets into
everything and even nick starts to get a
little corrupt in his own uh way of of
talking and everything else by the end
he's he's not quite the same um that i
get that sense that um
we get corrupted that in the sense that
by the end of the novel we can just look
at oh oh they're having an affair you
know right you know oh he oh he threw
that you know the black sock game 199
right
so that's almost the thing is that that
all of that seems to fall by
and then we can see that that little
piece of
gold right uh
as as caked with filth as it is it just
gets a little glint of it so yeah so
meyer wolfsheim is actually he seems to
be actually pretty uh tender right on on
gatsby at the very end it's very
difficult to get to him and all the rest
of it goes on but but still there's some
little yeah and even though he doesn't
even though he doesn't go he sends a
note yeah which is almost in its way it
elevates him ever so slightly above uh
some of the other characters it's even a
source of wisdom when he says
let us be friends with people while they
are still living
i think fitzgerald is just too good a
writer at least with his male characters
to uh
not give him some sense of
three-dimensionality it's kind of like
the merchant of venice [ __ ] which is
a
horribly anti-semitic image but at the
same time uh shakespeare gives shilak
one of the most empathetic lines that
that that a jewish person has ever given
in in in literature in that period where
you know do not jews bleed if you cut
them and and and it's just it's a
quality of good writers but uh it it
does show
uh just
the general atmosphere at the time had
some really really reprehensible ideas
which are picked up in the novel and as
both of you mentioned too tom uh is i
think if i remember quickly just is more
upset not so much about what happened or
how
gatsby
made his money as much as with whom he
associated to make that money and again
the implication is somehow if you deal
with these people you become tainted you
become
uh
the references here for uh
some other aspects of religion um are
plentiful but they're a little they get
a little more subtle here so i'm gonna
i'm gonna go down a road if you'll
pardon me
that i really don't know where it's
going to take us but i am curious on
your reflections on this
we have a certain physical movement in
the novel that happens all the time
all the way out from from west egg to
this uh to the ash heaps and then to
manhattan and certain immoral behaviors
happen in manhattan and then there's
these sort of glorious excesses
of the mansion of the gatsby mansion and
then right there in front of the eyes of
dr t.j eckleburg
where the ash heaps are uh it seems like
a kind of purgatory but i i can't quite
get a feel for whether that was an
intentional movement
or whether i'm just reading too much
into it i i thought a lot about that too
and uh
this is this is about the most i can
come up with i'm not sure if we could i
wasn't able to make some kind of a sense
of the movement from
long island to manhattan and back to
long island it seems that they go to
have fun in manhattan but it doesn't
seem to represent any more of a a a den
of sin than than do the the mansions on
long island uh but what i was able to
pick up was
it's kind of a good university word
liminal
it's a word we use to describe an
in-between place a borderline that
doesn't uh isn't quite completely one
thing or another but retains the
qualities of both and so i think the ash
heap is the liminal place the place of
possibilities the place where
transformation can truly happen when
they're on the long island when they're
by the way i grew up in flushing and
passed this place all the time it's it's
not an ash heap anymore
but
but they have what they do on long
island and what they do in manhattan
doesn't change them but the things that
happen in this middle place the boundary
lands the borderlands change everybody
so what happens there we have the affair
between tom and myrtle which takes place
in this borderland we have the
the only place where we get any serious
interaction between
the upper classes and the lower classes
and this is a very very class conscious
novel in in the united states where we
think we don't have any classes uh and
it's also the place where uh myrtle is
run over where where just this whole
little pseudo-friendship community
that's been developed gets blown apart
so that's the part of it i want to kind
of latch on to that
not that the new york and the long
island is terribly important but that
this liminal place where
eckelberg's eyes are where this garage
is that they always kind of end up at uh
that this is the place where things
happen this is the place where the the
spiritual fates of the characters all of
them is determined is in this
liminal never never land and is that
because that's the only place where god
is
in a non-omniscient god
uh
a limited god of power
that only the the things are only
punished or that there are only
consequences for sin in the liminal area
the excesses on either side
don't seem to have consequences but
right there in the middle where the
classes interact that's also where the
one of the ugly race references is made
right there in the ash heaps uh could
that be evidence of some perception of a
god that only saw that or only looked at
that area and only interacted with those
people at that time
i want to say more just that's the
remnants of god rather than god i don't
i don't see any strong presence of the
divine in that place i see kind of
remnants of god having been there in the
past and that's where the ozymandias
reference that
i think the uh
the plaque at the bottom of the statue
in the shelley poems is you know
look on my empire you weak in despair
and there's nothing there
and it's tragic and it's chilling and
it's haunting and that's what i think we
have in this place
uh god might have been there at one
point but god is no longer present
father james and i'd agree with that the
uh there is there seems to be some uh
at least
an attempt to
to try to show some sort of ceremony
that the fact that the cars have to stop
um for the you know the bridge you know
the barges to come through there's
seems like perhaps an uh um some sort of
a tipping of the hat to like the river
sticks um but i don't think
that
it i don't think the analogy is a
perfect uh
lineup i don't think you're having uh
you know heaven is his east egg and
purgatory's the ash heap and hell is is
manhattan well maybe if it's the remnant
of god maybe that area is the remnant of
heaven hell and purgatory maybe that's
all we have left is just
uh well then i'll ask you what is it
that and we'll get some questions here
and i hope that you all feel free to ask
them uh in the time that we have
remaining which i i think we have five
or five or so ten minutes coming up uh
what is it in the end that you think
gatsby believes in
what what does
where is gatsby's faith
faith in what
i think it's pathetic his faith is that
daisy's going to call him back that
daisy is going to somehow
recognize and appreciate what he has
done for her taking the rap for her hit
and run crime and we know and nick knows
everybody knows but him that he she's
never gonna call
and that's what he's waiting for at the
end and he he's
killed uh he's killed but he was already
dead because his hope was gone
it's a tragedy in fact i think it's
gatsby when there's finally the
confrontation between him and tom uh
makes the statement he says you won't be
able to take care of her
anymore in fact that not that you know
um you know she's not your woman anymore
it's not no reference about about the
relationship you won't be able to take
care of her that that's i think that's
precisely then is
he he's done all of this for her i mean
you know created this whole thing and
now uh you know he's built the world uh
kind of like bluebeard you know the
woman's not going to come into the
castle it's not you know the whole thing
collapses you know the funny i think
that uh daisy and tom are gonna have a a
very satisfactory marriage i think
they're gonna go on and it's gonna be
like this never happened there's a uh
there's a scene in a woody allen film
where woody allen walks up to this
couple and asks them if they're happy
and they say yes he says how could that
be and he says well we don't have a
thought in our heads
and that's that's tom and daisy they're
gonna just be happy go along
but there's also then that there's an
element to that though that if they are
they may be happy we know about their
problems that they had before
gatsby we those are you know there's a
laundry list of the things that they
went through um and as hollywood would
describe it you know perhaps in that
sense gatsby is a traveling angel story
that with those with whom he interacts
somehow their lives are changed forever
uh and that that that they will have a
better life but it somehow because of
some sort of purification that happened
uh as a result of this relationship
wasn't that uh jordan's uh statement is
that you know she's the
the pro golfer who's the terrible driver
and uh right she expects everyone to get
out of her way uh when she's driving
find the question of what happens when
you meet someone who's like you
expecting you to get out of the way you
know and that's and that seems to be the
that's exactly what we it seems to be a
a little metaphor for what's going on
here is that when worlds collide huh you
know as fitzgerald says though gatsby
believed in the green light
which was daisy's home daisy's home
but the unattainable that which is the
orgastic future that year by year
recedes before us it eluded us then but
that's no matter tomorrow we will run
faster stretch out our arms further and
one fine morning
and he's wrong it's that's not going to
happen and i i actually don't agree that
daisy and tom's life is better i think
it's the same i whenever i read a novel
i always ask myself who is the character
that changes in the novel
and the only one who changes in gatsby
is nick
he he sees this world he's attracted to
it and at the end of the novel he's
repulsed by the world he turns his back
on it and he goes back home
gatsby just remains this hopeful person
all the way through
tom and daisy uh they're gonna they're
gonna cheat on each other they're gonna
come back because they realize that they
love each other and they seem to
complement each other and it's gonna be
as if gatsby was in there oh yeah that
that that that man on the on long island
we used to go to his parties you know i
wonder whatever happened to him but if
it's horrible if they are happy in the
end though if if you say that they you
believe they will live happily then
something did had to have changed them
because they were not happy up until
that point and we know that from the
very beginning of the novel where
there's
there all of their conversations are
steeped in subtext and they're quite
anxious quite angry and he's quite
confused you know the hope is that maybe
after
uh the whole the loss of myrtle and the
embarrassment of it all that somehow uh
he would be a better man for it but but
you hold out no hope yeah we'll agree to
disagree it's the abusive syndrome where
where he comes back and they uh and then
it'll happen again i mean they left uh
whatever midwestern town they were in i
don't remember because he'd had this big
hot affair and this was the only way
they can get out of it and they won't be
happy in the end
ultimately
they'll they'll be in that flat area
where where they'll go back and forth
they will not change
the last time we see them together
is they're having a rather folksy little
thing around the coffee you know with a
cup of coffee in the kitchen you know
that's the as gatsby sitting outside the
window you know waiting you know waiting
and waiting but that's the last time we
see them is they seem to be having a
very domestic
sort of little interaction right there
well yeah this would be a great moment
while we still have time how much do you
have left you think we have um
about seven minutes well let's take
three or four for some questions and
then we'll have some closing comments if
anybody wanted to ask anything of our
panel about gatsby
and i know that many of you have
been
reading the novel or re-read it
so if you have anything now's the time
if you could go ahead i guess i have a
comment and i'd like you to agree or
disagree with it um when speaking of the
nobility of the human spirit um i think
it was you that said that um you think
that gatsby is uh represents the
nobility of the human spirit in this
novel and i guess
i think that it's nick in the case that
when he says something in the end where
um he says i i'm five years too old to
lie to myself and say and call me noble
or something like that and and i think
that also in
your uh your reference to the owl the
man with the owl eyes being our god
figure he's the only one that relates to
nick nick is the only one that has a
relationship with him so i mean i think
that that those two things combined are
kind of where i mean this is nick is our
nobility of the human spirit and your
thoughts on that
i agree i i think as i said nick is the
only person who changes anywhere in the
novel and that should draw our attention
to him uh when i referred to gatsby
gatsby is
kind of the the center of energy around
which all of the uh the action in the
novel uh uh surrounds and circulates and
moves around
and so uh there's something we learn
from him there's some way that we are
drawn to him as a person and uh and what
i'm seeing that we're drawn to him by is
his is his his hopefulness as he reaches
out towards something beyond himself so
i think when we're talking about nick
and we're talking about gatsby uh we're
we're we're talking about very different
things uh gatsby's a tragic figure uh
nick's
depth of character which ultimately uh
saves him i think makes him a much more
admirable figure so i don't i don't
believe we disagree he's not he's not a
purely passive narrator often that's
what you see i mean there is an arc
in his character development yeah so i
think that he's so nick is a much more
interesting character uh just from cover
to cover gatsby is he's the mainspring
of this whole thing he wind you wind him
up and and the story revolves but he
never changes but he never changes and
nick in walking away from it doesn't
walk away the same man he's witnessed
this summer and it has changed him
yeah
in that sense then do we have a
sacrificial character at all uh a
christ-like character that offers
something salvific
for either for the era or for the era
that comes after him
and i want to say yes but yeah
we uh gatsby offers himself for daisy
there and and so there is a kind of uh
uh patterning of a christ story in that
however there are two problems one is uh
what he's offering
which is his fantasy and it's it's it's
not it's a it's a soap bubble and the
second thing is the person for whom he
offers it it does not change her
and uh the thing about uh the uh the the
christ story is that it's a story which
transforms people and i'm gonna argue
that at the end of the day there's
nobody changed there's nobody
transformed not even nick
i don't know if nick nick is transformed
by his own coming of age by his looking
at this whole group of people and just
uh just withdrawing with revulsion and
that's not quite the same thing he's not
changed by uh gatsby's sacrifice he's
rather changed by his realization of the
shallowness of these people
well i think but but there is obviously
there's some some statement trying to be
made the fact that uh gatsby drags the
the stuff himself out of the you know
the garage for the pool in fact the pool
is being chlorinated you know that it's
thought they're going to drain it uh
after his last little swim in it or
whether it's float around um so there's
in chlorination so this whole notion of
cleansing and purifying um that i think
that what i understand of fitzgerald is
that he had that same disillusionment
about uh
that the jazz age where it heard was on
the fact that it relied on materialism
as being the the highest good that there
wasn't some sort of of transcendency to
it that just simply get get the most you
can and get off you know that's the
that's that's the idea and uh i think
that's what he was disappointed with was
that what had become the american dream
you know the the horatio alger uh story
i think gets perverted
in in gasping i think that's that's what
he's saying is that this thing that
supposedly made our country in fact that
he should use that whole image of that
green breast
uh of earth you know the first dutch who
would have looked upon this land you
know so i mean he's he's trying to
hearken back to this and i think what
he's saying is he's uh believing what
gatsby said we cannot go back to the
past
we have time for one more quick question
i would imagine
if we did
if anybody had one
we have a comment if we could just get
can you go ahead and point the
microphone toward her go ahead man
in the area i live i live at 57
49 there was a walleye run back in the
20s
he was still there when i got that in
the 60s
and he was kind of confused about the
character of the f scott swift jail and
coming around and kind of lonely and
trying to make contact with him and he
was a single man in this green house
right down
on the dale
so
i'm still trying to picture him as a
real person
i mean this guy's fitzgerald and i can't
picture this the writer or the character
than his player the real person but this
man feeds a lonely person how could he
write such a novel
[Laughter]
if you can't picture
either of them as
real persons it may explain why he could
write such a novel
in that
he's also perhaps grasping with his own
shallowness or or chameleon-like
character uh as he was making
transformations quick comment on that uh
no i have some final comments all right
i feel that i feel like
i when i think when i think of
fitzgerald i think of i think of nick i
mean i i visualize fitzgerald as as
speaking through nick and nick is his
personality and i i can picture somebody
like nick walking through the streets of
saint paul
one final comment please yeah i just
want to say that i don't think that
gatsby gatsby is not a theological novel
so what we've been doing here is a kind
of counter reading
and i think what gatsby is about is is
the is is the failure of this kind of
american dream and the inadequacy of it
and i think it's a it's it's a powerful
tragic novel that brings that across
father closing comments and uh i would
agree with that too in that uh
what seems to give gatsby life is hope
and once in fact there's that beautiful
quote that uh
when gatsby kisses daisy for the first
time
uh in fact it's just the one little
quick quote here it just says that
he knew that when he kissed this girl
and forever wed his unalterable vision
unutterable visions to her perishable
breath
his mind would never romp again
like the mind of god
so to me that's a very poignant
statement is that when when hope loses
its vitality
i'd like to thank everybody for making
this such a vital afternoon for us the
folks from c-span to be here uh and to
participate in this wonderful weather
that we're having this weekend in st
paul
remind you all again if you ever come to
town please look us up here
the dead theologian society meeting
regularly at the bound to be read
bookstore if i hear a round of applause
please for father james mcconville
who's uh who's still working on his
first book
and uh forever and dr david penchansky
author of what rough beast which is
available as well
and uh i'll give you as uh as a way here
of just some parting wisdom the final
line
from gatsby
so
we beat on
boats against the current born back
ceaselessly
into the past
i thank you all for being here
i remind you as you go forth from this
place
to work like you don't need the money
love like you've never been hurt and
dance like nobody's watching
deus tiamat thank you very much
[Music]
this friday night starting at eight
eastern from st paul minnesota
authors literary works and important
literary movements
and now from saint paul minnesota
american writers to the 20th century
as we examine the life and times of
short story writer and jazz age novelist
f scott fitzgerald
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
you're listening to some of the sounds
from the 1920s in america's jazz era we
are coming to you from st paul minnesota
scott fitzgerald grew up in this
neighborhood along summit avenue and
during his life could frequently be seen
here at the university club for the next
couple of hours we'll take a closer look
at the man and his literary works we're
joined by matthew bruckley who has spent
most of his life studying the man
authored and edited a number of books
and david page who teaches a course here
at st paul
on the life and works of f scott
fitzgerald thank you both for being with
us matthew brookly who was he
he was the
writer of
the richest prose ever produced by an
american author
he was a writer who wrote probingly
evocatively movingly
about the american dream
american aspiration american character
and
uh easiest way to answer the question is
he's thought of as the author of the
great american novel the great gatsby
what was happening in america at the
time politically socially well the 1920s
uh
are labeled the jazz age he was actually
the one who came up with the phrase
although he knew nothing about jazz
uh but the phrase jazz age was intended
to express an era of emotional
nervous energy it was a time of
aspiration
it was a time of confidence
and it was also
a time of great advances in the arts
literature music painting
as well as prohibition
inver hills community college is here in
saint paul david page is a professor
there also preparing a fitzgerald
conference that will take place in this
city in september how much time did he
spend here in st paul and in particular
along summit avenue
he was born september 24 1896 about four
blocks from here at 41 laurel avenue
he after two years his family moved to
upstate new york but then in 1908 they
came back to st paul lived in various
houses throughout the neighborhood he
rewrote his first novel
this site of paradise at 599 summit
where he gained his first national fame
and many of his uh uh early works were
either written here in saint paul or
based on sites here in saint paul so he
was very much tied to this neighborhood
matthew breckley where does the name
come from f scott fitzgerald
he was named for a remote kinsmen
francis scott key fitzgerald the author
of the star-spangled banner
but the connection was remote
second cousin six times removed
something like that as david paid
mentioned uh f scott fitzgerald born in
1896 take us through his early life
well his early life
coincided
uh with
america before uh world war one which
was still essentially a 19th century
america fitzgerald grew up with the code
of the american gentleman
and
it is
sometimes puzzling to find him regarded
uh as
the
quintessential american writer of the
20th century
whereas he was
really more at home in the 19th century
his writing comes out of the 19th
century
uh
tradition of the social novel and
fitzgerald was preeminently a social
historian he was other things but he was
a social historian better than anything
else
this series is taking a closer look at
our nation's history through the lives
and literary works of leading american
writers and today our focus is on f
scott fitzgerald we are coming to you
from the university club in saint paul
minnesota as always during the course of
these programs we welcome your
participation with your phone calls you
can phone in at 202 585-3890
if you are in the eastern or here in the
central time zone and for those of you
out west
202-585-3891 we'll get your calls in
just a moment when did he begin writing
boyhood
9 10 years old
he was writing such things as a history
of the united states didn't get very far
with it uh he was a born writer all
great writers are born writers
in order to understand the man
what are the factors in his life that we
need to know about mr fitzgerald you can
look up this street and get a pretty
good idea
fitzgerald grew up keenly aware
of social stratification
keenly aware of the american class
system
because he was
tortured uh by the recognition uh that
his father was a failure
and
the fathers of the boys he played with
up and down this street were successful
men
and
i think fitzgerald's i'm sure
fitzgerald's fascination
with
american society
and american money he was one of the
first american writers to write
seriously about the effects of money on
character
i'm sure that all began on this street
what was his first novel his first novel
was this side of paradise 1920 written
on this street in 1919
novel said at princeton it was the first
uh
college novel of the 1920s and has set a
pattern for what became a whole american
literary genre the college novel
and david page what do you think
influenced his writings
i think one of the greatest influences
on his writing as far as st paul's
concern and as far as his whole career
had to do with the catholic church which
had a great impact on him as a young boy
i also think his love of history uh
as professor brockley said led him to
become a social historian so the
catholic church's love of history
both influenced his writing and we've
been talking about this street summit
avenue if you can just briefly go
through the neighborhood
and what role it played in his life in
particular the church down the street uh
he wrote about
he wrote about these places in his
writing so it had that direct impact
he wrote about the cathedral he said it
was
like an imitation cathedral left
unfinished in some flemish town
in the short story the popular girl he
basically took a tour of summit avenue
and um you could i talked about the
houses down the avenue we talked about
the nathan hale statue which is just a
block from where we're standing and at
the end of the passage just
the person in the story said why did you
take me down this street and the person
said well this is our show place exactly
what professor brookly was talking about
and he said well it's a museum of
american architectural failure and so
he's always been branded with that line
but i really think he loves saint paul
and i think he had a deep affinity for
the midwest and the values that he
learned here did religion play a life in
his a role in his life i think not
he was one of those irishmen who was
able to walk away from the church and
never looked back
he
went through a period
of devoutness as a young man but i
always felt that was an act
fitzgerald loved attention he would do
almost anything to get attention and one
of one of the ways for him to get
attention uh as a teenager
uh
was to say he was going to become a
priest
uh
i
never was able to put the credence in
that
what was the great gatsby
the novel you mean oh it's a novel about
uh a poor boy uh
who
wants to be a great success and he also
wants to marry a mitch rich girl
and he gets the two things mixed up
and
he is finally destroyed by the cruel
hard rich girl
because gatsby who is an innocent naive
person uh doesn't understand how tough
and hard the rich are
let me read what you wrote about the
book in one of the uh
introductions you said that jay gatsby
is the self-american made man indeed the
self-invented man
he believes in the american dream of
success he fulfills it and he is
betrayed by it how so
well because he thinks when he makes all
this money
and embarks on a life of conspicuous
consumption
that he will be accepted
as
an american
hero
that he will have
broken the class boundaries and he finds
out
that his money buys him nothing
except the contempt of the freeloaders
who come to his parties
we'll get a call from new york city good
afternoon welcome to the program good
afternoon i am so impressed with
fitzgerald's social medias and the
topics that he selects in his books
i
i just finished the beautiful and the
damned and picked that up and
i just wanted to talk about how
fitzgerald was beyond his time
in regards to
the social mores in relationships
between men and women men and women
how the topic in that book is just
so like it is in 2002 today
[Music]
matthew is that addressed to me ma'am
is that addressed to me it is uh
the
uh the novel uh published in 1922
and rewritten while fitzgerald uh was
living
in saint paul
uh in this neighborhood
portrays
the mutual destruction
of
a married couple
and
this
certainly in the year 1922
represented
a new departure
when
marriages were not given the kind of
scrutiny
that
fitzgerald gives to the marriage of
anthony and gloria patch apart from that
it's not a good novel
you had touched on this earlier but the
relationship that he had with his
parents and his childhood growing up
here and moving around in a number of
cities what was it like
well as i said uh he was
embarrassed by his parents
his mother was regarded as eccentric
his father was known to have failed in
business
and
fitzgerald
a show-off apparently as a boy
he was difficult to be around
in order to compensate for what he
perceived of as his
social disqualifications
his mother was devoted to him uh his
mother spoiled him
uh and fitzgerald later blamed him
i'm sorry later blamed her his mother
for his subsequent
social problems
because he claimed uh that her
indulgence
uh had ruined him
made him
unaware
of other people's needs requirements
expectations
yet
he dedicated one of his books to his
mother although he did not dedicate a
book to his father
our next call from washington state good
afternoon good afternoon gentlemen
i read the great gatsby as a novel that
exposes the emptiness and the
vacuousness
of
the american dream
and i was i was wondering
what would you think fitzgerald's
reaction would be to the surprise
americans seem to feel that
peoples of the third world and
you know people with set cultures are
are horrified to see that american
mick culture or the mick worldization of
the world how would fitzgerald react to
the surprise that americans have that
the rest of the people of the world
don't want our sickening degenerate
culture in their part of the world
okay
well i have i'm sorry you're done
yes sir now i have two answers for you
number one fitzgerald was an intensely
patriotic
man
and he would have been dismayed
bewildered
uh
by the hatred
uh of america uh from other countries
2.
[Music]
the great gatsby
has become
perhaps the most widely translated
american novel of the 20th century it is
available in every language in which
words are printed uh the great gatsby
has had an enormous
effect throughout the world on
conveying to people
a sense of what america is
and i would say
about half the readers fell in love with
america
because of reading the great gatsby the
other half were mad as hell how many
novels did he write he wrote for he
published four novels during his
lifetime and on his deathbed he left a
novel that was about 70 finished the
love of the last tycoon
which was posthumously published in 1941
and dave page how many short essays did
he pin oh he he published around 160
short stories essays uh etc so he had
quite a prolific career when you
consider that he died when he was 44. he
put out quite a bit lock arbor new
jersey you're next on c-span's american
writer series go ahead please thank you
for taking my call uh just uh two very
brief questions
uh matthew broccoli pointed out that uh
that fitzgerald is as very very much a
social historian would he please comment
on fitzgerald's failure to graduate from
princeton as i understand
uh through his inability to pass a
required history world history course
and what that that may say about how
history was taught at that time
and second uh would you wish to comment
on whether or not the name gatsby is an
ironic
uh variation of the word god's boy and
we have here uh another theme that he
would like to comment on in in
throughout gatsby thank you
uh
i'll take question number two first
uh
i'm convinced that the name gatsby is a
pun on the word for the slang word for
gun gat
and gatsby is called gatsby because he
has made this fortune through
illegal
and
almost certainly gangster
ish
activities hence the name gatsby uh is
appropriate
tell me your first question sir
carla you still with us we'll move on to
new lunch did you want to follow up what
was the first question you know i don't
know i was i'm gonna go to new london
connecticut with our next call go ahead
oh hi my name is steve how are you
dropping out of princeton um just have a
comment and then perhaps i'll leave it
at that
when f scott fitzgerald wrote in his
diary right after he married zelda he
wrote that it wasn't his wealth or his
magnetism that got her but his good
looks and intelligence he goes on to say
and that always gets the girl
that in itself we know is like a bit of
a lie to himself because scott himself
knew that he couldn't marry zelda
because her father was a judge and
wouldn't approve until he had money and
of course he got it after the
publication of this side of paradise my
only comment that would lead to a
question is in the rich boy and all his
other works it's almost like this is a
writer who both has a love and a hatred
for the rich and that's very
significant says most writers like
hemingway write only about what they
love this man wrote about
the two and i think you mentioned that
earlier when you talked about gatsby
being someone who was naive and at the
same time who tried to be something that
he wasn't then my comment leaves it at
that it's scott and how that plays into
his overall
writing in terms of that
dichotomy that
love of the rich and that feeling that
he really didn't belong
uh i can't improve from what you've said
because i agree with it i would
just add
that your insight
supports the point
that fitzgerald was a far more complex
thinker a far more uh
intelligent writer than he is usually
given credit for
of all american of all great american
writers fitzgerald has received the most
abuse
he's been the most consistently
underrated and belittled writer
and
one of the lies
that has
been attached to fitzgerald
was that he was somehow a genius who
didn't know what he was doing uh that he
wasn't really very intelligent but as
you've just pointed out uh the ideas in
his work his attitudes about characters
his attitudes about america uh are
uh
indeed
complex
if we could let's try to bring in the
last two points of the callers first of
all when and why did he go to princeton
uh
fitzgerald went to princeton because it
was regarded as a gentleman's school
in his time there were only three
schools yale harvard and princeton and
he felt that princeton had an elegance
that the other two didn't have what year
was that well he was class of 17 so he
arrived in september 1913 and why did he
leave uh it is true as the caller said
it comes back to me now that he did fail
a history course but it wasn't that it
was all the other courses he failed
mainly the courses in chemistry uh and
mathematics
because fitzgerald felt quite uh
properly
that there was nothing happening in the
chemistry classes or the math classes
that he needed
by the time fitzgerald got to princeton
he knew what he was going to be he was
going to be a writer
and
he wrote uh every spare moment
at princeton when did he meet his future
wife zelda
during world war one he was a second
lieutenant
camp sheridan
outside of montgomery alabama
where he met 18 year old zelda
fitzgerald at a country club dance
i was just going to add talking about
zelda that in sami the walt she wrote
that what attracted her to fitzgerald
was his ability to dance and that's one
of the things that his mother made sure
that he knew how to do is dance he took
dad's blessings over here a few blocks
he danced at the commodore hotel and so
i think he saw that as one of the ways
that distinguished the you know the rich
is that they had time to take dance
lessons time to learn how to dance
we're gonna take a call from new york
city and then later we're gonna take you
inside this university club here in st
paul to give you a sense of what it was
like when he was here in the 1920s and
1930s but first you're on the air caller
go ahead
uh this is a question for the professor
there's a question for the professor how
revolutionary in your opinion
is the very complex
first person narrative of the often
overlooked character
nick carraway in the great gatsby and
what influence do you think this
narrative had on other writers such as
say
jd salinger
oh you really ought to have my job uh
because you've got an excellent uh eye
uh
for a prose structure the use of nick
carraway in the great gatsby as a
partially involved narrator
gives that novel most of its force
because the reader sees everything
as nick carraway tells it to the reader
and not in straight chronological order
carraway tells the story out of
chronological order and leaves it for
the reader to reconstruct
the
structure of the events in the book
and
this structural device
gives the novel much of its
effectiveness it makes gatsby believable
if gatsby told his own story nobody
would read the novel uh the novel works
because carraway serves as a gatsby's
translator
and yes sir
that
device
of the
narrator who is not the hero of the work
has
been widely
imitated or if imitation isn't the right
word
then has been widely
used by other writers
subsequent to the publication of the
great gatsby in 1925.
take a walk inside the university club
dave paige did this
university club play a role in the
social life of f scott and zelda
fitzgerald absolutely um
the building's been here for almost 100
years uh st paul landmark
he came here to socialize with his
friends when he was in college just like
many young men would
um when
after zelda had their their only
daughter scotty
in november scotty was born on october
20 1921 in november there were only five
days of sunshine
zelda was a southern girl
she didn't like being cooped up and so
fitzgerald would have parties here for
her to try to make her feel better about
st paul
as you look at this room the fireside
room is this indicative of the
architecture of the time absolutely it's
indicative of a lot of the architecture
up and down summit avenue fitzgerald
would have been very familiar with this
because he was in homes up and down the
avenue his friends lived in in homes
that would have had architecture and
furnishings much like this
matthew brooklyn before we let you go
downstairs to the bar i want to read you
something that f scott fitzgerald had
written the author ought to write for
the youth of his own generation the
critics of the next and the school
masters of ever afterward did he yes it
came out
one of the
exciting things about fitzgerald was his
ability to make dreams come true
and
fitzgerald makes a prediction
of
the evolution of his development with
his tongue in his cheek this was written
for a joking
piece uh he published for the american
booksellers association
but
uh by one of those miracles of
literature uh that boast came absolutely
true he is the great gatsby is now
probably the most widely taught
american classic
matthew breckley we'll join you
downstairs in the bar and dave page
let's take a walk inside how were the
reviews of the great gatsby during the
time that it came out in the mid 1920s
um the reviews of the great gatsby were
actually uh very very favorable um the
play based on the great gatsby got uh
fantastic reviews
um however the sales weren't as good as
fitzgerald hoped and so
he was always trying to write that
blockbuster novel but he never quite did
it um the sales today of course the
great gatsby it's one of the
best-selling books still so had he been
alive today he'd be rolling in dough but
what were the patterns in his life he
would come out with a book he'd move
around frequently come out with another
book
why is that the pattern was he was
writing short stories in order to save
up enough money to write another novel
his family lived in probably a dozen
different homes around this neighborhood
they never owned a house fitzgerald
never owned a house
so he grew up much like his family did
and so he was constantly moving around
searching for a good place to live a
place that had inspiration a place that
was cheap
so that he could save up enough money to
write that next novel joining us on the
line is eleanor lanahan who is the
granddaughter of f scott and zelda
fitzgerald she is joining us from
burlington vermont good afternoon thanks
for being with us hi bobby
hello
eleanor and eleanor lanahin what do you
know about your grandparents
um well i know what little i've heard
from my mother and what i've heard from
people who knew him and uh from books i
i've accumulated a bit of knowledge
about them
do you mean
what do i know about his time in saint
paul or
um well in general and how you think
americans view him today
[Applause]
i have the impression that he's very
much admired
by writers in particular i think an
awful lot of people love to go to
princeton in order to be able to write
like him
his writing's been it's held up
timelessly um and i think a lot of
people
relate to him as a very modern character
he definitely was dapper and
he was fresh he was and he died so young
i mean our impression of him is of
youth and
somewhat like we think of ourselves as
americans as a young country
so
we are showing our audience a picture of
your mother this is a photograph that
was taken in paris in 1925
does your mother remember moving around
a lot
yes she did my mother had very happy
childhood memories i there are people
who say well maybe she whitewashed a
little bit about her childhood because a
lot
was going on for her she was in the care
of nannies which gave her a certain
shelter from the moving about and
and scott's drinking and
by the time my mother was 10 zelda was
hospitalized so
it wasn't an easy childhood but she had
very happy memories of both parents
your mother was born when
she was born in 1921.
so she was born just a couple of years
after they were
married in october
and
it's amazing the symmetry of the
family's life i mean she was there for
the for the really best parts of their
marriage and then later after zelda was
sick she formed sort of a
family of two with her father
he looked after her incredibly
he tried to be mother and father to her
and
some of the letters that he wrote to her
have been
published in a volume that's completely
inspiring i mean it's practically a
manual of how to raise a teenager what
to expect from them it's a little harsh
i have to admit but beautifully written
this is one of those books and i know
you wrote the introduction
the love letters between your
grandparents how would you describe
their relationship
um
[Music]
first of all
scott and zelda were just fell madly
madly in love zelda was in the middle of
quite a social scene down there in
montgomery with the um
with the all the gis that were stationed
nearby getting ready to be shipped
overseas in world war one
so the balance was very much in favor of
women there were so many more men and
she
she was trained to be a flirt and to
have lots of bows so she didn't
i really don't know whether she was in
love with scott and strung him along as
a way to keep him keen or whether um
she really was you know interested in
lots of men and lots of dances
because you never knew who was going to
come back from the war and it was very
important then for her to marry well but
in any case um she clearly did end up
very much in love with him it was a bit
of a courtship and
i they were so
there's such a record of how in love
they were i don't think there's any
question about it and they were
incredibly respectful of each other's
feelings
and
scott had a huge sense of responsibility
about zelda's well-being throughout
their marriage and scott's life
and he was just absolutely devoted to
him in a way it was a different era
because she was
sort of
back up to her husband she wasn't
she wasn't modern woman by a stretch
but she did have ambitions and lots of
artistic aspirations lots of talent
and um
they inspired each other i think the
combination of the two of them together
was greater than the two of them
separate
so i we're in the fireside room of the
university
i'm sorry i i
just want to mention the audience we're
in the fireside room of the university
club uh to give our audience a sense of
what this uh town and this facility in
particular was like during the 1920s and
eleanor atlanta and i want to read what
you wrote in the introduction to this
book that we just showed our audience a
moment ago the love letters between your
grandparents oh sure you say to mention
f scott and zelda fitzgerald is to
invoke the 1920s the jazz age romance
the outrageous early success gleaming
hotel lobbies smoky speakeasies flappers
white suits and nostalgia for what is
described as the lost generation
scots alcoholism and zelda's madness are
a powerful part of that myth can you
elaborate
um
well
elaborate on their relationship in terms
of their myth
well their relationship but also what
was happening in america during that
time
that the country was really truly
celebrating and when i say that i can't
speak for um what was hap on the east
coast at least it was in full
celebration with the troops returning
from europe and
america never having been defeated in a
war and it was an it was an artist a
time of artistic explosion the music was
bursting out of harlem it was um
women were shortening their skirts and
getting away from their chaperones
you know it's funny at the same time
liquor was made illegal um but at the
very same year women got the vote so
there there are a lot of contradictions
in that era
um
california our next caller go ahead
my question actually thank you
can you hear me he's not here right now
but how about for david page go ahead
call her um you could possibly answer
i'm sure you would have an opinion what
do you think is the reason that the
great gatsby is apparently so impossible
to make into a good film
i actually
liked the film with mia farrow although
i thought mia farrow didn't do a
terrific job i think it's really
difficult to translate fitzgerald's
beautiful prose
into film i mean he uh uh was just a a
wonderfully artistic writer and um so
it's the writing that's that's that's
capturing us not the action and
uh of course in film you have to have a
lot of action so um i think that um
it's it's it's very difficult to capture
any of fitzgerald's
work on film although a couple of the
short stories have been done pretty well
if you want to get more information on
this american writer series you can log
on to our website americanwriters.org
miriam webster has put together this
american writer's dictionary which is
available on our website also for
educators you can get more information
and a lesson plan on this ongoing series
our next call is from gainesville
florida good afternoon
hello
hello i want you're on c-span's writers
series go ahead
okay i wanted to ask the uh the
gentleman mslanahan um about two women
who played a role in that scott
fitzgerald's life one is uh his first
love jenever king and another actress by
the name of lois [ __ ] and what impact
they had on his writings
well eleanor lanahin can you answer that
they both figure in his writings i'm not
sure i can tell you everything you want
to know geneva king was his first love
and
he was
inspired
i don't know whether by her or by his
imagination of her because he wrote her
volumia
voluminously and i don't think she
returned his affections as intensely she
was a girl from
a prosperous family and he definitely
wasn't from a well-to-do background so
it wasn't going to work and he
was supposed to have learned a lesson
from that and a lesson that probably is
threaded throughout his writing i think
she probably had an influence on that um
lois moran figured in tinder is the
knight
i i think it was an innocent affair but
it was enough to make
zelda quite jealous she was a young
actress i she
may have had a big influence for one
thing she was a
working girl and um i think scott would
as years went by it was it began to
admire women who worked rather than
women who were decorative or who
tended to the amenities so
um
but lois moran stirred up zelda's
jealousies pretty badly for a period of
time in there
um over to you dave what do you think
uh scott actually met you never came
just a couple blocks from here at a
party but he had already heard her name
because she was
pretty famous as a debutant he fell
immediately in love with her in fact
people expected sparks to fly here was
the um the gorgeous of scott fitzgerald
and the gorgeous rich to never king
scott would say that basically all his
female characters were jeneverking and a
mixture with zelda and uh geneva shows
up in the great gatsby in a kind of a
weird way that um she was from lake
forest and of course tom buchanan is
from lake forest and jenever king's
father base could have been one of the
models for tom buchanan eleanor lanahan
when did your when did your mother pass
away
in 1986
she had a pretty good long life
she was still in college when scott died
and so she
was in a position to
manage
the placement of his papers at princeton
she gave his papers in one big gift
which was a great thing to do
because it's made it made them available
for scholars all in one place
and she she really made sure that they
were treated fairly by history in a lot
of ways
she called it a part-time job that was
highly remunerative and
i she didn't
she really did them
did them justice i would say she
remembered the best
times
why for someone who was born in saint
paul moved around a lot was buried in
rockville maryland
well a lot of um scott's family and
zelda the sayre family came from
maryland ancestors branched out from
there the keys are buried there too
some of them
i'm not sure
not francis scott key that i know of but
eliza key is maybe a great great great
great grandmother and i think
francis scott key it was her first
cousin
so there there was a whole
sort of tradition of ancestors that are
buried there and um
actually scott wasn't allowed to be
buried there when he died he was his
books at that time were on the
prescribed list by the catholic church
so he was buried in a in the rockville
union cemetery nearby
and then zelda was buried with him when
she died
but my mother very badly wanted to get
them into the cemetery where a lot of
the
fitzgeralds and keys had been buried so
she had them i think it was 1974
or six she had them reinterred and
had and did rights by them she really um
was a good daughter i would say and my
mother is buried at their feet right
there
so that's the story got a call from
boston good afternoon hi thanks for
taking my call go ahead boston hi thanks
for taking my call i have two questions
for david page um
could you please comment on fitzgerald's
relationship with ernest hemingway and
my second question is i'm going to be
visiting st paul in june and i was
wondering where a good place to
to visit in uh
in terms of uh like museums or anything
like that
well unfortunately we don't have a
fitzgerald museum uh i'd love to get one
started but uh it takes a lot of money
um if you come up to summit avenue start
at the cathedral drive down summit it's
a five mile ride uh you'll pass many of
the places fitzgerald wrote about you
can see the university club you can walk
in here exactly where we are right now
there's just a lot of places in st paul
that have fitzgerald stories so
that's real easy to see i think
professor breckley is going to talk a
little bit about hemingway later
as far as i i kind of want to add
something matt and i probably disagree
with about this that um the catholic
church had an i think a real impact on
his life it was uh an important uh
fixture here in the city and i think
some of that catholicism of really
helping came out to fitzgerald so
fitzgerald helped a lot of writers
including hemingway and i think
hemingway resented that a little bit as
he as uh later when he became famous
himself and i didn't like the fact that
fitzgerald really had given him a really
good start eleanor lanahan are scott
fitzgerald's writings relevant today
um yes people still read him very much
so i just thought there was just a story
in the new york times about jay gatsby
being a man of our times had he lived
today he would probably
be in the upper echelons of
enron it said
and with all the corporate scandal going
on i think he yes it's very very timely
is that let me ask you about the
tombstone in rockville maryland that
includes the words from the great gatsby
so we beat on boats against the current
born ceaselessly into the past
what does that represent that phrase
it can mean so many things i think of it
very often it really just haunts me and
i think it was haunting maybe for my
grandfather because he um
i mean everything that we know
is behind us and you draw on it and you
never really get away from it i mean
we're part of that continuum and
um
i think it's a it's saying history is
important and
that we don't escape it try as we might
um
[Music]
it's saying
you know it's it's open to
interpretation i
ask dave too he may have another take on
it
eleanor lanahan who is joining us from
burlington vermont the granddaughter of
f scott and zelda fitzgerald thanks for
being with us
thank you
bye-bye
did you want to follow up um
i you know i think um
any beautiful writing is going to be
something that people want to read
so i i think people will continue to
read fitzgerald just because he was such
a
terrific
pro stylist we're in the fireside room
here at the university club dave page
will keep you up here for another 15 to
20 minutes this past week we talked with
actor and writer george plimpton among a
number of things including the
relationship between f scott fitzgerald
and ernest hemingway also fitzgerald's
drinking and a lot of writers who spent
the 1920s overseas including in paris
here's what george plimpton had to say
what were two americans doing in france
during the 20s why were they there well
france in the 20s i mean the uh it was
it was the uh of course it was the time
of affluence and there was a large
colony of um
american writers there
uh
there were salons there was gertrude
stein's cello and everything seemed to
be going on at that time there was a
there were revolutions in writing there
was pound
ezra pound and james joyce and there was
the uh
sylvia beach's bookstore where they met
it was the time when there's a
revolution going on in art you had
picasso and all that also in music you
know stravinsky
rights of supreme and it is just a
huge uh
energy and
and the toppling of all sorts of
institutions
so it was a very rich place to be in
terms of imaginative work creative work
and i think that's what drew them
i mean we originally went there for the
toronto star i went to europe for the
toronto star
uh stayed on in paris wanted righteous
gerald was there really more to
celebrate i think celebrate his success
but also become part of his very
wild
time and letters and social life as well
you mentioned alcohol what role did
alcohol play in the lives of fitzgerald
and hemingway
well i think it's sort of
it's pretty much known that it destroyed
or almost destroyed fitzgerald
he apparently had almost no capacity for
alcohol he would very few drinks would
would
set him off
he behaved apparently atrociously with
booze
sort of person at a party who say oh
things are getting out of hand here
and there are stories about him in the
south of france sort of becoming really
outrageously drunk
zelda in his letters is always
criticizing him for dragging himself
through this
drunk through the streets of paris
coming home drunk
so it was obviously a very
um debilitating thing in his case
of course in the latter part of his life
he
through
he quit
but in the paris days for sure
also in these letters he occasionally
says i'm going on the wagon
there's always usually a line or two in
these letters about whether he's going
to be able to stop drinking or not
christmas is coming i'm getting
off the wagon and that sort of stuff
we're in the lower level now the varsity
bar here at the university club matthew
brooklyn thanks again for being back
with us did his drinking
affect his financial difficulties in his
lifetime
well
he would go on prolonged vendors and
obviously uh his drinking uh
reduced his writing time
but
uh
fitzgerald as i said
earlier uh is a writer uh
who
is the victim
of slander
and
he was no more of a drunk
than
most american most great american
writers of his time
and
uh even though the drinking
interfered with the writing he never
wrote drunk uh he insisted that he
couldn't write drunk yet in 20 years he
produced a more than respectable
cannon
uh he did not waste his life drinking he
just drank too much
can you explain though what george
plimpton was referring to when he said
that f scott fitzgerald was not a good
drinker well my friend george is right
fitzgerald's problem was not that he was
an alcoholic but rather that he was an
alcoholic with a low capacity
for booze
hemingway and faulkner outdrank
fitzgerald uh fitzgerald as george said
got very drunk
on what would have been
a small amount of alcohol for ernest
hemingway
the man
the irony one of the many ironies
about fitzgerald is the most celebrated
uh alcoholic in american literature was
not a
two-fisted drinker a two-finger drinker
we're looking at the life and times of
that scott fitzgerald who was born in
1896 and died at the age of 44. our
phone lines are open at
202-585-3890 if you're in the eastern
half of the country and for those of you
out west
202-585-3891 as we get a call from
baltimore good afternoon
baltimore you with us yes yes
go ahead please um actually my question
was for uh dave page uh but maybe uh
professor brookly can answer it as well
uh i wondered about sixty day page is
upstairs so he can hear it
arden
go ahead with your question okay okay um
i wondered about fitzgerald's reputation
in minnesota itself um as i understand
uh minnesotans are not
or at least in the past were not all
that excited about uh their native son's
uh reputation uh there was a statue i i
i understand erected some time ago and
and people were not that excited about
it and i wondered about his reputation
today in minnesota my other question has
to do with
catholicism
um
mr page has mentioned uh that he he
thinks catholicism
influenced fitzgerald quite a bit and i
wondered how strictly he was raised as a
catholic as a child and where he might
have gone to church and hi dave this is
joan thank you caller
hi john
um
uh what was the first question again it
was about uh the reputation today how he
well actually i think the reference to
the question his uh how he was viewed
during his time and then once he passed
away in minnesota um during the time i
think people who were his friends liked
him uh his parents were considered a
little bit eccentric i think people
didn't particularly like zelda and if
you talk to people there's a couple
different versions
some people say that the reason why
saint paul lights didn't like fitzgerald
is because he didn't go to church on
sunday um some other people uh don't
particularly like him because he loves
st paul in 1922 and never came back
today that once again there's still a
love hate uh relationship with
fitzgerald you almost rarely see a
newspaper article in this city about
fitzgerald without the words drunkard in
front of his name
and so you can see that
as far as
and that's how people see him today
and the catholicism question again was
about
where he went to church
the
he was baptized here in the city
his family was very very much involved
in the catholic church uh here
the cathedral was unfinished so they
didn't go there but his family gave
money to visitation convent and he often
went out there to perform literally
perform for the nuns uh read poetry sing
songs things like that so he didn't have
a real strict catholic upbringing
but yet he did have a
i would say a fairly average catholic
upbringing in the cathedral of saint
paul which is about a half a mile from
where we are situated here at the
university club on summit avenue in this
city the twin cities of minnesota our
next call is from denver go ahead please
hi um fitzgerald once wrote
there are no second acts in american
lives and i wondered
for anyone
what do you think he meant by that and
how did it apply to his own life
i believe he meant that
the trade trajectory of american careers
is very steep
that americans peak early and burn out
early
and my recollection is
that the remark was inspired by general
grant's career
that after the
the civil war
although grant became president he
was never
able to regain uh his
greatness uh but put general grant aside
uh
fitzgerald felt that americans burn out
or peak early
matthew berkeley to get a sense of the
the social
side of this community in the 1920s you
brought along a parody of a newspaper
that was from january 13
1922
who wrote it and what does it represent
uh at this club on the 13th of january
1922
there was a bad luck bad luck ball
because it took place on the 13th of the
month friday and at midnight
[Music]
fitzgerald had news boys distribute a
parody newspaper
would you reach it please sure a parody
newspaper
uh
saying that
the cotillion is sad failure
uh this is the kind of joke that
fitzgerald enjoyed it's the kind of joke
he was good at
uh he almost certainly wrote
uh some maybe most of the articles but
since nothing is by lined we don't know
which articles fitzgerald was
responsible for but the whole thing
was fitzgerald's idea and again this is
during prohibition period 18th amendment
businesses rotten says the bootlegger
chuck kennedy a well-known bootlegger of
this vicinity gave out an interview to
our reporter in which he says business
is no good
what do you think he was talking about
it's probably
a joke about somebody named kennedy
the whole thing is filled with jokes
that no one can get now
uh because they refer to people who are
50 years dead
but the whole thing
is an elaborate hoax
uh
frightful orgy at university club is the
headline at the upper left
and
uh
five copies of this is a facsimile five
copies of the original i have survived
charleston south carolina good afternoon
hey neighbor hi how you doing
hi can you hear me doing fine
uh what i wanted to find out if grad if
gadsby is represents america in the
1920s and fitzgerald wrote the great
american novel of that time what would
you compare
in this time in this day and age are
there any novels that compare
you know to gatsby in terms of our
situations and present present-day
america
america is lucky we always have great
novels and great novelists
i would think
that
one of the novels that should be uh
cited uh as a great post-world war ii
american novel is certainly
uh joseph heller's catch-22
many people uh would put
catch you in the rye on the list i'm not
so sure about that
david page teaches here in the st paul
area at inverse hill community college
and matthew bruckley is a teacher from
columbia south carolina at the
university of south carolina what is the
fitzgerald collection
the universe the thomas cooper library
at the university of south carolina has
uh the most comprehensive f scott
fitzgerald collection
known to man or beast
it includes not only books buying about
fitzgerald but letters
manuscripts artifacts memorabilia it was
planned
as a research collection a working
collection
it is there to be used by students by
teachers by faculty
scholars come from all over the world to
use it i brought along one of our
exciting items this is the notebook
fitzgerald carried around uh in
hollywood
when he was making notes for what proved
to be
his unfinished masterpiece
the love of the last tycoon his
hollywood novel
and
the address was garden of allah
the return address garden of allah
hollywood which was a hotel an apartment
hotel that fitzgerald lived in when he
was working for mgm
and here
are the notes fitzgerald made about
his impressions of hollywood the first
one is
thing to conceal is low-caliber caliber
of men one's dealing with
we welcome our next call from anchorage
alaska
good afternoon
uh my question is there was uh the
caller made reference to tom buchanan
earlier of the great gatsby and i'm
curious uh is buchanan considered a
purely uh totally fictional figure is he
rooted in some person who
who fits gerald new or do uh do you
think that he is a
group of people perhaps
thank you
david page
as i mentioned previously i think part
of tom buchanan's
were fitzgerald got tom buchanan was
from geneva king's father
i think his name was charles king and uh
he was a
big magnate in lake forest uh um
illinois and that's where tom buchanan's
from and so um and
supposedly it was charles king that that
said the line you know poor boys don't
marry rich girls and fitzgerald probably
resented that since he was in love with
his daughter
as we travel around the country for this
american writers series we also bring
along one of the two c-span school buses
which one is here in st paul yesterday
outside the bound to be read bookstore
on grant avenue across from summit
avenue here in st paul and we have a
group of people who are watching this
program from over there and that's where
our next call comes from go ahead please
hi my questions for uh either gentlemen
i had read somewhere that hemingway once
once mentioned that
he felt fitzgerald sold his writing
short by marketing by selling for the
mass market
and my second question involves uh one
of the most humorous short stories i've
ever read involved the baby was born
like 70 years old and as he aged
he got younger and i was wondering if
fantasy was a job
the story about the the
the man who grows up backwards is called
the curious case of benjamin button
uh fitzgerald had a weakness for fantasy
and he wrote uh several stories uh
dealing with fantastic supernatural uh
events
uh some are good some aren't good one of
the best is set in st paul it's called a
short trip home
uh i recommend it uh to everyone
who hasn't read it have scott fitzgerald
a short trip home
uh
and i've forgotten your first question
anybody remember the first question
i want to ask both of you dave paige and
uh matthew brockley why did you become
interested in that scott fitzgerald and
what do you find most interesting about
the man matthew brooklyn we'll begin
with you yeah i became interested
because when i was a senior in high
school
uh i read uh
some writings by a writer no one had
ever heard of
named f scott fitzgerald
and i realized that i'd never read
a writer who wrote so well
in the view of an 18 year old expert
uh
and why have i spent
uh the next 60 odd years of my life 55
years of my life with fitzgerald the
answer is because i haven't been able to
use them up
he keeps he keeps getting better
and david page
what's your own interest in this man as
professor brockley already mentioned
fitzgerald was
prophetic and about his own life and he
said things like i want to marry the
beautiful girl and become the world's
greatest author and and someone who can
set a goal like that and then achieve
that goal is
something that intrigues me and then of
course once i started reading about him
once i moved to saint paul and came to
summit avenue i was hooked
next call from fort washington new york
go ahead please yes i have a question uh
i understand that
he
he was living in kings point when he
rode gatsby and the east egg and west
egg
oh great nick which is king's point
that's the northern part and that
manhattan harbor as you look out from
plum point over to king's point and vice
versa was the physical landscape the
other thing is the writer
unsuccessful writer going to hollywood
as followed in the movie barton fink
could you discuss those two questions
thank you for the series
well for the setting of the great gatsby
it's loosely
based on the north shore of long island
fitzgerald did not
work
close to his sources
so yes uh
westag uh
is loosely roughly great neck
uh as for uh
the barton think movie
uh i did see it uh and it seemed to me
that there was more of william faulkner
as the drunken southern writer than
there was of scott fitzgerald in it
he brought along a couple of items from
f scott fitzgerald's life including this
whiskey flask with a date september 13
1918 from his wife zelda
what's inscribed in it and how did you
come across this when
fitzgerald
uh was shipped
or his unit was shipped out of uh
alabama uh presumably going overseas uh
to fight in france uh some of
fitzgerald's friends in montgomery
chipped in and bought him this very nice
uh flask
and uh
it is inscribed forget among other they
all uh put a sentiment on it uh but one
of these sentiments is forget me not
zelda uh fitzgerald did not get overseas
the war ended
while he was in new york waiting
to get on the troop ship
and for the rest of his life he
regretted
that he didn't get over
he wanted to
experience battle
and where did i get this flask
someone found it in a porn shop in
florida
and asked me to authenticate it
and
uh
he subsequently
must have wanted the money uh because he
contacted me and asked me if i would buy
it from him and of course i was
delighted to do so how much
guess
uh
my guess is somewhere between 500 more
than 500 less than a thousand
our next call from los angeles good
afternoon
uh comment on an earlier call about how
the world presents america's degenerate
ways i think uh the world also admires
america greatly in fact it's hard to go
anywhere and not the america the
american way of life being adapted and i
think that duality fitzgerald depicted
very well integrates gatsby in the
person of gatsby whom you admire and
also despise
and he there was a duality about him he
came out to hollywood
wrote perhaps the most insightful book
on it the last tycoon which he didn't
finish yet he never understood the town
he could never make a living here he
used to tell dorothy parker that
hollywood is the land of infinite
possibilities and she who was much more
successful would say yes it's the land
of
infinite impossibilities so if there's
any comment on those thank you
well it is true
that fitzgerald was an unsuccessful
screenwriter he just didn't understand
the way the studios ran
and by nature he was incapable of
collaboration he felt quite properly why
should he let some illiterate hack
tinker with his writing well the answer
is because the illiterate hack was a
better screenwriter than he was
uh but fitzgerald never
was comfortable in hollywood but yet
uh he was such a sensitive observer such
a sharp observer that he was able to
write
what is even in its unfinished state
one of the three good books about
hollywood
and the best of the three i think
this briefcase uh and again a lot of
references to the number of homes that
he had on this briefcase
597 fifth avenue in new york city that's
the address of the scribner building
charles scribner's son says publisher
making the point
that his publisher was really his only
permanent address
and that's the name he had
printed a return address he had printed
on his uh briefcase
because
his life was what's called peripatetic
uh rented a apartment to rent a house
hotel room to hotel room
it is
miraculous
that fitzgerald managed to preserve
so much of his literary
material
manuscripts
uh
incoming mail
proofs
uh
of his work uh
moving around the way he did and because
fitzgerald was a saver uh
fitzgerald's
uh fitzgerald the state of fiscal
research and scholarship is so good the
two great fitzgerald scholars were f
scott fitzgerald and his daughter
scholarly scottie
uh because they both
preserved uh fitzgerald's material
scotty when she was under pressure to
break it up and sell it piece by piece
did he feel at home at places like this
university club
i
i never socialized with the man but
based on what you know about him but
he liked uh
gatherings at which uh
his friends were having a good time
so i i would think that
he would have enjoyed himself
uh in this room uh belly up to this bar
we're gonna take a walk outside and
again show you another perspective of
the veranda which is here at the
university club and as we do dave page
we'll take a look at the skyline outside
the saint paul skyline today what would
he have seen
when he was here in the 1920s
well much of the saint paul skyline has
changed dramatically as most cities have
as you would expect what you're looking
out outside is is the high bridge that's
a landmark in saint paul it was rebuilt
a few years ago
to connect the east and west banks and
the mississippi
you're looking down basically at the
flats along the mississippi river and
the reason why st paul is here is
because geographically it was the
highest point on the mississippi river
boats could get to and it had a natural
levee and so it became a transportation
hub and james j hill came for that
reason and built his railroad
we got a call from tallahassee florida
good afternoon hi i was wondering um
what what was fitzgerald's favorite book
and who did he admire like before his
time
like philosopher writers
i don't know anything like that thank
you
i can i can tell you who fitzgerald's
favorite poet was john keats
and he could recite
uh
keita's uh sonnets
of
the eve of saint agnes uh was one of
fitzgerald's uh favorite uh poems
uh
he was
probably better read in 19th century
english lit than he was in american lit
uh although uh
he was widely read and
commented intelligently
on other writers writings
and it is noteworthy uh that
he was not envious uh of the success of
other writers he really was happy
when a
competitor came along for example he was
one of the writers who embraced uh
thomas wolfe's look home with angel
fitzgerald was so happy that another
american genius had emerged
if you've just joined us we're about
midway through our look at the life of s
got fitzgerald c-span's american writer
series and we're on the other side now
of the university club on the veranda
overlooking the mississippi river and
the saint paul skyline
if you've just joined us dave page let's
quickly go through his life when he was
born here where he grew up and some of
his early childhood homes
yeah he was born at 481 laurel avenue
september 24 1896
he
lived there for a short time it's a
very
lovely apartment building there were
probably servants quarters in the back
although it was an apartment building
you can see a picture of the laurel
avenue house on the screen right now it
really hasn't changed much since
fitzgerald was there the sign says 1893
that's when the building was built not
when fitzgerald was born
it was one of the cornerstones in the
redevelopment of the area because people
refused to let it be torn down they said
fitzgerald was born here and so people
uh uh bought the building and fixed it
up and now the neighborhood has just uh
had an incredible revival and you can uh
thank scott fitzgerald for that we
welcome our next call from los angeles
go ahead please
hi my question is for mr page or mr
riccoli
um my question is about
jay gatsby
and uh
how his character relates to the
character of f scott fitzgerald to me
one of the
redeeming characteristics or character
traits of jay gatsby was his capacity to
dream
and more importantly to feel and i was
wondering do you think that there was
anything extraordinary about f scott
fitzgerald's sensitivity as a person or
as an emotional being
[Applause]
dave
um
james gatz of course in in the in the
great gatsby is from minnesota he he
meets dan cody up in duluth harbor and
and gets on his yacht and sails around
the world so
james gatz is definitely a midwestern
boy much like fitzgerald did who was a
little bit ashamed of his father
fitzgerald himself claimed that he
became a writer in his mother's womb
because
two earlier um siblings had died at the
time when his mother was carrying him
and so he would i i think he would say
and i would agree that
that he
kind of had some sensitivity
passed on to him you know by his mother
and so i would say certainly he was very
sensitive and a very romantic person who
believed in
his own capabilities and matthew brookly
the great gatsby is that book a
reflection of the 1920s
yeah sure
it's the work that has taught people how
to think about the 1920s
the wild parties the extravagance uh the
people with unexplained and
unexplainable fortunes the suggestion of
the beginning of gangsterism and
racketeering
uh
sure
it's
the
the book that most people especially
most
europeans
regard as an accurate portrayal of
american society
in the 1920s and yet at the same time
there was the the harlem renaissance
going on in new york city connection
between the two fitzgerald was totally
unaware of it
uh
i'd be a liar if i tried to make a
connection yes it was happening uh but
fitzgerald was unaware i had no
connections as i said earlier
uh
the 20s was the great
uh decade of american jazz
louie young strong duke ellington jelly
roll mort and bessie smith i doubt if
fitzgerald would have recognized those
names
elkins west virginia good afternoon yes
i seem to recall a film uh it was either
about
scott fitzgerald or based on his life
i starred gregory peck and deborah carr
and i think deborah carr played somebody
who came after zelda she was
incapacitated at the time and
they were still married but uh this
other one under this later person uh was
his companion for some time i wonder if
you could comment on the film and uh
if you saw it or recall it you recall
what i'm talking about
yeah the movie uh
was called beloved infidel and was about
f scott fitzgerald and sheila graham
who was his companion in hollywood uh
in the last two and a half years of his
life
and i regard you you can hear uh
various uh judgments appraisals of
sheila graham i regard her as one of the
heroines of american literature uh
because she kept fitzgerald alive uh she
tried to keep him sober and
what we have of his last book the love
of the last tycoon
uh we have because sheila graham uh kept
as scott fitzgerald alive
uh
longer
than
he probably would have lived uh had he
been on his own in hollywood and
drinking
what led to some of the troubles in the
marriage between f scott fitzgerald and
zelda
in the latter years of his life
well uh
there is no kind way to say it uh
zelda says
uh was deranged
before
f scott fitzgerald ever saw her uh he
didn't drive her crazy
she was crazy all by herself
and it was a marriage
between
two
extravagant
undisciplined
self-indulgent people
that
it was
a marriage
uh
in which
two people
did terrible things to each other
and one of the partners uh eventually uh
became institutionalized
is not truly surprising well how do you
explain the love letters back and forth
they don't require explaining uh
they fell in love with each other
and
there's no accounting for love
i think fitzgerald
i think guess
fitzgerald had second thoughts when it
was too late
but when he met her
she was 18
and
a legendary southern bell already at
least a famous southern bell already
he was
a 20 year old
army officer expecting to go overseas
and die
their
early romance was charged
with romantic sentimental
circumstances
and
she became part of fitzgerald's dream of
success and he had to have her and he
got her
uh
and
after he got her uh
it uh
wasn't what uh
he expected however it must be said uh
that fitzgerald remained loyal to her
uh when she had to be institutionalized
he saw to it that she got the best
treatment money could buy
he did not divorce her unlike other
wives who other writers rather who trade
in wives with every book
fitzgerald always kept his promises
fitzgerald's always did his duty
fitzgerald was really
a man who could be
admired
for his
devotion uh commitment uh to his family
and
even though uh he no doubt uh
bitterly regretted uh the circumstances
of his marriage nonetheless uh he saw to
it that his wife
had the best care
that money could buy
when he had money and when he didn't
have money
matthew berkeley has spent about 50 plus
years
studying f scott fitzgerald we're going
to get a call from sterling heights
michigan good afternoon oh good
afternoon um can you hear me
uh yes ma'am okay uh this is a comment
well toward paige first of all my name
is maria jonah i'm calling from michigan
i'm a bit of a writer of myself but
nowhere in a sphere it's just gerald as
i would love one day but
uh
i had to analyze gatsby in high school a
little bit at college and i just want to
say as a writer what made f scott
fitzgerald as a great writer
was not his prose styling yes he was a
beautiful pro stylist as mr page says
but that's secondary what's primary what
made him a great writer was the ability
the absolute magic to couch the great
facts of humanity of life our capacity
of hope
things that really target our hearts
rings and to be able to put him in
beautiful prose that's what made
fitzgerald a great writer also it's for
zelda
it is disrespectful that we say she's
crazy i wish we could be kinder the way
we describe her i believe she was a
woman in her own right
i believe she was very intelligent and i
believe she was inspiration for uh some
of fitzgerald's writing and i i think as
a woman she was frustrated being in the
shadow
among other things but um
i also believe that fitzgerald perhaps
fancied himself a bit as the great
gatsby because the great skiatsky is a
loner and the writer is a loner and and
he's there with his dream and and
sometimes all we have is our dream to
keep us warm at night and and some of
our dreams as corrupt as they may be are
founded on the pure pasture that is hope
so i'd like to say it wasn't just this
pro style it's because it insults the
intelligence of the reader it's not
enough to say that his words were pretty
and sounded like music to our ears they
were music to our ears because he knew
the words because he knew what went into
those words it was his passion it was
his soul is under his deep understanding
of humanity and i'd like to say and call
me a little bit biased i think this uh
hemingway was a little bit jealous of
that because fitzgerald brought up gold
when he dug into the dirt into the grime
into the soil into the darkness of of
the human heart and where conrad found
pestilence i'll stop you there
thank you we'll stop you there and get a
response from dave paige um i i don't
think we disagree i think a lot of
people have deep passions in themselves
and and um it's it's the fact that he
could express them
that
makes him so readable today and will
make him readable a hundred years from
now so i don't disagree with that um i
think and i also agree with the fact
that zelda probably married the one man
in the united states that could upstage
her
i think one of the tragedies of
fitzgerald's life is that um
you know when zelda was
institutionalized his own mother died in
an insane asylum as well no and so
fitzgerald was um
you know
you know dealing with
a couple of these
issues
uh-uh dave
molly molly mcquillen fitzgerald did not
die in an insane asylum well i
i have a birth certificate and have have
been to the place it's it's still a uh
an asylum for uh people with mental
disabilities so
um
yeah i i think he was probably dealing
with that as well yeah when the show is
over we'll have a fight about that sure
we'll go back to your calls on that note
milwaukee good afternoon
uh yes a question for professor uh
brooklyn i was hoping he could comment
on the accuracy of hemingway's portrayal
of fitzgerald in a moveable feast
hemingway was a mean son of a [ __ ] uh
and
everything he says
about fitzgerald in a moveable feast uh
has only one witness ernest hemingway
uh no one else supports documents
uh the charges hemingway makes against
fitzgerald
uh
i think uh
that
a movable feast should be read as
a brilliant nasty piece of fiction uh it
is not trustworthy on fitzgerald yes uh
it was motivated i'm sure
by fitz hemingway's envy
of fitzgerald that fitzgerald could do
things that hemingway couldn't do
hemingway's a very good critic he knew
how good
fitzgerald was
and
it is unfortunate that
people have read a movable feast as
gospel
as having what hemingway called the true
gen not only about fitzgerald
but the other people in the book i
recommend people to read my book
fitzgerald and hemingway where you will
find the true gen about this very uh
difficult friendship and let me remind
our audience the next installment of
this program from key west florida as we
look closer at the works of ernest
hemingway what led to the 18th amendment
why did america have prohibition
because
alcoholism heavy drinking uh in
particular the saloon
uh
one of the
forces opposed
uh to
drinking one of the forces that put
across uh the 18th amendment the
prohibition amendment was the
anti-saloon league uh
where
working men who got paid in cash stopped
off on the way home and drank up their
week's wages and the wife and children
starved
there was an alcohol problem
prohibition was not
the way to solve it because
uh it turned out that prohibition
changed uh american drinking habits it
didn't stop american drinking uh it made
uh drinking uh respectable it made
drinking an act of rebellion
against what was regarded as a
puritanical law
and not only that
it had something to do with the exodus
to europe during the 20s the so-called
expatriate movement in which so many
writers artists musicians
uh went uh to france paris in particular
they didn't go there to drink they went
there to get away from a country in
which
a prohibition amendment could be passed
and dave page we heard earlier from
eleanor lanahan who is the granddaughter
of zelda and f scott fitzgerald she
wrote about speakeasies in in the
introduction to that new book on the
love letters between these two people
i don't know if you can answer this
question or not but would this club have
been a place where alcohol was produced
or made would this have been equivalent
to a speakeasy well i don't think it was
produced or made here but i'm certain
that it was uh the people had drinks
here um just right up the street the
commodore hotel used to knock twice on
the door and get into the basement there
was a speakeasy there he lived there for
a while so um st paul was actually
pretty notorious there was a lot of
alcohol flowing during prohibition here
dave paige we're going to join you uh
appropriately enough down here at the
bar in just a couple of minutes
in the meantime we'll get a call from
redlands california
good afternoon you're on c-span's
american writers series yes hi thank you
for taking my call i was wondering a
question for either mr page or mr
piccoli on
the similarities of the american view or
the american dream uh between nathaniel
west and f scott fitzgerald i've been
as of late
told that they had similar views is that
true sir
uh
west uh and fitzgerald were actually
good friends in hollywood a very
unlikely friendship
uh and
you might say
that
comparing fitzgerald's the love of the
last tycoon with west's day of the locus
uh
is
seeing of
the
visible uh
side of hollywood in fitzgerald of and
in west you saw the invisible side of
hollywood uh and
west regarded hollywood is so grotesque
that he wrote a novel about grotesque
people uh engaged in grotesque behavior
they're very different books
we're about a quarter mile of even that
from the mississippi river did he write
at all about this river or did it have
any influence
in his works not that i know of sir not
that i know of our next call is from new
orleans louisiana good afternoon
speaking of the mississippi yeah go
ahead colleen mississippi i'm calling
from the other end of the mississippi
and i've got two questions one is i live
on britannia street here in in new
orleans
and i believe that um
scott fitzgerald lived here at a certain
point in his early years for a short
period
wondered if mr uh brookly could uh
could um clarify that the other question
i have is
there's a story about uh ring lardner
um
scott having been involved
knowing ring lardner that there was some
uh
in
some of ring lardner's influence on
scott's creative process during the
writing of gatsby and i wondered if you
could talk about that thanks
number one uh fitzgerald lived on
britannia street new orleans during the
winter
uh
of 1919 1920
uh because he was convinced uh that he
was in danger of tuberculosis and he
wanted to leave uh the cruel winter of
uh minnesota and go to new orleans uh he
didn't stay there very long but while he
was there he wrote a short story
entitled the camel's back and he claimed
to have written it overnight
uh as for ring lardner uh
laudner and fitzgerald were
great friends uh fitzgerald
was heartbroken uh about lordna's uh
inability to fulfill
his genius and lordna turns up twice in
fitzgerald's work he's probably uh owl
eyes in the great gatsby and he is abe
north and tender is the knight
uh and moreover fitzgerald wrote an
obituary for lardner entitled ring
which is
one of fitzgerald's masterpieces of
non-fiction prose
the decade began with warren g harding
in the white house followed by calvin
coolidge and then herbert hoover
did he have any influence on political
leaders of the time
fitzgerald listed himself in who's who
was a socialist which is amazing
later on in hollywood he regarded
himself as a liberal but not in the
sense that people call themselves
liberals now fitzgerald was largely
apolitical
uh for example he did not get involved
in the sacko vanzetti case he didn't
sign any of the protests
uh
fitzgerald
regarded
politics and politicians uh
with
something between suspicion and cynicism
matthew brookley is here we're joining
dave page in just a moment but first a
call from fitzgerald force michigan
any connection with the name
good afternoon gentlemen uh
my family is broadly fitzgerald and
butler and
i don't think there's any familial
affinity between our name and uh f scott
fitzgerald
i hope you re your listeners are aware
of the fact that
f scott is named after francis scott p
a distinct relative uh i uh will had the
president reach the luxury of spending
uh some time with ernest hemingway in
venice at harry's bar
and we discussed fitzgerald and a lot of
anomalies in some of hemingway's writing
about the upper peninsula of michigan
trout versus youth for example big
two-hearted river which he named
the big two-hearted because he didn't
like the name fox at the
ancient community a modern community
called uh uh cassini michigan well
anyway i might
call her what year was that
oh what year was that when you had that
conversation i would say
1949.50 around 19
uh 68
i think
somewhere in there no sir he committed
no he committed suicide in 61.
49.50 you're right i forget how many
years have elapsed it was 50th
but it was 1958.
but you
you you've got diamonds sir would you
please write me at the university of
south carolina and i'd like to do an
interview with you for the uh record uh
because
no one uh knows the the things that you
just mentioned please contact me
department of english university of
south carolina columbia south carolina
well i'd be happy to
i did ask hemingway if he had the
inspiration on uh
fitzgerald and fitzgerald uh did he have
any distinct influence on hemingway and
heavily said no we practiced uh in
distinctly separate literary worlds and
i've also wondered about that but i
think they did have an influence on each
other and i will contact you at the
university of southern south carolina
right
good thank you thank you caller thank
you
another connection with ernest hemingway
and hayden
hey dirt
falls church virginia good afternoon i
have a brief question for professor
broccoli
um one of the major criticisms
apparently
of scott fitzgerald was that he was
overly preoccupied
and over and only wrote exclusively of
of rich people it wasn't a comprehensive
view of america or of society uh in
general but only of rich people
and after getting through that professor
if you don't mind giving us a brief
evaluation as to the present standing in
literary circles as between um
fitzgerald and hemingway it seems to be
an ebb and flow generation ago people
said it was hemingway
and now uh the
flow seems to be coming back to
to scott fitzgerald so thank you very
much for your comments
second question
the
reputations of fitzgerald and hemingway
uh go up and down like the dow jonah dow
jones average uh fitzgerald is now
leading hemingway in sales the great
gatsby outsells the old man in the sea
and every time i see a sales report i
laugh like hell because i can imagine
what's going on in that great saloon in
the sky when hemingway and fitzgerald
see the royalties reports
we're going to get a call from
sacramento california walk back inside
to the varsity bar here at the
university club in st paul go ahead
caller
fitzgerald's popular reputation seems
focused on the glamour of the rich in
the jazz age
given that reputation where does the
short story a diamond as big as the ritz
with its violence and surprisingly high
body count fit into fitzgerald's body of
work
thank you
oh the dime the diamond as big as the
ritz is an allegory about the effects of
money
uh
braddock washington is the richest man
in the world
and his wealth destroys his humanity
it's a family in which they routinely
invite children to come for a holiday
and then murder them
and
those
readers
who see fitzgerald incorrectly as a
worshiper of the rich or to read or
reread diamond as big as the ritz
because that is a novel that expresses
disgust
with the effects of wealth
on
character
let me just point out something about
this bar i'm going to try to move back a
little bit and see if we can get some of
the the etchings that are here including
yale and dartmouth
princeton
it keeps coming up
these ivy league schools
why is that
well because
at that time
the
well-off people
in
st paul
and
other
american cities sent their children uh
to new england to be educated
new england was the land of prep schools
and colleges
and it is not surprising
uh and princeton sort of counts as new
england
it is not surprising then
that most of the
colleges and universities
engraved on the bar
are
either ivy league schools or new england
schools uh
fitzgerald was one uh he when he was
threatened with the university of
minnesota he regarded that almost
as a form of living death
and fitzgerald was one of the
midwesterners
for whom
the great eastern colleges and
universities were the inevitable
destination
i got a call from long branch new jersey
good afternoon hi how are you i was
curious to know if scott fitzgerald and
henry miller knew each other and whether
or not there was any influence on each
other
dave you want that one boy i i don't
know the answer is no the answer is no
easy no
no no connection sir yeah i didn't think
so i've never heard of a connection
next is lake hughes california we'll
take another view outside to show you
the skyline of st paul
go ahead please yeah hi
um thank you for taking my call
um
i'm uh i'm the owner and uh co-founder
of the theater in hollywood called the
met theater
and it just happens that the
metropolitan opera
also called the met
in new york is doing gatsby
the great gatsby as an opera and we are
just starting in pre-production on a
play
off fitzgerman's called gatsby in
hollywood by josh rebel and i was
wondering if uh the professor recalled
he knew
if this was part of a revival
or if the interest in
fitzgerald um
just the circumstance right now
it's very interesting i just happen to
be watching and working on
on gatsby and hollywood at the med
theater and we also know of the uh the
metropolitan opera doing the opera of
the great gatsby
you're right it's not a revival anymore
it was a revival back uh in the 50s
peaking around 1960
now it's more like a resurrection
fitzgerald
is permanently
placed at the top
of american fiction
the revival though is worth commenting
on um because there have been
revivals
in american literary history the
melville revival the hermann melville
revival immediately comes to mind but i
know
and that was created in english
departments uh the wonderful thing
about the fitzgerald revival is it
wasn't done uh by english professors it
was done by readers going into
bookstores and asking for his books it
was a spontaneous
revival and i think
it can be regarded as the
strongest
most enduring revival in
american literary history it was a
wonderful thing uh he died regarding
himself a failure he died believing that
he was forgotten
and
now
uh
he is
one of the big three of the 20th century
american novelists
faulkner fitzgerald hemingway
and if i had dared to say that when i
got into fitzgerald business in 1949 uh
i would have been regarded as deranged
was he a tall man and no are there are
there any recordings of what he sounded
there is one recording of his voice
which i found
above his possessions at princeton
uh he went to one of those booths they
used to be in which you put a quarter in
the slot
and you got a little one-minute
recording of your voice
and in the recording he recites poetry
uh shakespeare and mace field
uh
size
five seven
uh
pounds
150 pounds tops
but when he was drunk
uh
he thought he was the heavyweight
champion of the world
our next call is from atlanta georgia
hi afternoon thanks for your call from
uh emory university uh what sort of life
did f scott fitzgerald uh lead at
princeton was he rowdy was he well-known
was he recluse was he uh good with women
dave um fitzgerald was very very
interested in writing and so immediately
he started
writing uh
shows for the triangle club and his goal
was to become president of the triangle
club and he also acted in those shows
and he was
known as a pony he was a female actress
because of course or actor
because there were only men on princeton
so he played female roles and and he was
very popular at that he did not
study very hard people in saint paul his
friends in saint paul who went out to
school with him there
mentioned that he
would rather
spend time practically doing anything
than studying chemistry
our next call is me too
we want to show our audience some of the
scenes around saint paul some of the
landmarks including a statue dedicated
as scott fitzgerald as we get this next
call good afternoon
hi hello park city utah go ahead okay
i'm sorry i didn't hear you um i'd like
to know more about the relationship
between fitzgerald and thomas wolfe
and also i'd like to hear um
your guest's opinion as to how
fitzgerald
was characterized in the reynolds
hemingway biographies were was were
those characterizations accurate
i'll do the first one and dave do the
second okay
the first all right
uh you do reynolds i'll do wolf uh
wolf was a member of the maxwell perkins
stable at scribner's maxwell perkins was
the great editor at scribner's
and fitzgerald felt a loyalty to perkins
and a loyalty to other scribner authors
and so
when look home with angel was published
in 1929
fitzgerald was delighted
that
perkins and scribner had another genius
and he wrote
sent
wolfe a telegram saying that
he'd read it for read it uh this side of
the
look home with angel for 20 straight
hours
and
uh was congratulating wolf on the
achievement uh interesting thing is that
fitzgerald wrote lots of interesting
things an interesting thing is
fitzgerald wrote a letter to perkins
saying
uh
don't cut him
he should be published at whatever
length he writes
and that went against the uh the wisdom
of the time
and
turns out that fitzgerald was right uh
wolf should not have been cut
they should have published whatever he
wrote at whatever length he wrote it
dave paige i know this came up did you
want to respond to that i was going to
say i i only read about the first couple
of the reynolds biographies and so i
have to confess that i didn't get to the
one yet that
would have included fitzgerald so we had
a call on this earlier we want to thank
craig johnson in the minnesota
historical society which has allowed us
to put some of this program together
they also offer some of the tours uh
along summit avenue that include the um
the landmarks of scott fitzgerald
what else can people see around here um
the james j hill house is open to the
public and of course fitzgerald wrote
about james j hill he was a great
admirer of james j hill he put him in
his stories
his family was closely connected to the
hills mary hill was catholic some of her
closest confidants were
fitzgerald's uh aunt and
his uh grandmother and so you know just
uh you can see the fitzgerald theater in
downtown downtown st paul it used to be
the world theater it's where garrison
keeler show a prairie home companion
takes place
and then the homes up and down summit
avenue
just just a great neighborhood up here
and you know we probably should explain
as you look at some of these pictures
you'll see snow in some of the
taped pictures that we had that's just
from about a week ago it's about 70
degrees here in saint paul today but the
snow was here last week as spring slowly
tries to arrive here in this city we
also want to thank att broadband
princeton university library harold ober
and associates as we get a call from
here in saint paul and the university of
south carolina library which we'll get
to go ahead st paul
yes i'm so delighted to have this
opportunity to speak with you
because like many people here i've had
such a huge
enthusiasm for mr fitzgerald all my life
but during the 70s i attempted to
get some of the constabulary some of the
people here interested in acknowledging
the fact that we in saint paul had
produced this marvelous writer and my
efforts uh were
failed dismally i was so disappointed
because i went to speak to many people
and some journalists and elected
officials and so on and they seemed
feeling somewhat responsible and
partly guilty i suppose that nothing had
been done in all these years
but when the world theater was then
named after scott fitzgerald i had the
pleasure of speaking briefly with mr
keeler and i told him about all my
failed efforts and how disappointed i'd
been and he just looked at me and said
when you own the theater you get to name
it anything you want
and then of course when they had the
wonderful
huge celebration and gathering under mr
keeler's auspices which was an enormous
success in saint paul busloads of people
coming from all over and the the
buildings downtown office buildings and
other public buildings
jammed with people listening to other
writers
a bill holm joe heller all kinds of
people came out and we realized this was
something long long overdue but it's
marvelous to see these two men who are
so steeped
and so knowledgeable in
the works of scott fitzgerald in his
life and i was particularly happy to
hear the professor
debunk some of these long held
foolish notions about scott fitzgerald i
have to even tell you professor
that some of your academic colleagues
over at the university of minnesota have
even published things to that effect and
i'm i'm very glad to see a man like you
who really knows scott fitzgerald i'll
put some of those silly notions to rest
because he he was uh really a genius of
sorts
and the other things i love to hear you
describe were his qualities of character
and the fact that he had been such a
loyal husband under such very difficult
circumstances and uh well i'm going to
stop you there caller thank you very
much we'll get a response who wants to
take that what could i just uh throw in
dave you take it sure well i'd just like
to throw in that we're having a
fitzgerald conference here in september
uh part of the conference will take
place here at the university club we're
planning activities at the commodore uh
my co-chair eleanor lanahan i mean i
mean eleanor hegan bought them from
concordia
and i
have been planning things for rice park
the saint paul hotel
and so people are welcome to get a hold
of me
through
c-span if they're interested in learning
more about the conference to be held in
saint paul this september
who were his friends at the time who did
he associate with
well uh fitzgerald liked other writers
and for a time
hemingway was his most intimate friend
ring lardner was his friend john dos
paso's was a friend
uh the humorist donald ogden stewart was
a friend dorothy parker was a friend
uh fitzgerald did not resent
other successful writers uh
as gerald felt
that american writers should stick
together and
support each other
outside of
literature
his great friend was the american
expatriate painter gerald murphy about
whom a great deal has been written
you mentioned it earlier what brought
you to the university of south carolina
and the development of this fitzgerald
collection down there in columbia
i came to the university of south
carolina because i wanted to get away
from ohio state university english
department which had been taken over by
the new left and i wasn't going to spend
the rest of my life in a loony bin
uh and i figured the university of south
carolina would be one of the last
english departments that the new left
would get and i was right
and
the
fitzgerald collection
is housed at the university of south
carolina
and grows
every year we make significant
acquisitions we are now seeking an
endowment to support the thing in
perpetuity and the credit for that goes
not to me but to the great librarian
under whom i served george terry
who
died uh
suddenly last year
and
that was a great blow to f scott
fitzgerald's scholarship
because george let me buy anything i
wanted
and let us if we can just go back to the
time period of the 1920s gertrude stein
often referred to it as the lost
generation explain that oh that's a big
long complicated question sir
uh
gershwin stein used that phrase uh
because she'd heard a garage
keeper uh refer to his
mechanics
who had been in the war as a lost
generation
that
those who had suffered trench warfare in
world war one were permanent casualties
and she told that anecdote to hemingway
and hemingway thought it was ridiculous
uh
and he used
that sentence you are all a lost
generation as one of the epigraphs on
his novel the sun also rises and of
course people took it at face value they
thought hemingway was endorsing the
position
although he explained later in
detail
that
the use of the epigraph
from gertrude stein was intended
ironically sarcastically
but the view that there was a lost
generation of permanent war casualties
was widely held
following world war one
we are at the varsity bar
the university club in saint paul
minnesota some bar we haven't had a
drink yet
it's right behind you though we're gonna
get a call from
are you about a drink on tv i don't know
if you're allowed to drink on tv but
we'll get a call from palm springs
california good afternoon
and you've got lots of snow where i have
got lots of sun and desert
but i had two questions it's actually it
is it's gorgeous here today we should
point out it's about 70 degrees here
today
but i had two questions go ahead with
your question why is it called and the
jazz age if as professor puccioli says
there was no contact with betsy smith of
a great jazz musician
and the other question is
i'm just going to read hemingway's last
three lines
on the preface to this um movable feast
if the reader prefers this book may be
regarded as fiction
but there is always the chance that such
a book of fiction may throw some light
on what has been written as fact and he
wrote said that from cuba
i was just wondering
next week will be hemingway i'm glad to
hear that too but why such vitriol i
read the movable feast
moments with f scott fitzgerald as quite
moving tender
and
i'm loving with showing someone's
foibles
and failures as well as his wife
but as a friend not as a predator
you read what you read ma'am uh i see it
as mean and nasty
uh
if you're able uh to find affection in
it
uh
enjoy it
there's nothing i can say
good afternoon to scottsdale arizona
you're next
oh thank you for taking the call what a
wonderful program and what a wonderful
group you are today i grew up in
asheville
in the 20s and 30s
and of course we had thomas wolfe there
his hometown
fitzgerald and then we had hemingway
i read all three of those uh as great
adventures
and i wondered if we'll ever have three
uh together like that again during that
period thank you
go ahead dave oh gee thank you predict
um will we ever ever have i i think we
probably won't and it's probably because
of the nature of publishing anymore
you're not going to have a scribner's
anymore i don't think it's going to be
disney and i i just don't see disney
making decisions about art based on on
recommendations that uh the kind that
fitzgerald made to bring in hemingway to
bring in wolf into the scrivener's
stable and and so i i i don't i really
don't see that happening but maybe
professor brooklyn has a different day
good answer the nature of publishing has
changed
uh the bookkeepers the accountants now
run publishing the editors don't
terry murphy and mark farkas are heading
up this project tony williams is the
producer here in saint paul and it's
being directed by greg sizowitz back in
washington and tom aldridge who is here
along with our technical crew
we also want to thank more pierce and
all the folks who have been involved in
this our engineering staff the folks
from the c-span school bus as we
continue to travel and looking at
american history through the lives of
some leading american writers our next
call is from phyllis phillipsburg new
jersey good afternoon good afternoon and
i just want to thank you so much for
this program it is so timely i'm an
educator in new jersey and i just
finished teaching the great gatsby in my
sophomore english class and we used
winter dreams
as a preview to the great gatsby and i
would just like to hear your experts
comment on winter dreams and perhaps as
a first draft of the great gatsby thank
you so much for this
i wish i'd had you in high school you're
absolutely right winter dreams is a
preview of the great gatsby
and again it's one of his minnesota
stories uh takes place at white bear
lake
uh
i want to squeeze in a
general invitation to you your students
anyone the f scott fitzgerald room at
the university of south carolina
welcomes visitors
uh we'd be very happy
to have anyone who's interested in f
scott fitzgerald and wants to come to
the university of south carolina to
visit the f scott fitzgerald room to do
so singly or in groups
uh right ahead uh
and we will make arrangements
uh the collection is to be used the
library is not a museum where we lock
things up away from people
the library
is a place where people can work on
fitzgerald can touch and handle the
sterile material
university of south carolina columbia
south carolina invites you to visit the
f scott fitzgerald room and a lot of
this information on our website at
cspan.org or at americanwriters.org los
angeles good afternoon good afternoon
i've got
two quick questions
the first one is how did f scott
fitzgerald being a midwesterner
influence his writing if at all
and the second question is
when did he ultimately decide decided
his ambition was to become a writer and
prior to that did he ever express an
interest in becoming anything else
thank you
dave
i don't think he really expressed an
interest in becoming anything else other
than a playwright but he was uh
he gained his first fame in saint paul
writing juvenile plays
that were produced during saint paul and
then taken out to the white bear yacht
club but he was a failed play writer is
play the vegetables is is very bad um i
he
he always said he wanted to be a writer
as as far as as i can recall
and um
i think the midwest had an impact on him
because he
probably always played off other uh
other areas to his uh upbringing in the
midwest so he was always making those
com comparisons to if you want to call
the provincialism of the midwest but i
think that was always something that he
uh um
had in his short stories and novels was
was that kind of dual role between what
he experienced here in the midwest and
and what he experienced in the rest of
the world matthew berkeley in his early
years who had the biggest influence on
his life and his writings
at when he was a prep school student
newman's school hackensack new jersey he
came under the influence
of a priest
father
uh faye f-a-y
uh and faye was a romantic figure uh
deeply involved in there is deeply
involved in
literature
new
writers new prominent people
and
father faye later monsignor
this side of paradise has fey as a
character and is dedicated to faye
how many books did he write who at scott
he wrote
five novels and four collections of
short stories
four 160 short story 160 short stories
published in four volumes
and during the time that he's rappers
and philosophers tales of the jazz age
all the sad young men taps it revelly
what was happening in the country at the
time well you know it was the boom
until uh october 1929 then it was the
depression
uh fitzgerald's uh best novel better
than the great gatsby uh a grown-up
novel uh great gatsby's a brilliant
novel by a kid in his 20s
uh a book full of pain
uh tender as the night was published in
1934
uh and was relatively speaking speaking
uh
a failure
because
novels didn't sell well
in 1934
at least not unhappy novels
and david page how do you explain this
man in the times that he wrote about to
students who are first learning about f
scott fitzgerald
um
when i when i talk to people about
fitzgerald i talk about the um the fact
that saint paul influenced him so much
and and um the fact that he was so
interested in history he learned the
history from his father while he was
living here in saint paul
um he had a um
a pretty solid middle west kind of
background where family was important
and
and he also gained a lot of the
experience here in saint paul that he
would later on write about many of his
short stories david page who teaches at
inver hills community college and also
preparing a symposium in september yes
scott fitzgerald
what do you tell your students about the
man
i tell them nobody
who ever wrote
american prose put the words together
better
and
i tell them if they have any ear or any
eye
for the american language uh they will
find fitzgerald
richly rewarding
and
if uh
their reaction to his prose is huh
then they better find something they
like to do
matthew breckley who is with university
of south carolina the fitzgerald
collection and the author and editor of
a number of books on this man that we've
been focusing on for the last two hours
gentlemen thank you both for being with
us thank you we also want to thank john
rob and peggy pharisee they have allowed
us to take over this university club and
uh we appreciate their help and everyone
here and back in washington from saint
paul
thanks for being with us
so
feature with a look at the influence st
paul had on native son f scott
fitzgerald
if you want to understand the modern
world and where we are today there's no
better place to start than looking at
scott fitzgerald because he was so
complex and he was dealing with the
complexity of american life and that
still resonates today saint paul had
this
huge impact on fitzgerald and fitzgerald
had an impact on saint paul
st paul was the most important town
to f scott fitzgerald's legacy he lived
all over the world but
the vast majority of
experiences that he used in his novels
and his writings either directly came
from saint paul was planned in saint
paul written in saint paul rewritten in
saint paul
so st paul had this huge impact on his
life up until he was probably about 40
and and the hollywood years so if you
read fitzgerald stories um they are
awash in st paul imagery f scott
fitzgerald was born in this apartment on
september 24th 1896. it was considered a
luxury apartment back then um
befitting uh the daughter of pf
mcquillen who was one of the richest men
in saint paul unfortunately he died
pretty young and so you know the family
was living off you know kind of the
legacy money
but still the mcquillens were well
respected around the town of saint paul
fitzgerald uh took his first steps here
you know he said his first words here
there were two
uh
sisters that died right before he was
born
he suggested that's why he became a
writer
and then he had another sister that was
born when they were out in new york but
he said he didn't know that anything
else existed in the universe until his
younger sister was born he left
about the time he was two years old
because his father went to get a job in
new york um but
they came of course back to st paul
we're standing in front of saint paul
academy uh the former thing called paul
academy the school has moved now
fitzgerald's parents had a lot of
ambition for him and of course that's
why they named him francis scott keith
fitzgerald after a distant relative uh
the francis also was the middle name of
philip francis mcquillen his grandfather
who had all the money
so when the family moved back to saint
paul in 1908 his father could not even
keep the family together
because of finances
but they still wanted to thrust him kind
of into this st paul society so what do
you do you sent him to the most
prestigious private school in saint paul
st paul academy ascending to dancing
lessons just a couple blocks away on
grand avenue
and so fitzgerald was rubbing
shoulders of course with the elite of
summit avenue even though his folks
weren't quite there
now it's not that he was a poor boy um
he was like today you would think of him
as like a millionaire amongst
billionaires you don't feel sorry for
the millionaire many of his stories are
about you know the influence of money
and
and um i wouldn't say the worship of
money but just the
fact that money was such a big driver in
in the united states
he came back to saint paul as i said
just on the cusp
of being a teenager
he was very
handsome he was very very smart
and
he was a leader he was a natural leader
but sometimes he was probably a little
over aggressive so in the saint paul
academy school magazine one of his
friends said well somebody poisoned
scotty to shut him up um apparently he
talked a lot he um wanted to play sports
but he wasn't um very big he's he was a
little bit taller than i am um weighed a
lot less than i do
um but he just he was like on the third
string baseball team you know i mean how
many students were here probably not not
that many so he wasn't a great athlete
and so he realized he wasn't going to
be the kind of hero athlete and so he
thought about other ways uh to
kind of gain notoriety and he found it
through writing he was writing detective
stories he liked to read them and so he
would write them
he was writing
westerns he was writing mysteries
so he was writing about the civil war
because his father
was alive of course during the civil war
and lived in maryland
and his relatives you know he heard
stories about his relatives in the civil
war so he was doing a lot of different
kinds of genres he was writing plays um
the plays were being performed around
the town and he was kind of gaining a
little bit of notoriety in st paul this
row of cass gobert designed townhomes is
really important to scott fitzgerald his
parents lived in a couple different ones
believe it or not not only did they move
from block to block they literally moved
from roh you know town home to townhome
in the same row of town homes and
they are associated with the two great
loves of his life uh jenever king and uh
zelda zaire and he met he was going east
to school
when geneva came to a party here
and um he fell in love with her
and his parents were living at one of
the town homes here
where he
kind of moped about because of geneva he
eventually joined the army and went
south and met zelda um and when she
rejected him because he wasn't making
enough money he came back to this town
home at 599 summit this is where magic
struck up in the third floor
um
space up there
he
rewrote the book that he'd written while
he was an army in the army it was called
the romantic egotists and eventually it
was published by scribner's
this side of paradise but he he
literally
you know uh
thumb tacked in you know cards of
chapters and worked really really hard
to rewrite the book and max perkins
liked it now supposedly
after he
learned that the book was going to be
published he ran out onto summit avenue
and said my book's going to be published
my book's going to be published his
parents were kind of giving him a last
chance you know get your novel published
or go out and get a job you know and so
he literally one of his friends got him
a job on james j hills railroad
he didn't last very long as a manual
laborer but then his book was published
in every his world
completely changed he he got the girl of
his dreams you know zelda agreed to
marry him um his book was published he
became
he became the um
literally the
21st century self-promoter um we
you know the the the difference between
the victorian age and the jazz age you
know fitzgerald exemplified that kind of
um exuberance and self-promotion that uh
you see continuing today um his peers
wouldn't have done the kind of things he
did
and um so they probably looked down on
him a little bit but he got a lot of
publicity during his time
he wrote a a pretty famous letter about
being half black irish
and you know and then the half of his
father from the old southern you know
family um and he said he would grovel in
front of kitchen maids and insult the
rich
um so i suspect to his whole life he had
a little bit of an inferiority complex
especially when he went out east to
school and he you know he saw some
people who made
vast amounts of money and that of course
came out in tom buchanan in the great
gatsby fitzgerald had a really
interesting relationship with people
with money i mean they were his friends
but i don't think he worshipped money i
mean he he was too frivolous with it
now in order to be frivolous with money
you had to have some so obviously you
know but he made a lot of money during
his lifetime he he did make some money
off his books he made money off the
motion pictures he made money while he
was in hollywood he made a pot load of
money selling short stories and so he
worked really hard he made a lot of
money but he
um he didn't kind of like worship and i
i think he really felt the biblical you
know it's the worship of money that's
the root of all evil not the money
itself
[Music]
when i
have the opportunity to come to the
ballroom here at the louis hill house it
is such a thrill for me because i know
that
this provided inspiration
for fitzgerald
and the kind of stories that he was
interested in
to make money the the saturday evening
post stories this is the epitome
of that huge volume of work that he
produced that he felt a little bit
ashamed of but are wonderful stories and
so i see this as a real positive
place for his career
there was one particular party at this
house that actually fitzgerald didn't
attend and apparently a young man it was
a costume ball and louis hill liked to
have costume balls and this room would
have been filled with people in
different kinds of costumes well a young
man apparently dressed up in a camel's
outfit
and went to the wrong house
who knows why
anyway the next day fitzgerald hurx
keep watching for more here on c-span 2
and watch any of our past programs
online at booktv.org
well now joining us on book tv is
maureen corraga who is the book critic
on a program called fresh air
so a lot of our viewers a lot of our
book viewers will know that program but
now you've become an author as well
what's your book
my book is called so we read on it's
about the great gatsby
i think the great gatsby is our greatest
american and our greatest un-american
novel at once i've read it over 50 times
and this book was born out of my passion
for gatsby and for fitzgerald he's one
of our
he's one of our gods in american
literature
american and un-american yes yes because
gatsby tells us that the american dream
is worth reaching for and it also tells
us that the dream is a con
and you know when the book opens of
course gatsby is dead already i'm not
ruining anything that's on page one
so what kind of an american novel is
this where nothing can be changed nick
carraway is remembering everything in
this novel
there's no possibility for change so
that's a little odd but at the same time
fitzgerald writes about the american
dream in language that's so beautiful
it makes it irresistible
so miss corrigan what do you do with
so we read on how do you deconstruct the
gatsby i oh god i hate that word i don't
deconstruct
i appreciate i celebrate and i talk
about how fitzgerald came to write it
and how it disappeared shortly after it
came out in 1925 i mean contemporary
reviewers mostly talked about it as a
crime novel
when fitzgerald died in 1940 there were
remaindered copies in scrivener's
warehouse his last royalty check was for
13 dollars and 13 cents
it was world war ii that brought gatsby
back in a big way this program called
the armed services editions that
distributed
novels and non-fiction and poetry to
soldiers and sailors overseas gatsby was
chosen and 155
000 copies of the great gatsby get
distributed to our armed forces overseas
after the war it's the paperback
revolution and gatsby is on its way
how many copies
how many copies these days
on in a normal year
um
fitzgerald's publisher sells 500 000
copies last year because of the movie
the baslerman awful movie they sold at
least three times that it's everywhere
it's conquered the world if only
fitzgerald knew
maureen corrigan that sounded like a
deconstruction to me but i won't i won't
quibble with you on that um
how did you get to be the book critic at
fresh air
i listened to fresh air that's the short
answer i listened to fresh air while i
was in philly in grad school at the
university of pennsylvania writing my
dissertation and at that time fresh air
was a three-hour live show
i i heard that it was going national i
had been doing some book reviews for the
village voice
i sent fresh air my my book reviews they
told me
no thanks we think you're too academic
but then a few months later i did an
expose of what it was like to be a
grader for the ap english exam and fresh
air contacted me and said we want you to
do this on air
and the nice part of this story is that
john leonard who was then book the book
critic for fresh air who i still think
of as the greatest book critic in the
latter part of the 20th century in
america was generous enough to say
bring her on board as a second book
critic there's more than enough books to
go around
how many books are you reading a week
i'm reading at least three a week i get
over 200 delivered to my small row house
in washington dc every week
and about 50 more delivered to my office
at georgetown
there's no shortage of books in america
what's a recent non-fiction a c-span ask
book tv book that you reviewed what did
you say about it yeah i highly recommend
hector tobar's deep down dark about the
chilean miners who were trapped
underground for i don't know something
like 40 days
and hector tovar got exclusive access to
the miners they gave they said they
wanted him to write their story
it's it's kind of like um into thin air
the john krakauer novel about climbing
everest except it's down it's about
being trapped down in the bowels of the
earth
waiting for rescue and having faith that
rescue will come it's a fabulous
non-fiction book and if you would like
to watch the author talk about his book
deep down dark you can go to booktv.org
in the search function type in that
title and book tv has covered that book
as well maureen corrigan of fresh air
so we read on is her book how the great
gatsby came to be and why it endures
up next on book tv afterwards with guest
host chester gills the dean of
georgetown's college of arts and
sciences
[Music]
and now from the annual san antonio book
festival a panel on american novels
[Music]
good morning everyone and
welcome to the san antonio book festival
and to see spans book tv
my name is michael soto i am the
moderator for this morning's
really
promising discussion about two fantastic
american novels i am on the
english department faculty at trinity
university where i teach courses in
american literature and cultural history
and i have to say the great gatsby and
huck finn are two of my favorite novels
so i'm very excited about this morning
it's very rare these days for literary
scholars to write books on the topic of
the american novel
when larry buell published his dream of
the great american novel last year
it was hardly a surprise that both huck
finn and gatsby were prominently
featured in that book back in the day
when scholars wrote about the american
novel on a regular basis
huck finn and gatsby were always a part
of that conversation and i think the
reasons are obvious
as to why
they should become even more obvious
after this morning's panel i'm pleased
to introduce maureen corrigan
whose voice you may recognize she's
regularly
on our radios
part of npr's fresh air broadcast
and she's also on the literature faculty
at georgetown university go hoyas
and
andrew levy is the chair and professor
of english at butler university
go bulldogs
and i've asked
them if i could put them on the spot to
start things off i've asked them to
choose a favorite
passage from
gatsby and from hug finn and to to read
that passage for us and to explain why
it's significant to them and why it
should be
significant to us
maureen i think you're queued up and
ready to go so let me ask you to start
things off all right thank you michael
do we have five hours because i want to
take this paragraph and or two and
pull it apart um one of the wonderful
things about writing a book about the
great gatsby is that i i can pretty much
assume as i think andrew can that we're
speaking to an audience who has read the
the novel at least at some point in in
their their lives so um i'm going to
read from the first chapter
where nick decides to go visit his
cousin daisy buchanan who he hasn't seen
in a while he's invited for dinner and
he walks into the buchanan mansion
with tom buchanan who has to be one of
the greatest characters in literature
we walk through a high hallway into a
bright rosy colored space
fragilly bound into the house by french
windows at either end the windows were a
jar and gleaming white against the fresh
grass outside that seemed to grow a
little way into the house
a breeze blew through the room
blue curtains in at one end and out the
other like pale flags twisting them up
toward the frosted wedding cake of the
ceiling and then rippled over the wine
colored rug making a shadow on it as the
wind does upon the sea
the only completely stationary object in
the room was an enormous couch on which
two young women were boyed up as though
upon an anchored balloon they were both
in white and their dresses were rippling
and fluttering as if they had just been
blown back in
after a short flight around the house
i must have stood for a few minutes
listening to the whip and snap of the
curtains and the groan of a picture on
the wall
then there was a boom as tom buchanan
shut the rear windows and the caught
wind died out about the room and the
curtains and the rugs and the two young
women ballooned slowly to the floor
yeah that's writing
those of you who love gatsby go on the
princeton university library website and
you will see the first draft of the
great gatsby in fitzgerald's hand
because he didn't type and you will see
how much he labored over that passage
over the sound of it usually when i read
this passage in class
i really emphasize those b sounds to
annoy my students and to wake them up
fitzgerald is writing like a poet he
loved john keats he loved shakespeare so
he's going after the musicality of the
scene
but he's also trying to convey
the fact that the women in the room
daisy and jordan baker
are not really paying that much
attention to nick as he walks in
and i say in my book that that this is
one of these scenes as you study it
where you realize
this the great gatsby is our great
american novel about class and about
where people are on on the class
hierarchy
we know right away that daisy and jordan
are
upper class
because they don't exert themselves at
all
to and and after all daisy hasn't seen
her cousin nick in years
they wait until he comes to them and so
that's going on in that scene as well
the awareness of where people are in the
pecking order the musicality and also a
lot of water imagery which i talk about
as being so central to gatsby because
this is a novel that's very aware um
of how far a nobody like gatsby can swim
before he inevitably goes under and of
course when when he's dead i'm not
giving anything away it's on page two of
the book when he's dead he's dead in his
swimming pool so end of quick lesson
thanks
that was great maureen really can just
listen to people read from the great
gatsby like that
anytime i'm gonna start with the first
five words of huckleberry finn
as my sample
and they are you don't know about me
it's not even the whole sentence it's
not even a fifth of the opening sentence
and i'm starting with such a short piece
for several reasons first because mark
twain took
eight years to write huckleberry finn
and during those eight years he rewrote
that sentence several times putting in
the contraction taking out the
contraction drafting and redrafting
so people often think that huckleberry
finn is just this kind of lazy sloppy
infusion in many ways it is but when it
came down to getting the tuning fork
right for huckleberry's fun finn's voice
mark twain was absolutely unrelenting
the second reason i've only picked five
words is because if any of us was alive
in 1884 and i'm reckoning none of us was
and we took the opportunity to go see
mark twain on stage which was a very
popular thing to do at the time
you'd know that he was recognized
obviously as one of the funniest men
anywhere as a true performer but he was
also recognized for having an extremely
distinctive
speaking style with enormous long pauses
between every word uh there was even a
joke uh from people who knew him that by
the end of the evening he got a little
drunk those pauses could last 30 seconds
but the newspaper reviewer said that
when you heard him do it and
alive it brought something out
that you couldn't get on the page that
he made every word into something that
means something
um and he loved pauses he just adored
them he said that he played with pauses
the way other boys played with toys as a
child
so you have to read those five words
slow
almost as if your sense of a sentence
changes
with every word as it drops into your
brain slowly
first of all about five words themselves
you don't know about me that's the first
thing mark twain is telling you in huck
finn which is you have never met a 12
year old boy narrating a book you have
never met a child in his real voice
narrating a book you don't know about me
but even go word by word
you i mean how many novels start with
you
not with a me not with an i but with you
a second person an audience you don't a
brief sudden accusation that there's
something you don't do you don't know a
brief sudden accusation that there's
something you don't know and then you
don't know about me you've never met a
child for real before
five words that set the agenda for the
entire book
huck finn and gatsby are mesmerizing
novels and i can assure you that that
so we read on and huck finn's america
are mesmerizing studies of mesmerizing
novels
they're not the first studies of huck
finn and gatsby there are in fact
hundreds of books and thousands of
academic articles devoted to the subject
of these two novels
so writing a new book about huck finn
and about gatsby is something of an
audacious act
i'm glad you made that that leap each of
you because you provide
important interventions into
the discussion of these two important
novels could you say a few words about
what first led you to the
to that audacious leap
and
what intervention your your
you'd really like our audience to know
about this
morning um
you're right of course michael i i refer
to the growing
gatsby scholarship which
multiplies exponentially year by year as
the blob i mean it's it is so daunting
if you start down start to write a book
about gatsby or huck finn
um you really have to say to yourself
how much of this do i really need to
know
before i can
stick my toes in the water so to speak
um
i've read gatsby at least 60 times and
counting
i i hope to go on reading gatsby every
year of my life until i i draw my last
breath i love it
i didn't love it when i first read it in
high school i thought it was a boring
novel about rich people and i didn't
understand its magic
but as i had to re-read it in college
and then inevitably teach it in grad
school
i really fell in love with nick
carraway's voice and that voice of
yearning and regret for his lost friend
gatsby
really just drew me in
i wanted to write this book
in a conversational style but informed
by scholarship
i wanted to tell stories which is what
we do on radio we tell stories
and i really wanted to try to figure out
why fitzgerald wrote this book it's so
very different from the two novels that
precede it
it's different from tender as the night
it's got some similarities with his last
novel in progress the loves of the last
tycoon but it really stands apart i
wanted to see what fitzgerald thought he
was doing
i wanted to figure out how it came back
from the dead because when fitzgerald
died in 1940 in hollywood at the age of
44. his last royalty check was for 13.13
he couldn't even get a copy of the great
gatsby on the bookshelves of bookstores
in hollywood that's not that unusual a
story in american literature that you
know a great book dies or isn't
recognized during its own time but what
is unusual is how quickly gatsby comes
back by the end of the 40s we've got the
second great gatsby movie
1949 starring alan ladd you know it's
very film noirish type gatsby so i
wanted to figure out how it came back so
quickly and i wanted to delve deeper
into its mysteries
i feel like i could write another book
about the great gatsby at this point you
know there's so much
left to uncover but i i did things like
go out onto long island sound to look at
great neck and sands point which uh
great neck is west egg sands point is
east egg in the novel i went down to
the university of south carolina i say
down because i live in washington d.c
to look at their gatsby archive went to
princeton and scariest research trip of
all i went back to my old high school
something i hadn't done in almost 40
years i wanted to sit in on classes that
were reading gatsby for the first time
because when i get my students they've
read it already i wanted to see what
they their reaction was and i wanted to
be in the classrooms i was in when i
first read gatsby
and
most startling fact of all my english
teacher is still at the high school
so and it was an incredible two days the
kids were very excited because the awful
baz lerman movie was about to come out
so they had a lot to say
um i took 20 years to write this book
and one reason i'm just shaking my head
like that
and um
one reason is because uh everything
keeps changing with huck finn and
changing and changing and changing and
there was always this kind of
feeling that put in my stomach that just
when i thought i had was on top of
things out would come something major
new or new debate would start
or something else profound would happen
with this book and eventually the fact
that things kept happening with the book
is what kept me going that and the fact
that twain is incredibly funny and you
really can just read more mark twain and
read more mark twain and read more mark
twain and and he rewards that uh he
keeps he keeps giving you something
interesting something that contrasts the
last thing something tricky and
unknowable his was the kind of sense of
humor that was designed not to to
confirm your judgments
but to challenge your judgments
and i like having my judgments
challenged i really wanted to figure out
this book but i wanted to figure out
this book hopefully to some extent
for other people too
it's taught in a lot of different ways
right now the debate is really settled
about huck finn at this point and it's
not going away there's a pro side and an
anti-side and what was the breakthrough
for me was going back to 1884 to 1885 i
usually do books by going to places but
in this case i bought a microfilm
machine from i think the texas library
system actually on ebay and while i
raised my child
i stayed at home in my study and i just
shipped in newspaper after newspaper
from 1884 and i read everything there
was about how people talked about
children and how people talked about
race and how people talked about mark
twain
and no matter how many people have
covered a subject you know it's america
and sometimes there's an open space out
there that surprises you and while a lot
of what i wrote was a synthesis of what
people had written before me and there's
120 pages of footnotes in my book to
prove it there was still a few open
spaces there that those old newspapers
yielded
i i think our audience has a fair sense
already of the
the depth of historical research that
went into each of these two books and
having written literary history myself i
can feel
the time and effort that went into every
single page in every single sentence
often
they are very historicist
approaches to to each novel
um but not in an
off-putting
uh antiquarian way they're they're also
uh books that are
very much in touch with contemporary
concerns
now if
uh an historian 50 years from now
were to write
about
these two studies
what would he or she want to say about
contemporary american society and
culture
based on an understanding of what you
did in your books
well
one of the things that
i wanted to talk about with gatsby was
how gatsby of course is a novel of its
time as well as this
vexed phrase this universal
classic in american literature
one thing that i think makes gatsby
eternally relevant to us in this country
is the way it expresses anxiety about
the economy about where we stand as i
said in terms of our class uh situation
i mean gatsby always seems to come back
when we've got an economy that's in the
tank because it's it's a novel that
really does talk about how real is the
american dream and how secure is your
footing even if you may be wealthy today
but is that wealth going to continue
another very contemporary topic that
gatsby engages is concern over
immigration concern over race of course
we're talking i'm sitting here talking
uh
about race next to andrew who's written
a book about huck finn which has to be
one of the well maybe the greatest
american nominee yeah it is and and if
you remember there's a scene again early
on in the novel where nick and gatsby
are driving across the queensborough
bridge into new york they're going in to
have lunch with meyer wolfsheim the
gangster who's modeled on arnold
rothstein who actually was a gangster in
new york at the time
and it's a passage that's often quoted
on literary calendars because it's so
beautiful
nick says something like the city scene
from the queensborough bridge is always
the city scene for the first time and he
gives you this beautiful description of
the new york skyline but as they're
driving over the bridge in gatsby's
amazing car
they're passed on the bridge the two
white guys are passed first of all by a
car in which um
two
well three african americans are sitting
being driven by a white chauffeur
and then also by a funeral cortege with
immigrants from southeastern europe
it's not this is a novel that's very
anxious about the direction in which
america is going it's written right
after we get the waves of immigrants
coming into this country that second
great wave of immigration from
southeastern europe from russia
from greece a lot of the immigrants in
that second wave were darker skinned
they didn't speak english
america is nervous about about this how
are these folks going to be
you know integrated into the society
gatsby is also written during the period
of the great migration and the harlem
renaissance in new york new york has
seen an incredible boost in population
in terms of the african-american
population again it's anxious it's
nervous it's a novel that's also anxious
about the role of women women have just
gotten the vote and don't forget the
femme fatale in this novel daisy well
she's behind the driver's seat at a
crucial point in the novel novel's very
anxious about women in power so i love
to talk about sections
like that scene in the novel not only
are the white guys being passed
but they're on the queensboro bridge and
for those of you who know any new york
history they're going over blackwell's
island which is now roosevelt island the
site of luxury condos and wonderful
restaurants etc back then blackwell's
island was an island for um people with
incurable diseases typhoid mary was
isolated on blackwell's island it had a
women's lunatic asylum um and uh and you
know a prison so it's not a good
sight for these again white guys nick
and gatsby to be driving over as they're
being passed
by new immigrants and by people of color
um
i love that scene on the bridge i really
do
i took your questions slightly different
michael taking a slightly different
direction
uh i couldn't have done this book
without the the digital revolution and i
think that 60 years from now they're
going to say
wow this is for the first these were the
first years where someone could go
online and see the trans the manuscript
of the great gatsby or the original
manuscript of huck finn and just sit at
home and see all of mark twain or scott
fitzgerald's changes that is amazing and
and that allows i think people like us
to really dig deep into history
confidently and easily in a way that
people even 10 years ago couldn't and i
think that they will talk about that
i also often thought of my book
i enjoyed writing my book the way i
enjoy like
watching antiques road show i think that
there's just you know i think that there
there remains at all times a kind of
american fixation with our past and just
to hold the objects to touch the objects
to understand the objects
and and um and to feel that warmth that
can only emanate from certain objects
almost almost if they contain more magic
than other ones do
but twain felt that way too we have to
remember he was writing in the 1870s and
1880s about his childhood the 1830s and
the 1840s you think about those 40 or 50
years difference
and now think about the number of
television shows or movies that go back
40 or 50 years and bring it back to us
with a kind of searching but almost
satirical quality
mad men for instance but you know that
you know downton abbey's a good example
not quite us but you know
we're always going about three or four
decades back for our fashion for our
music
for our politics to re-examine them and
that's exactly what twain was doing i
feel that in that book he almost touched
upon this ongoing
impulse
to just understand that group and to
some extent that's just because people
in their 40s or 50s they get a lot of
control of the culture and they think
back to their childhoods
but that's the way we structure our
popular culture and twin was doing that
too
andrew huck finn is one of the most
unique and memorable narrators in
american literature
a young boy
whose
irony
is not at all self-aware
um uh
it's built into the character
um
i think you importantly remind us that
huck finn
um
is
less a novel about
race
than it is about boyhood at it written
at a time when
uh questions of youth and youth identity
were entering the popular and even
professional discourses in ways that
hadn't been the case before could you
say a bit more about how
a child narrator gives us access to
these really interesting questions about
childhood itself sure thanks michael for
the question um yeah the the major idea
of my book is that for the last 50 or 60
years when we talk about race and
huckleberry finn we have a very serious
and controversial conversation but that
when we talk about children we regard it
as a lighthearted romp you watch the
movies there's cartoons everywhere this
has been the case for 50 to 100 years
but if you go back to 1884 and 1885 you
will see that actually there was an
extremely
serious heartfelt debate about how we
raise our children that was
in fact mark twain wrote and published
the book in the middle of what was
called the bad boy crisis
and everyone was afraid that their
children especially the boys had too
much access to violent popular culture
and it was making them violent and they
were thinking specifically of these thin
little dime novels like pirate novels
and western novels which were were built
in such a way that you could slip them
inside a textbook
and read them and you could return them
and get new ones so i mean the the
publishers knew what they were doing and
the the um
the newspapers were filled with stories
of kids reading those books and going on
marauding hijinks stealing even
murdering
having way too much access to guns
and
in the context of a serious debate like
that
twain's book drops right in the middle
of it
and someone like huckleberry finn is a
complete
taunt
of that dialogue
he is
the kind of kid that was being sent off
to work farms he's the kind of kid that
they were doing everything they could to
control
and he said and mark twain said he
smoked tobacco and tobacco was like a
drug would be for us his best friend tom
was in a gang it was a joke a gang but
it was still a gang and the gang
attacked you know sunday school picnic
um and they were worried about gangs and
they were worried about all of these
things hawk was illiterate he smoked
and he was the anti-hero of the time and
twain made him into a hero
and but the thing that makes it work and
this is the crucial thing is the
authenticity of the voice
twain was raising his own children at
the time he kept copious notes on how
they talked
which are amazing and were only
published for the first time about six
months ago by the way university of
california but go get it if you love
mark twain and just read how much he
loves his children but be how much the
way he thought about his own children
filtered into huck finn
and
it was
almost as if
it was a parent's impulse
almost as if he said you know i i trust
my children i trust their voice
and i'm gonna let their voice speak
and then you can judge for yourself he
did not like overbearing parents he
tried as hard as he could not to be one
with mixed results as you might well
guess um he could actually be almost
another kid in his own family and i
think that must have been deeply
irritating to his wife
um
but in the end that was that was the
game he played and by the end of his
life he joked a thousand years from now
historians would think we had two sets
of children how did that work and they
would think huck and tom were as real as
his real children and when you read the
back and forth you'll see how much he
invests love and faith in a real child
into huck finn as a way of combating a
dialogue that he felt would ultimately
oppress children
gatsby is one of the brilliant observer
hero narratives because it's about the
hero gatsby but it's
the storytelling is done by
another unforgettable narrator nick
carraway so maureen can you tell us
what is going on with
a young narrator on the cusp of 30
from
an elite
ivy league education part of the
american
upper crust
why does fitzgerald
give him the task of narrating the life
of the
the uh up by your bootstraps gatsby what
does that tell us about social class
especially well at first fitzgerald
didn't if you go and look at that first
draft of gatsby
online
on princeton's uh
website you'll see that at first we had
a third person narrator
you know omniscient
um fitzgerald thank god ditched that
idea and gave us nick carraway
nick is carried away by gatsby nick is
carried away by the memory of his dead
friend when the novel opens
two years have passed we're supposed to
think that the present time of the novel
is 1924.
and nick is looking back two years to
the summer of 1922.
having this partially involved
first-person narrator
allows gatsby to retain his mystery
because we don't know an awful lot about
what is true and what is not true about
james gatz or jay gatsby as he later
becomes there's a lot of
you know stories and lies and myths
floating around gatsby some readers
didn't like that edith wharton famously
wrote to f scott fitzgerald and said
you know i like the book
i think you could have done a little bit
more with gatsby's background but then
she steps back and she says but you'll
say that's that's my way and that's not
the way of your generation to leave this
ambiguity in these holes um she was
right she was also very worried about
the dog that myrtle buys you know what
happened to the dog
wharton was a great dog lover so she was
concerned about the dog
uh
also with nick as as i've said before
nick is reaching out
you know trying to grasp his dead friend
gatsby
everybody in this novel with the
exception of daisy our femme fatale
is reaching for somebody or something
that's out of their grasp the first time
we see gatsby at the end of chapter one
he's standing at the edge of his lawn
reaching out his arms for that green
light right the signal image of the
novel the image of aspiration that's
what fitzgerald said the novel was about
everybody nick is reaching for gatsby
myrtle is reaching for tom tom is
reaching for daisy
mr wilson is reaching for myrtle you can
play with it different ways this novel
is so over designed
so many symbol systems 450 time words
it's a very time conscious novel time is
running out in this novel but and yet as
jonathan franzen has said you can read
it without an awareness of any of these
patterns or symbols and it goes down as
smoothly as though you were eating
whipped cream another one of
uh fitzgerald's achievements here it's
important though that
we don't trust nick completely i mean
he's not
a 100 percent reliable narrator um and i
think holden caulfield salinger's great
character owes a lot of course to huck
finn but also to nick carraway there's
that that sense of
nick is holding some things back and we
find out once in a while throughout
gatsby that he hasn't told us everything
so
it's a novel that urges us to be aware
of what this what kind of stories we're
hearing and to think about them
critically
i think i read somewhere that that mark
twain was the most photographed human
being of the 19th century
and maureen i'm grateful that you
include so many great snapshots that
fitzgerald or people around him took
during the period that
that the novel was being written
and i guess it's a good thing for us
that they existed before the age of the
selfie because i imagine that they would
probably be prolific
selfie takers because both twain and
fitzgerald were
very
conscious cultivators of their
larger-than-life personas
and gatsby
and huck finn as characters have taken
on these larger than life afterlives
that
unmore them from the novels they inhabit
and
and in a sense they i think you both
point out that
both the novelists and their characters
um
exist
in our contemporary consciousness in
ways that that kind of distract us from
from some of the crucial concerns of the
novels themselves could you say a bit
about
how you handled these larger-than-life
personalities that you had to wade
through
i am i mean i went with it
i i love that twain was you know
copyrighted at his own name and
he'd walk out in new york city in the
last 10 or 15 years of his life and he
put on that white suit just to be seen
you know i mean let's not kid ourselves
about that he really enjoyed the
attention um and i also love the list of
the most photographed people in the
world it was mark twain at one point it
was mount saitung at one point michael
jordan muhammad ali it's a great list
um
but one of the things i enjoyed most
about doing about my book or doing my
book was was was following twain's book
tour with huckleberry finn
and reading the accounts of him
performing on stage and then the
larger-than-life media presence he
created as he did sort of little bits of
business designed to attract the
attention of the newspapers he would
take interviews from his bed you know so
so they just saw the interviewers
whether they would go into his into his
hotel room maybe they're in bed and take
the interviews
and uh or he'd have a fake fight or he'd
go on a train
and he'd go in the smoking car and he'd
lower all the windows to get the smoke
to go out and just over and over these
little things that would irritate
or animate everyone around them but made
it clear that he was his own man
traveling through this world and you
know it's just article after article um
when he traveled with huckleberry finn
he started the um
his book tour the day after a
presidential election which was a hotly
disputed one for weeks afterwards with
the electoral vote in doubt and that
upper right hand corner of every
newspaper where the major story goes
mark twain presidential election down
here
there's there's reasons we still think
about him but it was part of it he was a
performance artist he was a copyrighted
out-there presence
and i think we should love that and
respect that and enjoy that and weave it
into our discussion of the literary
i i didn't know he was uh mark twain was
kind of doing a john and yoko interview
from the dead
talk about performance artists my god
well i feel with fitzgerald michael you
can't help but root for him
if you have any feeling at all for his
his work
his writing you can't help but root for
him fitzgerald himself
was a gatsby gatsby-like character um he
he
grew up in a family where his mother's
family had money but his father's family
had breeding but no money um he grew up
on
partly on summit avenue in saint paul
where his where his parents rented
apartments on this incredible avenue
where you've got the mansion of james j
hill the railroad tycoon for a while his
was the largest private home in america
i mean it's still an
incredible landscape there on summit
avenue of of beautiful houses and
mansions garrison keeler lives there um
so
that sense of being on the outside
looking in
was something that informed fitzgerald's
psychic landscape and then he goes to
princeton on scholarship in a sense um
due to the timely death of one of his
mother's relatives he's always kind of
got one foot in and one foot out
that sense of not quite belonging that
infuses gatsby is something that
fitzgerald wrote about in letters and
said that he felt all his life
he told john o'hara in the 1930s my
problem is that i've got a two-cylinder
inferiority complex
fitzgerald
came to fame in 1920 with this side of
paradise his first novel which gave us
the jazz age he coined that term he and
zelda
who he married a few days after the site
of paradise came out were the king and
queen of the jazz age for a while and
the 1920s is also the age when we get
all of those glossy magazines vanity
fair the smart set the new yorker so
their faces were on the covers of all
those magazines um like andrew's saying
about mark twain they knew how to
manipulate their image and they were
both very beautiful dorothy parker said
that to see scott and zelda fitzgerald
come into the room was to look at two
people who looked like they had just
stepped out of the sun
they're both
beautiful golden people but it doesn't
last long
you know gatsby comes out 1925 it
doesn't sell well
zelda has her first major breakdown and
institutionalization
for what we assume was schizophrenia in
1929
you know their golden period together is
just about 10 years and then it falls
apart
and as i said when fitzgerald dies
he's basically broke in hollywood trying
to write for the movies he you know and
he's treated like a hand in hollywood
like so many of our great writers were
worked for two weeks on gone with the
wind pulled pulled over to another film
andrew mentioned artifacts one of the
artifacts that really got to me is at
the university of south carolina they
have f scott fitzgerald's battered
leather briefcase
from his hollywood years
and the leather briefcase has his name
inscribed on it in gold f scott
fitzgerald and then his address
what is it 537 fifth avenue it's it's
the address of the scribner's building
his publisher
um
in in new york that was his only
permanent address really all his life
and that briefcase tells you the story
of the end of his life he died thinking
he was a failure
so i think my my job with this book
i had to guard against
being too much in fitzgerald's corner
you know because because he was a nasty
drunk he
and and you know he had his other alter
human flaws
but he was a good father
a concerned husband
and a great friend to other writers
don't get me started on how hemingway
treated him after he introduced
hemingway to max perkins his editor
okay i won't get you started either
maybe some of our audience members will
though as
much as i would love to ask 100 more
questions i think i will no longer stand
in the way of our audience let me ask
that you wait until the microphone
reaches you before you ask the question
i see we already have a hand up in the
yellow
this is a really loaded question so
okay anyway
if each of you could pick one today a
novelist what would you who would you
pick
oh a contemporary novelist right now
there's some great ones i love i love
marilyn robinson
i love don delillo i love tony morrison
it's three right there
yeah i would go with tony morrison
and um el doctoro i i love and i think
phillip roth should get the nobel prize
come on
we have a question up here in the front
if you could wait for the microphone
please
as far as max perkins did f scott
fitzgerald ever visit him at his
compound in windsor vermont
i have us
three questions real quickly um joan
didion and where i was from writes about
how easy it was to institutionalize
women in california at a certain period
did his wife really require that
institutionalization because in the
blurb it said she was bussing tables and
in your email exchange with joe
alkenbach where he writes about your
book in the washington post
you said that there were several books
that deserve the treatment that you have
given to f scott fitzgerald one was
melville with moby dick wuthering
heights jane eyre i think one by edith
wharton i was wondering if you could
yeah and i actually have questions about
twain but
i don't i don't think fitzgerald ever
visited max perkins in vermont um
but i could be wrong
so please hold your letters and emails
you know max perkins of course is one of
the great heroes of american literature
in the 20th century not only was he
fitzgerald and hemingway's editor uh tom
thomas wolf's editor marjorie cannon
rawlings you know the list goes on and
on and on there's a movie that's coming
out maybe some of you know this about
max perkins and his relationship with
thomas wolfe and max perkins is going to
be played by colin firth be still my
heart so um
so that's that's on on the horizon there
um
some of those novels that i mentioned in
the interview with joel achenbach that
deserve the treatment that we've given
to
to our beloved books they've already
been written um
nathaniel philbrick wrote a great book
about the whale ship essex which is the
real whale ship that that of course the
pequod was um
modeled after and he's also written a
book about moby dick so um those books
are coming out it's andrew and i were
talking before the the panel began and
we do seem to be living through kind of
a a mini golden age of books like our
books where
you know
uber fans um who've done some
scholarship and and have lived with
these novels for years and have
gone to the ends of the earth doing
research or you know
uh
through digitization done the research
as well
we're we're writing books also though
from the heart i think this is an age in
which
um academic criticism
um
wonderful as it can be
people are realizing that there are
certain shortcomings to it
and i for one am a great fan of the mid
20th century american critics like
edmund wilson um alfred kazan
you mentioned joan didion i mean people
who knew what they were talking about
but also weren't afraid to put
emotion and point of view in their
writing and make it
lively and have a voice in your own
writing and you know that's that's what
i was aiming for myself that was my
green light with this book i like books
i like books of criticism in which the
author's presence is the critics
presence is felt is there a was there a
house of mirth book
i don't think so
[Laughter]
my idea
we had a we have a question up here in
the blue
i'm fascinated with the relationship
between hemingway
and fitzgerald and so i wonder if you
can speak to that yeah
well you know
hemingway and fitzgerald met in 1925 in
the summer of 1925. by the way gatsby we
just celebrated the anniversary
yesterday april 10th 1925 the 90th
anniversary of the publication of the
great gatsby so
that was the spring in the summer of 25
fitzgerald kind of engineers a meeting
with hemingway who he's been hearing
about and who he's read
some of hemingway's short stories and
it's kind of a scouting mission for max
perkins fitzgerald kind of appointed
himself as a scout for scribners to to
see whether uh hemingway might be
interested in signing on with scribners
they
they met uh in paris
they hit it off
and gradually the
soured you know as
hemingway's star began to rise
um
he gets
testier with fitzgerald and fitzgerald's
star of course is dimming
and
you know it
eventually hemingway breaks off the
friendship toward the late 20s
um
he can be hemingway was very nasty and i
could go on and on but when he heard
that fitzgerald was depressed in the 20s
he wrote he wrote fitzgerald um these
kind of chiding
funny letters but not so funny like you
know snap out of it come on you know and
then he suggested that he would have
fitzgerald murdered
so that uh scotty and zelda could
collect the insurance you know if you're
so depressed why why don't why don't why
not i know arrange for a hit job and you
know then they'll collect the insurance
now this is not of course when you think
of hemingway's end you realize how
ironic all of this is this impatience
with depression
in the 1930s um
hemingway was
raising funds for the spanish civil war
in support um you know the spanish civil
war activists and uh fitzgerald was
invited to a dinner
and he he decided he couldn't meet
hemingway again i think it's 36 or so
and he writes um to someone else he said
ernest speaks with the authority of
success i speak with the authority of
failure we could never meet across the
same table again
so um
it's
it's not a pretty story it's it's not a
pretty but hemingway did that with a lot
of writers a lot of his colleagues he
i mean i think his writing is unearthly
and i i especially the nick adams
stories um you know some of the novels
but i would i would never have wanted to
have a beer with hemingway
yeah and that's what got fitzgerald into
trouble um i'm i'm i can't believe i'm
blanking on hemingway's 1912 the sun
also rises
fitzgerald gave a lot of
hemingway asked would you read the draft
would you give me you know have at it
you know take out your red pencil and
fitzgerald stupidly did
and
hemingway could never forgive
um
fitzgerald for all of the places in
which he suggested uh hemingway should
revise the sun also rises and he writes
an obscenity next to the draft that he
got back from fitzgerald so
you know you didn't criticize hemingway
well gertrude stein was one of the few
self-described geniuses who deserve the
label and she preferred fitzgerald's
writing and that also hurt the
relationship because she she said in
both men's presence that fitzgerald
burned with the brighter flame
you know
i saw a hand up in the very back
hi i've heard some critics complain
about the ending of huckleberry finn do
you agree or do you think that ending
was appropriate for the character um
that's a great question
and um
i'm going to say that
a lot of
what i write in my book ghost are trying
to explain why the ending of huckleberry
finn is the way it is
and
hemingway said a famous thing about mark
twain's huckleberry finn which
was unfortunate
which was that you know that you know
all he wrote very complimentary uh
famously that all american literature
comes from one book huckleberry finn by
mark twain but then he said but you have
to stop about two-thirds in the rest of
it is cheating so he was one of the
first people to say huck finn is the
great american novel and one of the
first people to say but the last third
stinks
and uh the reason it thinks for many
people is because the first two thirds
of the book really looks like a very
positive
um
metaphor for american race relations
where a white american and
african-american come to know each other
in this isolated place the raft away
from society
and then at a certain crucial point the
white american huckleberry finn decides
that he will go to hell for jim's
freedom
and that's the story that's the story we
want to tell of american civil rights
um you know that that um but
what happens after the moment that
huckleberry finn says will go to hell
for jim is that he doesn't
that the last third of it is this
burlesque where tom sawyer plays with
jim like a toy even though jim is
fundamentally free the whole time tom
sawyer knows that he's seen the will
that said jim is free but tom sawyer
constructs this big big parody of
freeing jim because it's more fun for
tom sawyer to take all that time freeing
jim
than it is for jim to actually be free
and at the end of the book huck finn is
completely scalded by this and he finds
the gym is free can't believe tom has
done this he thinks tom's the biggest
idiot alive and he says i'm just out of
here so it looks like twain is
frustrated too
so if you want that positive parable you
can't have that ending because the
ending reverses everything that came
before
but the thing about huck finn is it was
written at a time where american race
relations actually were taking a
backward step where the promise of
reconstruction from 1865 to 1877
was towards biracial governments was
towards enfranchising more and more
people um and that from 1877 to 1884 or
five you had this retrenchment um where
there was a prison boom that put a
tremendous number of african-americans
behind bars there were
disenfranchisement efforts there were
the first wave of jim crow laws
mark twain starts writing huckleberry
finn at 1876 when hope is high he
finishes writing it in 1884 when hope is
low
and the last third of that book reflects
and satirizes the retrenchment and
failure of the promise of early
reconstruction and if you look at it
that way the ending is exactly what it
should be
but with that case it's a challenge to
all of us to realize that race relations
is not easy
that you have to do something more than
swear in private you're going to help
another human being you have to do
something publicly too but that the
society bends another direction and that
it's going to take a long time so the
book ends pessimistically and if you
look at it that way then it's exactly
the ending it should be
um about hemingway i did read somewhere
that he did say about fitzgerald that he
was the greatest talent of his
generation
so um but my question is about um you
mentioned fitzgerald as a fan of
shakespeare do you see nick as horatio
and gatsby as hamlet telling the story
of his best friend
that's
that's nice nice spin i'll have to
include that in in the next edition
[Laughter]
i mean this this is what i love about
talking about gatsby and and i'm sure
andrew i know you've had the same
experience talking about huck finn i
mean the conversation continues and
each we both teach our beloved books as
as well as um you know andrew teaches
gatsby i don't i don't teach huck finn
as much as you teach gatsby but
every time i read gatsby with a class
pretty much every time there's something
new that comes out of that discussion
with the students um
sure why not i guess the only thing that
would trouble me about that equation is
that i don't see gatsby as tortured as
as hamlet is
um gatsby
even at the end of the novel right bef
you know right before his death as nick
is retelling the story
when he's seen after myrtle's death
gatsby is
walks outside the buchanan mansion at
night he's keeping vigil he wants to
make sure that tom isn't going to hurt
daisy um in retribution for myrtle's
death
and
it it turns out
he and nick look through the window and
there are daisy and tom sharing a dinner
of cold chicken together and drinking
beer and looking like they're conspiring
there's no need to keep a vigil over
daisy
she and tom understand each other
they're both
as the book says careless people who
hurt people other people and things and
leave leave a mess and expect other
people to clean up the mess for them
after gatsby sees that he gets busy
trying to rationalize what he sees oh
she was just playing along with him oh
you know she she doesn't really love him
not not the way she loves me you know he
keeps rationalizing so i don't see
gatsby
as
being as
tortured by thought as hamlet is
gatsby wants to be single-minded with
that idealization of of daisy until the
very end
otherwise it works
now both of you allude to uh the role
that these novels play
in the curriculum and and in a kind of
formative stage of students
um i i ask as the father of a 12 year
old son with a fonus for
post-apocalyptic novels
is he ready for gatsby is he ready for
huck fan
because he's 12 years
uh
yeah
i i have a 12 year old son too with the
exact same about we talking about the
exact same novels
and if you want to do a video game
comparison later i bet
we do well too i wouldn't recommend a
hug finn at that age just yet
um russell baker famously said that huck
finn is best appreciated by people who
are 25 or older and then 35 or older
even better
and even then someone who has a
foreknowledge of american culture
and
from that point of view it then becomes
an absolute road map to the country and
its history and its culture
think and david bradley has famously
described it as a power tool in terms of
teaching which is to say it's very
powerful and very dangerous
um i think that kids got to be older and
you gotta you have to work really hard
and really self-consciously don't have
hot fin land properly
12 i would say is too young
we we encounter gatsby as we do huck
finn oftentimes in high school
and that was one reason i wanted to go
back to my old high school which is in
astoria which is in the landscape of the
novel um to find out what what students
think about it the first time they read
it
i did learn something from that visit
you know i've been for years saying oh
we read gatsby too young you can't
identify with nick's voice of regret and
longing when you're
15 16 years old
but the kids in the classrooms of my old
high school showed me
of course there's a gatsby for when
you're younger and a gatsby for when
you're older
they really identified with gatsby
rather than nick they didn't like nick
they thought nick was a sellout they
thought the fact that nick shakes tom
buchanan's hand at the end of the novel
was unforgivable
but they identified with gatsby that
over-the-top-ness that i'll do anything
you know to reach this goal
whether it's a green light or being rich
or something you can't even name which
is what daisy stands in for we're told
at the end of the novel i'll do anything
to get there
they also very much identified with
fitzgerald when i told them that daisy
was modeled on fitzgerald's first love
in part geneva king
whose father was very wealthy lived in
chicago and her mansion in chicago
looked like a small department store
when fitzgerald went to visit her and he
was about 18 years old
um
as the story goes ginevra's father said
in fitzgerald's hearing
poor boys shouldn't think of marrying
rich girls and he was wounded to the
quick
the kids in high school you know you
could hear the audible gasp because
they're still at that age where they
kind of have to please somebody's
parents or you know perform for
somebody's parents so
they identified with parts of the novel
that at least for me have receded a bit
in in the background and
i love that they that they were on
gatsby's side and and that all all or
nothingness
the one thing i wanted to to say while i
still have andrew here is um
i feel like you've got the great
american novel of
the rural america and i've got the great
american novel
you know of
of 1925
of urban america the 1920s census is
when
we see for the first time that most
americans live in cities
and i haven't i have that album of james
taylor and carol king and duet and i
kind of feel like i'm carole king
singing the city part and you're james
taylor with the country part i should be
selected but you know i mean
i'm a little bit country
we are unfortunately out of time so
we'll have to let the
pop music reference take us out
you can purchase copies of huck fins
americas and so we read on and have them
signed upstairs help join please join me
in thanking our
fantastic dad
oh thank you very much
c-span is in asheville to feature its
literary history up next we visit the
grove park inn to learn about f scott
fitzgerald's time at the hotel
f scott fitzgerald came to the grove
park inn in 1935 it was his first visit
here he came here to cure himself of his
gin addiction in 1935 asheville was
still a very very small town it was a
manufacturing town people came to
asheville still a little bit for a
recuperation it had begun
that reputation in the 1900s when we had
about 900 tuberculosis recovery beds
here in asheville north carolina so this
was a place of respite recovery it was a
place where you came to escape the
hustle and bustle of the city and f
scott fitzgerald did just that he
actually came to asheville to kind of
recapture his muse he needed to get away
this was post-riding gatsby of course so
fitzgerald was actually a little bit
passe people passed him on the streets
people saw him here in the dining room
and didn't even acknowledge him they
didn't even recognize him esco
fitzgerald was tired
he was beaten up by his glamorous life
he was very lonely at the time zelda had
been diagnosed with some
mental disorders and he was really
confused he had lost his writing career
by this point he came to asheville and
really was just looking for a place to
belong a place to recover a place to
rest but he came here most importantly
to again to recover that muse he wanted
to write again but he needed something
to write about so when he came to the
grove park inn he wanted to find stories
and the people that were staying here
here we are in the palm court the grove
park inn and we are here at the f scott
fitzgerald rooms 441 and 443 this is
where he stayed in 1935 and 36 one room
for riding one room for sleeping
come on in
take a look around now while it is not
exactly as it was when f scott stayed
here we keep it very similar to the way
that it was uh one just to honor our
history of over a hundred years but two
people come here specifically with the
knowledge that if scott has been in this
room and in 443 and they want to
experience it very
much in the way that he did or as close
to it as possible
in 1935 he was quite a bit of trouble he
was here to cure himself of his gin
addiction using the beer cure so he was
drinking 56 little pony beers a day
which is basically a case of beer
so whether or not he was actually cured
of that gin addiction is really only
known by him
but in 35 he caused quite a stir he had
an affair while he was here in fact he
chose these rooms not to overlook the
mountains which one would think you'd
want to look at the beautiful mountains
to be inspired but instead he chose two
rooms that overlooked the courtyard
these rooms
as they look over the courtyard he could
see young women
coming in he wanted to note the caliber
of their luggage
how much luggage they were carrying and
whether or not they were chaperoned uh
he did this so that he could see
who he could talk to and well again he
was here to reclaim his muse so he
wanted to make sure that he was talking
with uh individuals that let's say could
um entertain him and provide him with
stories fitzgerald was a bit of a
philanderer and made no excuses about it
and was pretty open about it at the time
it is rumored that in 1935 he started an
affair with a woman here thinking that
when her husband arrived it would be a
huge battle and they would fight and it
would be something great to write about
it would be exciting it would kick him
into this like great story that he'd be
able to share in an essay or in a short
story and so he started this affair the
husband arrives and is
not really concerned about what his wife
has been doing this child is enraged
because the husband isn't angry and so
there is no fight so he stamps back into
his room and discharges a pistol into
the ceiling
of the room it is uh not let's say some
of his best uh work if you will he also
fell in 1935 uh it is said
that he fell in the pool and broke his
collarbone but we have it on pretty good
authority that he fell going into the
bathroom missed that step and broke his
collarbone simply because again remember
he was drinking about 56 pony beers a
day doing this beer cure that he had uh
invented and he missed that step he
caused so much trouble in 35 when he
wanted return in 1936
we only admitted him
back to the property if he was
chaperoned and he was chaperoned by a
nurse in 1936 when he came back to the
property f scott brought zelda
to asheville in 1936 to admit her to
highlands hospital highlands hospital
was located in montford which is a mile
from here he wanted to keep her nearby
and keep an eye on her he would bring
her here in 1936 to have lunch in the
plantation dining room and people would
walk right past them and he was angry
but also somewhat sad
again he was here to kind of find
himself find that muse again and he
thought in some ways since he didn't
find it in 35 he thought by bringing
zelda here to asheville north carolina
that maybe having the two of them
together they could find that but really
it was a little bit far gone for him so
in 36 he did come here he did stay with
us again but he spent much more time
writing in fact we saw him a lot less in
1936 because he was actually writing
again he had a secretary come with him
she would type up all of the notes that
he would make and he wrote everything
out on pads and longhand and then turn
those over to her to type out so 36 was
a much better time for fitzgerald here f
scott fitzgerald was working on several
essays while he was here now we don't
know exactly what ones they were but we
do know this is the beginning of when
he's starting to come back and he's
starting to actively write by 36 he's
spending hours and hours in his room
writing and getting his feet back under
him in fact people often say that this
was the time where fitzgerald was going
to
bring have a comeback if you will a
literary comeback and he starts actually
getting published again
we don't know for sure that those are
the essays that were written here but we
do know he was actively writing and he
was starting that essay process here at
the grove park inn f scott fitzgerald
left the grove park inn in 1936 he left
as the fall began
the temperatures began to cool and he
left us again he was starting to write
by this point he was reclaiming that
news really accomplishing what he had
intended to do here
unfortunately fitzgerald did not return
to us and four years later he does pass
of a heart attack in 1940.
we truly believe that the grove park inn
offered f scott fitzgerald exactly what
he was looking for a place to rediscover
himself uh whether or not he actually
cured himself of his gin addiction i
don't think anyone knows that but him
however we do know he was being much
more
productive when he was here so we're
very happy that f scott found what he
was looking for here at the grove park
inn which is maybe a little bit more of
himself
author and poet carl sandberg won three
pulitzer prizes